Hallo, moin
Leute, ich hab nicht ausgeschlafen
Aber das macht nix
Deswegen machen wir jetzt die Aufwachen-Stream
Es ist warm, wirklich
Geht so
Deck
Wetter-Check-In
12 Grad, Keck-Weight
Ist nicht warm
Nochmal Home Assistant gucken, Wetter
13 Grad, stop
Ist nicht warm
Es ist nicht warm
Omega-Lul
Ich finde meinen Chat nicht mehr
Achso, das ist warm
Ach, jetzt versteh ich's, okay
Achso
Adam regnet
Hier ist so gemischt, aber zum größten Teil
Wolken, ja, zum Glück war gestern nochmal
Gescheit-Wetter, konnte ich wieder
Bisschen Wander-Stells machen
Leute, ihr werdet es nicht glauben, ich hab den Label-Champ
Gestern Off-Stream
Weiter-Programmiert und hab wahrscheinlich mehr hingekriegt
Als in drei Streams zusammen
Wir haben jetzt, vielleicht machen wir am Mittag weiter
Wir haben jetzt sogar
Ähm
Crit-Lines, wo die
Wo die ganzen Elemente
Zusammensnappen können und sowas
Wenn ihr nicht dabei wart, wisst ihr wahrscheinlich nicht
Wovon ich rede, aber wer dabei wart, kann sich vielleicht
Vorstellen
Also sowas hier, guck mal
Ich zeige euch das mal schnell
Was ich meine, auch wenn es komplett keiner checkt
Wahrscheinlich, der sich den Stream nicht angeguckt hat
Aber, guck mal, sowas
Sowas kann mein Programm, ich kann solche
Jetzt nicht zeigen, weil ich hab den Source-Code nicht hier
Aber können wir uns heute Mittag angucken
Guck mal, sowas kann der Label-Champ jetzt auch
Hä?
Wait a minute
Warum snap? Hä?
Moment, warum snappt das nicht zusammen?
Normalerweise kann das
Können die das?
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen hab ich das
Gesnapper ausgeschaltet, hä?
Can't wait
Normalerweise snappen die Dinger zusammen
Ihr wisst, was ich meine, oder? Also, hä?
Hab ich das ausgeschaltet?
Dass der Kram snappt?
Ah, Snapping
Ja, guck mal, das kann mein Programm jetzt auch
So Dinger hier
Snappen
So wie hier
Komm, können wir uns heute Mittag angucken
Wie ist die Geschichte mit den Reifen ausgegangen?
Noch gar nicht
Ich lass das am Montag machen, ich brauch mein Auto ja eigentlich so gut wie nie
Ich hab gedacht, bevor ich da jetzt noch in der Weltgeschichte rumfahr
Und, ähm
Ja, irgendwie noch bei 5 Dingern anrufe oder so
Was ist das?
Mach ich das einfach mal Montag, gut ist
Dienstag brauch ich's vielleicht
Je nachdem
Aber ich fahr wahrscheinlich Dienstag nach Frankfurt mit dem Zug
Aber die Sommerferien, äh, Osterferien sind rum, glaub ich, ne?
Sind die Osterferien rum? Nächste Woche, Leute
Hessen Osterferien
Die sind rum
Bis
Schulferien in Hessen
Zeig mal
Die sind rum
Ah, die sind schon rum!
Die sind schon rum, nächste Woche, na, ob ich dann...
Ja, ich fahr mit dem Zug
Naja, ist egal
Ja, richtig
WonkaDB
Da wär das passende Emote für
Ah, hm
Also
Soll ich euch mal was sagen, Chat?
Ich hab heut Morgen schon gleich wieder richtig
Woke gemacht
Ich hab nämlich im Bett
Den Satz versteht auch außerhalb von Twitch keiner
Ähm
Also ich bin von so
Ich bin von so zu so gegangen, ungefähr
Weil
Ich hab heut Morgen Handy aufgemacht
Und das erste YouTube Video, was ich empfohlen bekommen habe, ist
Neuerungen in
Und jetzt haltet euch fest
C++
Da hab ich mir gedacht, nee
Ich guck mir jetzt kein 53 Minuten Video an
Zu was für komische, wirre Sachen sie wieder gemacht haben
Und ich bin auf die ganz schlechte Idee gekommen
Und hab mir folgende Seite angeguckt
Und danach hab ich mir wieder gedacht
Nooo, God!
No, God, please, no!
Als ich hier drüber gescrollt hab
Ist mir mal wieder aufgefallen
Was für ein absolutes Shitfest C++ ist
Chat, wer von euch
C++ Kenner
Wer von euch kennt C++?
Wer von euch kennt den Unterschied
Jetzt ohne Google, Google kann nicht auch
Und ich weiß den Unterschied mittlerweile auch
Wer kennt den Unterschied zwischen
Standard Basic String
Und Standard String
Warum gibt es da überhaupt verschiedene Sachen?
Na ich mein den Unterschied zwischen Standard Basic String
Und Standard Basic String View
Den kann ich mir im Kopf ja noch zusammenbauen
Das eine ist quasi eine Art Pointer
Auf Teile vom String
Und das andere ist ja die Zeichenkette selbst
Aber warum gibt es Standard String
Und warum gibt es Standard Basic String?
Ich kenne keine Programmiersprache
Außer C++
Die sowas hat
Ich versteh's nicht
Also doch, ich versteh's
Soll ich euch's erklären?
Soll ich euch sagen, was der Unterschied ist?
Soll ich euch sagen, warum es Standard Basic String
Und Standard String braucht?
Also
Für alle C++ Pros und die, die es werden wollen
Standard Basic String
Ist ein Template
Und
Standard String
Ist ein
Standard Basic String für Character
Also quasi
Das da
Ist quasi
Das was man
Als Alias oder Standard String findet
Warum?
Ich weiß es nicht
Also ich weiß es schon, aber ich versteh nicht, warum man das so macht
Das ist, dass man eigene Stringtypen definiert
Aber was braucht man denn eigene String?
Ganz im Ernst, wozu
Braucht man 20 verschiedene Stringtypen
Eigene Stringtypen
Das braucht man doch nur
Weil der in C++ eingebaute Standard String
Absoluter Bullshit ist
Was
Was ist Unicodes in 2022
Beziehungsweise was ist UTF-8
Genau
Du brauchst das
Und um verschiedene Encodings abzubauen
Aber das könnte man alles anders machen
Wenn man unter dem Hut den Standard String handelt
Damit muss ich mich überhaupt nicht auseinandersetzen
Wenn man es ordentlich macht
Aber C++ ist nicht ordentlich
Das muss man sich abschminken
Weiß gar nicht, warum ich mich drum kümmern soll
Warum es mich überhaupt interessieren soll
Als Entwickler
Ich mein
Wenn man das irgendwo in den Untiefen
In irgendwelchen Interface Namespaces
Was auch immer versteckt
Dass es in irgendwelchen krassen Sonderfällen geht
Okay
Wenn man das in C++
Jeder seinen komischen eigenen Stringtyp hat
Ganz ganz eklig Leute
Ganz eklig
Und ernsthaft
Wenn ihr euch das hier durchlest
Und ich hab
Ich bin kein Profi C++ Programmierer
Das will ich auch nicht werden
Weil dann dreh ich wahrscheinlich durch im Kopf
Aber ich hab schon
Nicht gerade wenig C++ gemacht
Gerade seitdem ich die letzten paar Jahre angefangen hab
Microcontroller Zeug zu programmieren
Hab sicherlich schon einige
Ja hunderte Stunden
Mit C++ rumgemacht
Trotzdem bin ich natürlich weit davon
Ein Fan der krasse C++ Checker zu sein
Aber trotzdem so ein bisschen
Kenn ich mich da auch aus
Ich würde sagen ich kenn mich sogar halbwegs brauchbar aus
Ganz okay
Aber wenn ich mir das hier durchlese
Dieses Dokument zu neuen Features
In C++
Fällt mir auf
Dass 90% der Features
Absolut nichts sagt
Und ich keine Ahnung hab
Was die uns damit sagen wollen
Ich mein das versteh ich jetzt noch
Es gibt jetzt sizeT quasi auch signed und unsigned
Alles in Ordnung
Es gibt Contains
By the way String Contains gab es anscheinend noch nicht
Contains in einem Standard String Typ
Wir sind aber in C++
Da ist das normal
Du konntest ja in C++ lange Zeit nicht mal
String to Upper to Lower Case machen
Eingebaut
In der String
Da muss ich mal überlegen
Ich hatte bis zur letzten Version
Keinen
Offiziellen
To Upper Case
Also String in Großbuchstaben
Und in Kleinbuchstaben umwandeln
Außer über Umwege mit extra Schleife und sowas
Muss ich mir mal vorstellen
So
Und die anderen Sachen checkt
Kein Mensch mehr
Okay Stacktrace
Typetrade
Standard ist scoped ina
Was auch immer
So
Irgendwelche
Iterator wo eh kein Mensch versteht
Wie man
Iterator in C++ gescheit implementiert
Dann haben sie die
Requirements relaxed
To time point lock
Alles klar
Standard visit
Standard variant was auch immer
Das ist übrigens mein Lieblings Change
Locks lock lockables
Iterator
Zwei
Nein
Denn
case und dann kannst du kannst du case insensitiv suchen also dass das ist aber übrigens hier meine
meine lieblings änderung loks lok locke bills 10 plus 23 standard alles klar zwar bescheid müssen
sich programmiert ja müssen sie ja gut wenn es danach geht könnten wir doch alles im vortrag
programmieren müssen sie schon es ergeben sich immer wieder neue sachen beispielsweise so die
letzten paar jahre ist der trend oder geht der trend finde ich gerade dahin dass du die
oldschool programmiersprachen gerade die noch aus der zeit kommen wo objektorientierung ist
das beste überhaupt also gerade wenn man sich was ich hab anguckt dass das immer mehr einschläge von
funktionalen sachen bekommt guck dir beispielsweise mal irgendwelche neue pattern match oder guck dir
mal generell go an go ist viel funktionaler als das beispielsweise java oder sich ab ist obwohl
es noch in obwohl es neuer ist das ist so ein mischmasch
also ja ich finde schon in go hat letztens generics bekommen ich meine wie konnte man das überhaupt
wie konnte man überhaupt ohne leben also natürlich muss ich das weiterentwickeln ich muss aber sagen
dass microsoft finde ich ziemlich gut eine gute balance findet bei c sharp was neuerungen angeht
die sind meistens sinnvoll nicht alle manche dann bräuchte ich nicht aber die meisten sind sinnvoll
so wie scroll noch mal kurz drüber dass ihr euch den wahnsinn mal angucken können also
ich würde mir diese den sehr schöne Jeroboam
das ist alles gut einfach so können wir den so das ist das es ist genau so sie haben das mit der
c++ 23 std lock lock lock lock lock lukke bis alles klar wir gucken zwar schneller wie das aussieht das war auf so sieht es aus moment beispiel example lockt text type adopt lockte was gibt es ein beispiel für eher sogar dieser standard ist abfang mäßig dass du nicht verstehst was er will was zum
sowieso, wissen wir. Conditional
Borrow Ranges, okay, to underline,
was auch immer. So, es gibt noch mehr.
Und ab jetzt wird's richtig abgedreht.
Const
eval if, if const eval,
alles klar, das ist irgendwelche Compile-Time-Checker.
Ähm,
das Bool sich automatisch konvertiert.
Äh, Standard
Span gibt es jetzt, ein String-Based
Span-Stream. Ich hab das Gefühl,
die führen random immer neue Sachen in die Standard-Library
ein, hier in C++-Standard, und es dauert
15 Jahre, bis die ganzen Compiler das... Ach ja,
wir haben jetzt übrigens, wir haben jetzt übrigens
Standard-Out-Pointer und Standard-In-Pointer.
Als wäre Standard-
Pointer, Unique-Pointer,
Shared-Pointer, Left-
Reference, Right-Reference,
L-Type, Right-Type,
was auch immer, nur nicht kompliziert genug.
Eigentlich ist sie
Sharp für Anfänger, jo.
Da hab ich ziemlich gute Einsteiger-Sprache.
Dann kannst du, was weiß ich,
Compile-Zeilen checken noch für Optional-Variant
und für Standard-
Type-Info-Operator gleich gleich
alles.
Ist klar. So, du kannst jetzt
den neuen Konstruktor für den Standard-Stake, Standard-Q
ähm, Range-Changes,
das mag ja durchaus okay sein.
Ähm, man darf jetzt
aus einem Null-Pointer keinen Basic-String
mehr machen. Muss ich vorstellen, das war vorher möglich,
ja. Standard-Format, das ist
das einzig Gute, was es in C++ gibt.
Ohne Scheiß, Leute,
die Format-Library, die
noch fast keinen Compiler komplett implementiert hat,
weil es C++ ist, ist das einzig Gute
oder eines der wenig guten Sachen an C++.
Und wisst ihr auch, warum das gut ist?
Weil sie es komplett aus Python
geklaut haben.
Das sagt der Typ.
Das sagt der Autor dieser Library
sogar.
Was aber auch okay ist,
weil das, wie du vorher Strings formatiert hast
in C++, war ja absolut abfuck.
Ich mein, die haben, guck mal, man muss sich mal überlegen,
man hat jahrelang in C++, so hat
man Strings formatiert.
Muss ich mir vorstellen.
2022, Alter.
Also, Standard-Format ist wirklich ganz gut.
Es ist ja, es hat übrigens,
es hört übrigens noch nicht auf.
Das lese ich euch jetzt nicht vor, weil spätestens das
checkt keiner mehr.
Es checkt niemand mehr.
Decay-Copy in Language Auto mit geschweiften
Klammern X oder Auto in Eckisch.
Was? Keine Ahnung.
Du kannst den Multidimensional
Subscript Operator
kannst du, kannst du overloaden.
Alles klar, wollte ich schon immer mal machen.
Ja, du kannst Alias-Declaration
Init-Statements machen. Init-Statements
ist der Kram, weil man sich gedacht hat,
Constructor sind zu dumm.
Also das da, das da ist ein Init-Init-Statement.
Und, und das ist, wenn man den, also mit Auto nicht,
aber wenn ich die Klasse so anlege,
dann ist es der Constructor.
Und wenn ich das so anlege, ist es der Init,
ist es der Init-Dings, was auch immer.
Ja, man kann jetzt, mehr Pre-Prozessor hat die Welt
auch gebraucht und dann hat man solche schönen Dinger.
Ich meine, alleine schon, dass man sowas reinschreiben
muss in seine Dokumentation, weiß man doch,
da ist irgendwas nicht richtig, oder?
Standard-Basic-Stack-Straight-Standard-PMR-Polymorphic-Allocator.
Was?
Warum steht das da überhaupt drin?
So, Range-Library, das lass ich mir noch gefallen.
Standard-Move-Only.
Monadic-Operations-to-Standard-Optional.
Standard-Basic-String-Resize-and-Override.
Aber jetzt kann man, äh, Volatile-Pointer-Printen.
Byte-Swap.
Heterogenes-Löschen-von-Overloads.
Alles klar.
Standard-Span.
Es, es ist jetzt, okay, Leute, Leute.
Standard-Span und Standard-Basic-String, wir sind jetzt einfach,
zu kopieren.
Trivial-Copyable.
Standard-Exchange, was auch immer.
Standard-Expected-Konstexprifotz.
Alles klar.
Leute, äh, also, das ist schon teilweise sinnig, ja?
Gerade die Sachen für Ranges und Format.
Aber der Rest ist einfach noch mehr verwirrenden Kram auf noch mal verwirrenden Kram,
in der Hoffnung, man macht es weniger verwirrend.
Was aber nicht passiert.
Was verdient so ein Informatiker Studium oder Ausbildung netto so Mitte 30 auf einer Wirtschaft,
wenn man durch den, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh.
Alter.
Dabei ist eigentlich mit dem Hals wieder besser.
Ja, ich wurde heute quasi aus dem Schlaf gerissen,
weil ich ein Video empfohlen bekommen habe, als ich heute Morgen auf YouTube geguckt habe.
Zum ersten Mal, also, zu, zu, zu, zum ersten Mal ein Video zu C++23.
Ja, äh, dazu, Heise hat Gehaltsumfragen.
Und das kann man pauschal nicht beantworten, weil,
du kannst dir auch mal ein Video dazu angucken, oder die Videos dazu angucken.
Ähm, das hängt ganz entscheidend davon ab, wo du, in welcher Branche du bist, ähm,
was du für, ähm, Erfahrungen hast, in welchem Bereich,
und vor allem halt auch, in welcher Stadt und in welcher Region.
Und beim Arbeit, das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Durchschnittsmäßig kannst du, wie gesagt, sind die, sind die Gehaltsreports bei Heise nicht schlecht,
es gibt aber auch noch mehr.
Ist eine Karriere nach dem Bachelorstudium ein Infanter?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wo soll ich das wissen?
Ich war nicht bei der Bundeswehr.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wenn die aber bezahlen, wie die meisten Ämter,
dann ist das erstmal nicht so geil.
Aber, das habe ich letztens bei Algorithmen verstehen in einem Video gelernt,
wenn man eine Weile dabei bleibt,
und dann irgendwie, also, wenn man höhere Gehaltsstufen und höhere Erfahrungsstufen hat,
äh, ne, ja doch, ne, wenn man höhere Gehaltsstufen und höhere Betriebs-, oder Amtsstufen hat,
dann wird das ganz in Ordnung.
Ich meine, du wirst wahrscheinlich dort nie so viel verdienen,
wie, äh, wenn du einen richtig, richtig guten Job hast,
der auch richtig gut bezahlt wird in der freien Wirtschaft,
aber es ist durchaus in Ordnung.
Und der große Vorteil anscheinend ist,
wenn du durchschnittlich ambitioniert bist,
wie es gerade jemand geschrieben hat,
ähm, dann ist es wahrscheinlich bei einem Amt gar nicht so schlecht,
deswegen treffen sich und tummeln sich da wahrscheinlich auch viele durchschnittlich motivierte,
oder ambitionierte, also wäre eigentlich genau das Richtige für mich,
weil du musst, du, du kriegst quasi mehr Geld durch nichts machen,
einfach nur da sein.
Was auch nicht verkehrt ist.
Ansonsten bei der Bundeswehr, keine Ahnung.
Aber ich will aus Prinzip nicht zur Bundeswehr.
Weiß nicht.
Okay.
Stell mir das irgendwie nicht so als, ähm, gerade, also,
gerade in der IT, irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht.
Da hat für mich nie zur, äh, Diskussion gestanden,
selbst ob ich zur Bundeswehr gehe oder nicht.
Ne, mach ich nicht.
Und wo wir gerade dabei sind, investieren, Leute.
Die China-Chinesen haben zugeschlagen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Letzte Woche, meine, meine Stonks.
Erinnert ihr euch noch, wo ich gesagt habe, es ist schon ein Skalierungsfehler?
Ne, ne, es ist kein Skalierungsfehler.
Und wahrscheinlich geht das montags gleich so weiter.
Stonks gehen Bash ab.
Not, not Stonks.
Was ist passiert?
Die China-Chinesen lassen keine Schiffe mehr nach Shanghai rein.
Musstest du noch Grundwehrdienst machen?
Ja.
Hätte ich machen müssen.
Sag ich gleich, was du.
Hafen Shanghai.
Guck, da gibt's doch dieses.
Ja, das ist, das ist übrigens nicht, nicht die, äh, Battlefield 2042 Map.
Da gibt's doch hier das da.
Guck mal, da sieht man, wie die Schiffe sich stauen.
Das ist richtig heftig.
Alle Schiffe.
So.
Was, wo musstest du dich durchbeißen?
Ja, meine Moti, also ist meine Motivation jetzt ultra krass hoch.
Das ist normal.
Was hat er denn geschrieben?
Um, um was ging's denn bei euch hier?
Ach so.
Ah, Motivation sein.
Ja, also ganz ehrlich, meine Motivation hält sich teilweise auch in Grenzen.
Vor allem immer dann, wenn meine Woche zu 70 Prozent aus irgendwelchem Gemiete besteht.
Leute, ich sag, ich lese euch, ich lese euch das mal kurz vor.
Ich mach mal kurz mein, mein Kalender auf.
Ich muss es aber leider ein bisschen, ein bisschen, äh, anonymisieren.
So.
Letzte Woche.
Letzte Woche, warte mal.
Letzte Woche, ging's echt?
Letzte Woche Dienstag, ja.
Dokumentationsmeeting.
Change, Changeboard.
Äh, Teambesprechung, täglicher Austausch.
So, und das alles Vormittag.
Das heißt, ich hab Vormittag im Prinzip bis 13.30 Uhr nix gemacht.
So.
Äh, Rücksprachemeeting, Daily Meeting, täglicher Austausch.
Äh, noch weitere, weitere Gruppenrufe.
Ähm, Server-Config-Meeting, Stand-up, ähm, oh, das hab ich vergessen.
Da war ich nicht.
Doch, da war ich, da war ich.
Da hab ich mich anscheißen lassen, hab ich Anschiss gekriegt auf dem Meeting.
Stimmt, ich weiß es noch.
Stand-up.
Das, muss man sich mal vorstellen, ne.
Ich, ich, ich bin in die, ich, ich steh in diesem Stand-up-Meeting.
Ich stehe nicht, ich sitze, weil ich daheim im Homeoffice bin.
Ähm, ich bin da.
Und da meint der Chef, der dieses, oder der Typ, der dieses, das, das Meeting, Meeting führt, meinte so zu mir, ähm, ja, Max, dann fang mal an.
Und da hab ich gesagt, ja, also, wie's, wie's schon im Protokoll steht, gibt nix, gibt nix Interessantes, ja.
Und da hab ich erst mal einen Anschiss gekriegt, warum ich das nicht richtig im Protokoll eingetragen hab, dass es nix gibt.
Ich mein doch, ja, da steht ja nix im Protokoll drin.
Ja, nee, aber das ist falsch.
Man muss die Standardpunkte löschen und reinschreiben.
Keine neuen Punkte.
Über solche Sachen regen wir uns da auf, ja.
Also, das ist halt Business, Business Enterprise.
Ist aber nicht wild, ja.
Also, also, das, äh, mich nervt das nicht persönlich oder so.
Ah, das, das, das sind halt so Probleme, die man nur in der Business Strongs Enterprise Welt hat, ja.
Ja, also, meine Motivation ist auch nicht sonderlich hoch, wenn ich Anschüsse kriege und, und, wenn ich, ähm,
so viel mieten muss die ganze Zeit.
Das find ich auch nicht so geil.
Oder, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was mich auch unglaublich demotiviert?
Worin frägt ihr eure Punkt Confluence?
Ähm, was wollt ich denn jetzt sagen?
Wisst ihr, ich, ich, ich wollt, ich, ich hab angefangen, wisst ihr, was mich auch immer ultra demotiviert?
Achso, ja, ich weiß wieder.
Wisst ihr, was mich auch ultra demotiviert?
Wenn die Leute vergessen oder wenn, sag ich mal, das Unternehmen, wo ich arbeite, vergisst,
was für eine Position ich eigentlich hab, also als was ich eingestellt bin.
Wie ich das meine ist, naja, ich bin ja da als, nennen wir es mal so ganz grob die Kategorie,
ich bin ja da als Techniker.
Ich bin da nicht als Management oder Organisator.
Ich, ich bin weder dafür verantwortlich, irgendwelche Abläufe zu planen, noch bin ich irgendwie dafür verantwortlich,
irgendwelche Projekte, Sachen zu koordinieren oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen einzuteilen.
Dafür haben wir Leute.
Aber, ähm.
Man vergisst das immer öfters, dass man dafür Leute hat, hab ich den Eindruck.
Weil die letzten, letzten Jahre über kommt das schon immer so, dass, dass die total oft irgendwelchen Technikern zusätzlich noch massig organisatorische Sachen aufs Auge drücken wollen.
Ja.
Und zum Beispiel, wir hatten letztens Probleme mit Zertifikaten.
Lag nicht an uns.
Wir, also ganz grob an uns.
Wir, also ganz grob, abstrakt, sodass, dass ich nicht so viele Namen verrate.
Wir haben ein Zertifikat ausgewechselt.
Auf, auf einem Lautpalenzer.
Was abgelaufen wäre in 14 Tagen.
Also, da denkt man sich jetzt so, ja, eigentlich ja nichts Schlimmes, oder?
Weil der Kram läuft eh in 14 Tagen ab.
Also würde man, oder Chat?
Also, da würde ich jetzt eigentlich nichts Böses bei denken, ja.
Also es war vorher ein gültiges Zertifikat und es war danach auch ein gültiges Zertifikat.
Gar kein, gar kein Problem.
Haben wir ausgetauscht.
Und auf einmal morgens regt sich einer von unseren Mobile-Entwicklern wahnsinnig auf,
wie wir einfach nachts das Zertifikat austauschen können.
Wir haben das nicht einfach ausgetauscht.
Wir haben das auf unserer Change-Runde angekündigt.
Wir haben das in unserem Change-Log drinnen steht.
Außerdem läuft das Zertifikat in 14 Tagen ab.
Was sollen wir denn machen?
Das laufen lassen, bis es abläuft, oder?
Was ist das Prognose?
Was ist das Problem?
Und dann meint er, ja, seine Mobile-App geht jetzt nicht mehr.
Warst du denn auch im Cup?
Ja, wir haben auch ein Change-Advisory-Board.
Ähm, was sollen wir denn machen?
Sollen wir das ablaufen lassen, bis es komplett, bis alles abkackt, weil das Zertifikat?
So, und dann hat sich rausgestellt, seine App ist kacke programmiert.
Die haben in ihrer App nämlich, warum auch immer, fragt mich nicht, warum das so ist,
die checken in ihrer App nämlich, äh, nicht etwa...
Ist das Zertifikat gültig?
Ist das Ablaufdatum richtig und sowas?
Nein!
Die checken in ihrer App, ist der Aussteller des Zertifikats explizit diese Zertifizierungsstelle.
Und unsere neuen Zertifikate kommen von Let's Encrypt mittlerweile.
Die kommen nicht mehr von der alten Zertifizierungsstelle, die wir mal vor 5 Jahren viel Geld in Bobbes geschoben haben.
Die kommen mittlerweile von Let's Encrypt.
Und seine App ist abgekackt, weil das Zertifikat jetzt von Let's Encrypt kommt.
Nicht, weil es nicht gültig war oder so.
So, und dann haben die einen riesen, riesen Aufriss, riesen Aufriss gemacht.
Dann haben die einen riesen Aufriss gemacht, dass ihre App angeblich durch den Zertifikatstausch kaputt gegangen wäre.
Und da musste ich auf, oder ich sag mal ich, ich weiß, also ich persönlich war gar nicht da bei diesem einen Meeting jetzt,
aber ich weiß es, weil ich war vorher bei allen dabei war und mich danach erkundigt habe, was bei diesem einen rausgekommen ist.
Zu dem wollte ich auch nicht.
Und dann haben sie zig Retrospektiven gemacht, ja, und auf dem einen, wo ich nicht dabei war, wurde dann behauptet, so nach dem Motto,
wir sollen uns jetzt um die weitere Koordination kümmern, weil wir hätten es ja auch kaputt gemacht.
Und da hat dann glücklicherweise der Kollege plus noch zwei andere, die da waren, das klargestellt, dass, was es kaputt gemacht hat,
die bescheuerte Programmierung der App war.
Und nicht unser Zertifikatstausch, weil der Zertifikatstausch hätte stattfinden müssen, weil in 14 Tagen läuft es ab.
Und dann...
Und dann haben die allen Ernstes richtig, richtig rumgenervt, dass wir, also diejenigen, die die Technik gemacht haben,
des Loadbalancers-Konfigurierens im Endeffekt, dass wir jetzt koordinieren, wann sie ihre Tests der App machen sollen,
wann jetzt neue Zertifikate ausgestellt werden, wann jetzt irgendwo...
Nein, das machen wir nicht.
Dafür haben wir Leute, die sind dafür da, das zu koordinieren.
Die wollten da drauf bestehen.
Deswegen ärger...
Okay, da war ich dann nicht direkt dabei.
Aber ich habe dann die Nachwählen mitbekommen.
Und das ist so krass.
Was wollen die von uns eigentlich alle?
So haben wir aber nicht gemacht.
Haben wir nicht gemacht.
Glücklicherweise war dann irgendein Change-Koordinator dabei, der das übernommen hat.
Aber allein schon, dass man diese Diskussionen führen muss, fuckt mich immer richtig ab.
Ja, und was ich auch wieder gelernt habe, ist, es gibt kaum Leute auf der Welt, die ein bisschen checken, wofür Zertifikate da sind.
Das habe ich nämlich auch gemerkt.
Da hat ein Entwickler...
Ich würde sogar mal behaupten, das ist der Chef von der Mobile-Entwicklung.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube, das ist der Chef von der Mobile-Entwicklung.
Passt mal auf, wisst ihr, was der zu mir gesagt hat?
Der hat mir das erklärt, dass das nicht stimmt.
Der hat mir erklärt, dass das nicht stimmt.
Also ich habe ihm gesagt, wir müssen das Zertifikat tauschen.
In 14 Tagen läuft das Zertifikat ab.
Wenn das Zertifikat abläuft, da geht viel mehr nicht mehr, als nur unsere App.
Dann ist total komplett alles kaputt.
Fällt das auch unter Zertifikat-Pinning?
Ja, das ist sowas in der Richtung, genau.
Also da geht sehr viel kaputt, wenn das in 14 Tagen abläuft.
Und da hat er zu mir gesagt, ja wie jetzt?
Das läuft doch gar nicht in 14 Tagen ab.
Natürlich tauscht das Zertifikat dann aus, just for fun.
Das läuft in 14 Tagen ab.
Und da habe ich gemeint, nein, er hat eben gerade reingeguckt, das Zertifikat läuft 2050 ab.
Nein!
Nein, Gott, bitte nein!
Hat er beim Root-Zertifikat, korrekt.
Da hat sich das Root-Zertifikat von der CA angeguckt, das läuft 2050 ab.
Die haben keine Ahnung.
Die haben keinen Plan, was sie machen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man überhaupt eine lauffähige App mit solchen Leuten auf die Reihe kriegt.
Keine Ahnung.
Unglaublich.
Also, und das sich dann auch hinzustellen und das so zu verkaufen, als hat man voll den Durchblick.
Das regt mich unglaublich auf.
So.
Dann haben sie mich aber abge...
Ich wollte ja...
Ich wollte ja eigentlich sagen, nein, das ist ein anderes Zertifikat.
Haben sie mich...
So.
Zumindest...
Der Hit kam dann.
Die haben sich dann auf diesem...
Auf diesem Emergency-Meeting...
Ne, der hat sich nicht dumm gestellt, der meint das ernst.
Da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher.
So, auf diesem Emergency-Meeting haben sie gesagt, ja, dann tauschen wir jetzt...
Passt mal auf.
Wisst ihr, was die Problemlösung war?
Da haben sie gesagt, wir tauschen jetzt das Zertifikat wieder zurück.
Weil das läuft ja noch 14 Tage.
Und ich kenne unseren Laden.
Wenn wir jetzt das Zertifikat zurücktauschen, dann ist das Problem behoben.
Und niemand, keiner kümmert sich freiwillig darum, dass das Zertifikat ausgetauscht wird in den nächsten 14 Tagen.
Und wir laufen direkt auf, es geht kaputt zu.
Deswegen haben wir uns auch so dagegen gewehrt, dass wir das irgendwie koordinieren.
Und als sie das gesagt haben, da war dann der Abteilungsleiter...
Der Abteilungsleiter war dann dabei und hat gemeint, ja, wir tauschen das jetzt zurück.
Da habe ich dann gesagt im Meeting nochmal...
Also ich will jetzt nochmal darauf hinweisen, wenn wir das zurücktauschen, in 14 Tagen geht alles kaputt, wenn das Zertifikat ausgetauscht wird.
Ich will das bloß mal gesagt haben.
Und da habe ich in dem Meeting einen Anschluss bekommen, dass wir doch jetzt Probleme haben.
Und nicht in 14 Tagen.
Und dann habe ich mir gesagt, wisst ihr was, ihr könnt mich zwar, macht was ihr wollt.
Das habe ich nicht wörtlich gesagt, ja.
Aber ich habe gesagt, macht was ihr wollt.
Ihr tauscht aus.
Ist mir egal.
Solange wir das nicht koordinieren.
Ich koordiniere hier gar nichts.
Macht ihr mal.
Tja, angeblich wird am Montag jetzt das Zertifikat ausgetauscht.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Also, wir tauschen am...
Jetzt passt mal auf, jetzt haltet euch mal fest.
Die wollen am Montag das Zertifikat austauschen.
Und am Dienstag läuft das Zertifikat ab.
Das heißt, wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Wenn das nicht funktioniert aus irgendwelchen Gründen, ist am 26.
Komplett im Arsch.
Also, wenn ihr lest am 26., dass es bei irgendeiner Bank, bei irgendeiner Frankfurter Bank, großflächige Zertifikatsmeldungen gibt.
Dann sind wir bei Heise wahrscheinlich, ja.
Dann bin ich mal gespannt.
Also, wisst ihr, was ich dann sage?
Dann sage ich wirklich, ich habe es euch gesagt.
Also, ich habe das nicht nur...
Pass mal auf.
Ich habe das nicht nur in diesem Ursprungsmeeting gesagt.
Ich habe das an zig Dailies gesagt.
Ich habe das in der Retrospektive, in das Protokoll von der Retrospektive...
Also, ich habe dem Typ, der das Protokoll für die Retrospektive erstellt hat, das geschrieben.
Dem Typ, der die Retrospektive durchgeführt hat, geschrieben.
Und am Ende reingeguckt.
Also, es steht überall drin.
Mal mal gespannt.
Ja.
Solche Sachen.
Also, es ist wirklich der absolute Wahnsinn.
Ich bin eh begeistert, wie viele Leute so krass unfähig sind, in dem Beruf quasi, wo sie eigentlich Geld für bekommen.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ja, Montag habe ich frei.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Montag wird das Zertifikat getauscht.
Da passiert noch nichts.
Dienstags passiert was.
Aber Dienstags abends erst.
Das Zertifikat läuft, glaube ich, Dienstag um 18.30 Uhr oder so ab.
Oder 18 Uhr oder so.
Ich schicke den...
Wenn das passiert, schicke ich denen irgendein Rig-Roll-Video in Teams-Chat.
Ja.
Da sage ich dann hier...
Poste ich dann einen Link bei uns in Teams.
Hier, das müsst ihr machen, dass es wieder funktioniert.
Und dann...
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Habe ich das...
Ja.
Genau.
Ich poste einfach in Teams-Chat einen Link.
Hier, das müsst ihr machen, damit es wieder funktioniert.
Okay, ne.
Da schmeißen sie mich wahrscheinlich raus.
Egal.
Ich sage euch auf jeden Fall, ich habe es euch gesagt, wenn das in die Hose geht.
Auf der anderen Seite sollen sie es machen.
So.
Du bekommst so eine IT-Zulage bei Behörden 1, die Gliedernhöhle...
Ja, da kannst du dich nicht beschweren.
Vor allem, weil du ja anscheinend auch weniger Steuern bezahlen musst, wenn du bei irgendeinem...
Bundes...
Oder Länder oder sonst was Laden bist.
Ja.
Es ist tatsächlich dann ganz okay.
Aber ich würde es zum Beispiel nie kriegen.
Weil ich habe hier irgendwann mal vor 15 Jahren Fachinformatiker gelernt.
Und die haben mir gesagt...
Ja.
Habe ich gelesen
Ist ja auch so
Es wird deutlich zu viel gemietet
Toaster, danke für den Sub
Ja siehste, verstehe ich auch nicht
Die Leute müssen doch mal gucken
Wie kommt es denn dazu
Ich verstehe den Sinn nicht
Warum nimmt man denn, wenn man explizit
Projektmanager, Managerposition
Und sowas hat, warum lässt man denn
Dann nicht die Leute, die dafür da sind
Den Kram planen
Dafür hat man noch Projektmanager
Ich bin Techniker geworden, weil ich keine Projekte
Planen will, dass man da dran beteiligt
Ist, ja, oder auch mal seinen Senf
Zu irgendeiner Planung oder irgendeinem Ablauf gibt
Oder vielleicht auch mal sagt, ja am besten
Passt, wenn wir Samstag, die Wartung, irgendwie sowas
Da sag ich ja gar nichts gegen, ja
Das ist, das ist ja, das ist ja normal
Aber übergreifende Koordinierungssachen
Gar nicht, das ist überhaupt, das sag ich mittlerweile
Auch, ich seh das
Nicht einseh zu koordinieren
Wir haben Architekten dafür, wir haben
Projektmanager dafür, wir haben
Teamleiter, Abteilungsleiter
Sonstige Sachen für, die sind genau
Dafür da
Ich seh sich ein, dass man im Endeffekt alles
Machen muss und im Endeffekt dann auch alles irgendwie
Anschiss kriegt
Ja, man muss, man muss direkt sagen, nö, gibt's nicht
Weil ansonsten
Laden sie immer mehr bei einem ab
Glaube, ha, das
Damit kann ich mich, damit kann ich mich durchaus
Leute, Zingler
Ich, ich screenshotte dich mal kurz, dass du
Diese Chatnachricht muss ich am Montag
Mal unserem Zertifikatsmanagement schicken
Weil die haben im Endeffekt
Einfach nur zur Beruhigung
Dass sie wissen, es ist nicht nur bei uns so
Dabei
Wisst ihr was ich nicht verstehe
Warum gibt es bei Zertifikaten so viele Probleme
Normalerweise ist es auch so
Rein theoretisch mal gesehen
Wenn ich
Wenn ich ein Zertifikat ausstelle
Dann weiß ich
Oder wenn ich ein Zertifikat beantrage
Dann weiß ich zum Zeitpunkt
Wenn ich dieses Zertifikat nicht
bekomme schon wann es abläuft also eigentlich ist das mitbekommen weil ein zertifikat abläuft
müsste total easy sein ich weiß nicht warum wir uns da so schwer tun und ich weiß auch nicht
warum sich gott und die welt damit so schwer tut und ich weiß auch nicht warum sich monitoring
sachen damit so schwer tun ich verstehe das nicht und wir haben explizit ein komplettes team ist
okay sind nur drei leute oder so die sich um zertifikats handling kümmern sollen und trotzdem
fällt das teilweise zwei wochen vorher auch wenn überhaupt wenn überhaupt manchmal auch nur gar
nicht oder am gleichen tag oder so wir ja wir haben jetzt glücklicherweise zum größten teil
letzten kripp ja also na ja zum größten teil ist übertrieben wir haben jetzt zu einem aber
nicht unerheblich teil letzten kopf zum größten teil würde ich nicht sagen ich habe jetzt intern
zum ersten mal bei uns also wir haben ja für unsere cloud resource und so was haben wir schon
jede menge
letzten kript aber ich habe jetzt zum ersten mal die letzten zwei wochen intern letzten kript
verwendet bei uns für einen legacy dienst der nicht ssl fähig ist wollt ihr mal raten was das
ist chat was was meint ihr was könnte das sein ein legacy dienst der nicht ssl dass er selbst
nicht ssl bzw hat dls https fähig ist was könnte das sein und ein banking ist einfach mal mehr
drucker note a das ist noch gar nicht nah wobei ihr könnt nein es ist es ist auch keine als 400
müssen es lohnt ja also ampel anbieter nein ihr könnt ihr könnt es eigentlich nicht wissen aber
ihr hättet ihr hättet eine sache vermuten können wo ich dann gesagt hätte ist es richtig ja es ist
eine uralte java anwendung oder typ und das ist jetzt kein scherz
der typ der das programmiert hat ist in rente schon da ist der ist nicht mehr da und wisst ihr
was ich mitbekommen habe auch kein wird auch kein witz jetzt die haben bei einer störung
mit diesem service tatsächlich den typ in rente angerufen das hat ihn auch nicht gestört ich wäre
wahrscheinlich übelst abgefuckt ich würde jemand in der rente anrufen das hat ihn auch gar nicht
gestört da hat das denn dann alles erklärt zumindest das ding ist so
ultra legacy das ist das ist das ist schon fossil da muss man das kann man nicht legacy nennen ja so
zumindest die unsere unsere programmierer dudes hat er sich sicher bezahlen lassen wahrscheinlich
wobei ganz ehrlich vielleicht auch nicht weil vielleicht kennt ihr das von den unternehmen
wo ihr arbeitet aber jedes unternehmen erzählt sie sind die geilsten und die besten und führend
und sonst was das macht wahrscheinlich das unternehmen wo ihr seid auch
aber gerade im finanzdienstleistungssektor ist das noch mal ausgeprägter also die die huldigen
sich 24 7 selbst dass sie die geilsten überhaupt sind und viele bei uns habe ich zumindest den
eindruck die fallen darauf rein also die die sind die die glauben dass dann irgendwann selbst und
dementsprechend kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen dass es leute
gibt die sachen freiwillig umsonst machen weil das ja der der guten sache irgendwie hilft ja die
denken wirklich wir sind die guten ja es ist natürlich unglaublich wichtig dass man irgendeine
oma noch eine lebensversicherung verkauft oder so ja das ist so würde ich oder sonst was macht keine
ahnung was die genau treiben ich weiß ich bezweifle dass wir wirklich die guten sind letztendlich ist
mir aber auch egal weil so lange die mein gehalt pünktlich überweist die huckst mich nicht lustig
also naja
ich weiß gar nicht wo stehen geblieben bin ist auch egal ja ach so er letztendlich genau und da
haben wir ein uralt habe ich wieder ein uralt legacy java dienst gehabt der jetzt haltet euch
fest aus der cloud heraus angesprochen werden soll und er kann kein https beziehungsweise kann
hora s was hab ich gemacht ich habe ein eiservor
genommen da dann haben wir ja auch schon ein paar mal im stream verwendet habt
mir von den dns leuten api zugang für den escher dns geben lassen das ist
übrigens escher dns ist auch pain in the ass wir haben ja cloudflare schon mal
benutzt im stream das heißt habt ihr vielleicht wenn ihr dabei wart gesehen
cloudflare ist super easy cloudflare trägst du dein dann api ein stellst noch
ein wer was ändern darf und gut ist in escher brauchst du fünf verschiedene
credentials secrets id secrets tenant id project id was auch immer du brauchst
1000 sache dass es in escher überhaupt funktioniert zumindest kann er jetzt
letzter kripp zertifikate abrufen und der proxy dem endeffekt auf diesen legacy
java service und das ist der erste richtig automatisierte letzten kripp
nennen wir es mal
proxy den wir intern bei uns überhaupt haben und ich hoffe dadurch dass ich das
jetzt gemacht habe und dadurch dass wir jetzt auch zugangsdaten und alles haben
dadurch dass jetzt nicht jetzt mal das eis gebrochen ist ja sowas intern zu
machen wir hatten ja ein zertifikat team leute
die immer noch erzählen das echte zertifikate vertrauenswürdiger sind wenn
man da geld für bezahlt als interessiert dass irgendjemand draußen die webseiten
verwendet ob wir dafür geld bezahlt haben oder nicht dem geht es darum dass in
seinem browser ein häkchen ist alles andere ist noch als bei sehr
Seriously, meint dir irgendjemand ernsthaft, guckt sich das an von irgendwelchen Endkunden im Leben nicht?
Das ist dem, das geht denen nicht, die wissen nicht mal, dass das existiert.
Ja gut, das war wahrscheinlich, die wollten wahrscheinlich ihre eigene Arbeit irgendwie da schützen oder sowas, keine Ahnung.
Zumindest, ich hoffe dadurch, dass wir jetzt intern Let's Encrypt haben an dieser einen Stelle,
dass wir nicht nur bei uns im Cloud Service, sondern auch intern immer mehr Let's Encrypt einsetzen können.
So, hab ich irgendwas vergessen?
Hängt jemand dran? Schreibt Ed Wublos dabei, wenn ich was übersehe, dass ich es sehe.
Ja, gibt es. Es gibt ein, oh wie heißt das, was rausgekommen ist?
Also wir haben eine Retrospektive, eine Root Cause Analyse.
Leute, jetzt weiß ich es, eine Root Cause, wir haben eine Root Cause Analyse.
Es gibt ein Dokument, eine Root Cause Analyse.
Da steht das drinne.
Da steht auch drin, was ich gesagt habe mit Ausfall.
Root Cause Analyse.
Das ist bestimmt auch irgendwie sowas.
Da gibt es jetzt bestimmt auch sowas.
Ja, ja, das ist auch so irgendein Management Speak.
Gibt, also gibt es, ja.
Wurzelursachen Analyse, genau.
Quasi die Art Wurzel, eigentlich die Wurzelbehandlung, ja.
Wenn man das so will, also, naja, Wurzelbehandlung trifft sich so genau,
aber ich fände eigentlich cool, wenn man das mit Wurzelbehandlung übersetzt.
Das muss ich mal versuchen irgendwie zu etablieren.
Sowas geht ja relativ gut.
Wenn man öfters bei solchen Sachen dabei ist und sagt immer mal ab und zu so,
haja, willkommen hier, alle Wurzelbehandlung.
Das ist glaube ich was, das finden die Leute auch witzig.
Vielleicht kriege ich das irgendwie etabliert,
dass das so unter, äh, quasi so, so, so, so Spaßeshalber unter Wurzelbehandlung läuft.
Das ist, finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Ist das Zertifikat von der Startseite? Ja.
Das ist nicht nur das Zertifikat von der Startseite,
das ist, äh, quasi das Zertifikat für,
sehr viele externe Services, also, es ist nicht nur die Startseite,
es wird, es wird, also, wie gesagt, sollte das mit dem Zertifikat nicht funktionieren,
dann wisst ihr wahrscheinlich am, also, wenn, wenn auf heise irgendwann so Dienstag 18 Uhr in Meldung kommt,
dass eine große, äh, äh, deutschsprachige, oder, oder Frankfurter Bank,
dass die weit, äh, Ausfälle im großen Stil hat,
oder zumindest Zertifikatswarnung, dann wisst ihr, was Sache ist.
Genau, das schicke ich ihnen dann.
Achso.
Ich dachte, du bezahlst auch weniger Steuern.
Ne, aber das ist natürlich in Ordnung.
Da kannst du nix sagen.
Wobei man natürlich sagen muss, ähm, wenn es immer im Monat ist, natürlich die Frage, mal 12, mal 13, mal 14,
aber trotzdem, ist auch, auch, auch mal 12, mal 12 in Ordnung.
Da sind ja dann, das kriegst du im Jahr, 40.000 Euro quasi, äh, überwiesen, das ist schon, das ist schon okay.
Man, mehr, mehr darf's immer sein, ne?
Es wird keiner sagen, Leute, wenn der Chef heute zu euch kommt und sagt, hier, ihr bekommt mehr Geld,
wird ja kaum einer sagen, ach, ne, das brauche ich eigentlich nicht.
Gebt das mal jemand, jemand, gebt das mal lieber jemand anderem.
Wobei es ja meistens dann nicht jemand anderem gegeben wird, sondern einfach nix passiert.
Jasper, danke für den Sub.
Arzi und Mr. Bengel, huge subscriptions hier.
Interview mit dem, das hab ich heute Morgen geguckt, das fand ich nicht gut.
Fand ich irgendwie langweilig.
Das hab ich auch schon gesehen, wobei ich das tatsächlich freiwillig mache.
Also ich hab schon öfters mal, aber nur mit Leuten, mit denen ich mich gucke.
Ich hab schon öfters mal, während wir, äh, Teams, Teams-Besprechungen gemacht haben,
hab ich schon gesagt, hier soll ich mal Desktop sharen oder manche Leute,
im Prinzip sind es eigentlich nur drei Leute, mit denen ich das öfters mache, ja,
weil ich mich mit denen ziemlich gut verstehe, auf der Arbeit mit dem, mit irgendwelchen Random-Dudes,
würde ich das auch nicht machen.
Da kommt es öfters vor, dass wir in irgendwelchen Team-Calls sitzen und dann entweder ich oder der andere sagt,
Rickroll kommt jetzt, ja, ja, ist mir schon klar.
Ähm, und der andere sagt, hier, ich share mal kurz, ich share mal kurz Desktop, lass mal zusammen gucken.
Das kommt öfters vor, ja.
Aber wie gesagt, nur, dass ich das öfters mache.
Nur mit zwei, drei Leuten, mit denen ich, mit drei, eigentlich sind es ziemlich genau drei Leute, mit denen ich mich gut verstehe.
Den Felix kennt ihr, Felix mag sowas auch, den Felix hab ich schon mal irgendwann in Gamescom-Videos aufgenommen,
vor Jahren, mit dem war ich ja zusammen auf der Gamescom, aber ansonsten, ähm, mit den meisten nicht.
Die meisten Leute gehen mir eh auf den Keks.
Die meisten, Radiosignale sagt, die meisten Planer, die ich kenne, sind total verplant.
Das macht ja nichts, solange sie sich nicht verplanen bei irgendwelchen Projekten,
aber viele Planer von uns haben halt, haben's halt richtig krass drauf,
irgendwelche tollen,
Sprüche zu bringen,
und dann klappt's nicht.
Wobei, wir einen haben, da muss man echt sagen,
da kann man sich auch drüber streiten, ob das immer toll ist, was da rauskommt,
aber, warte mal Leute, ich muss was trinken,
ja, also wir haben einen Planer,
bei uns, der, finde ich, der macht das nicht schlecht.
Der hat zwar auch die krassesten Sprüche drauf, überhaupt,
der hat zum Beispiel mal ein, eine Präsentation gehalten,
als wir,
äh,
muss ich mal überlegen, was war denn das,
als wir, ich glaub,
ich glaub, als irgendwelche Standorte verlagert wurden,
als man, genau, das war, als sie umgezogen, das ist schon Jahre her,
als, äh, als,
von einem Rechenzentrum, also eines der Rechenzentren in ein anderes Rechenzentrum umgezogen wurde,
und da hat er gesagt,
ähm,
also was ja in Deutschland immer beliebt ist, sind Fußball- und Autovergleiche,
und da hat er in einem, und da hat er's tatsächlich nicht schlecht geplant, muss ich sagen,
aber da hat er immer richtig krasse Sprüche drauf, der Typ,
der hat da eine Präsentation gehalten,
und hat dann, und hat dann so ein,
eine Auto, äh,
keine Ahnung,
Konstruktions, äh,
Fließband gezeigt, ihr wisst ja, diese Präsentation haben wir mit der eigentlichen Sache, die gemacht wird, relativ wenig zu tun,
und dann hat er gesagt,
wir haben mehrere Produktionsstraßen aufgebaut,
damit wir Systeme parallel zur Verfügung stellen können,
und da hab ich gesagt, das klingt super krass,
im Endeffekt,
wurde da ganz normal, Server,
reingebaut,
Linux installiert,
äh, Zeug drauf kopiert, und sonst was,
aber er hat halt gesagt, wir haben mehrere Produktionsstraßen erstellt, oder sowas,
und da haben sich alle gedacht, boah,
Alter, sind die krass, was die alles gemacht haben,
da war eigentlich gar nix,
aber das hat er gut verkauft, ja,
mehrere Produktionsstraßen, da erinner ich mich heute noch dran,
wo ich mir gedacht hab, was zum Teufel ist los,
aber da hat's nicht schlecht geplant, muss man sagen,
der, der labert nicht, nur der kann das auch,
einer der wenigen,
einer der wenigen, die wir haben,
die auch planen können,
ja, das ist auch immer geil, ne,
das ist auch immer geil, wenn die Leute,
die irgendwann mal das Meeting einberufen haben,
selber nicht mehr zu den Meetings kommen,
sowas haben wir auch, kennt ihr das, Leute,
irgendein Du-, irgendein Typ,
hat mal vor nem Jahr oder so,
ein Daily, äh, kein Daily, irgendein Weekly Meeting anberaumt,
und, dann war er irgendwie drei-, viermal da,
und seitdem,
sagt er entweder immer,
ah, ich hab leider einen Paralleltermin und kann nicht,
oder kommt einfach gar nicht mehr,
das ist immer geil, ja,
aber da geh ich dann einfach nicht mehr hin,
das seh ich, also, sinnlose Meetings,
wenn die absehbar, dass sie sinnlos sind,
geh ich da mittlerweile gar nicht mehr hin,
nice, Blue Falcon, so muss das sein,
hast du die Ausbildung schon fertig,
oder hast du angefangen,
die Leute checken nicht, wie Zertifikate funktionieren,
das ist richtig, und ich bin der Meinung,
man muss ja gar nicht mal im Detail checken,
ja, also ganz genau, was weiß ich,
muss keiner wissen, was es, was es,
für verschiedene, für verschiedene,
äh, Typen gibt,
ähm, was weiß ich,
auf was sich jetzt 1024, 2048,
4096 Bit bezieht,
ja, ein bisschen den Unterschied
zwischen Private und Public Key,
ok, sollte man wissen, und man sollte halt die Basics wissen,
man sollte zum Beispiel wissen, ok,
Zertifikat, Gültigkeitsdatum,
ja, man sollte wissen, ok,
Trust Store, beziehungsweise, ähm,
CA,
und mehr oder weniger reicht
das eigentlich schon,
so, so krasse Kenner, also man muss,
man muss jetzt nicht RSA selbst programmieren können,
oder so, aber,
das fehlt trotzdem bei vielen,
du bist im August mit dem ersten
Jahr fertig, nice,
ja, ist echt so,
damit kann man, ich weiß,
es, wie gesagt, es scheitert
nicht daran, dass es
keine Tools gibt, das zu machen,
also
an den Tools scheitert es bei größeren Unternehmen,
selten, wer nutzt denn noch
Nodes? Boomer,
wir haben immer noch einen Node Server,
wisst ihr auch, warum wir noch einen Node Server haben?
Übrigens, zu geil,
das wollte ich euch jetzt noch erzählen, bevor wir anfangen Videos zu gucken,
Node Server,
wir haben ja die Umstellung auf, äh,
Exchange und Outlook, so wie ziemlich
99% aller anderen Firmen
mittlerweile ja auch haben, ähm,
die ist bei uns noch gar nicht so lange her,
ah, 4, 5 Jahre oder so,
davor war das Nodes,
und ich hab mich ja bei ein paar Videos
früher auch öfters über Nodes aufgeregt, so,
und
in der Umstellungsphase
vor noch gar nicht allzu
langer Zeit, lief das so,
wenn ein neuer Mitarbeiter
angefangen hat, der hat eigentlich
kein Nodes Account mehr gebraucht, aber
einfach einen Outlook Account
anlegen konnte man nicht, also,
ich weiß das noch, das war nämlich
jemand, der mich ein bisschen vertreten sollte, der angefangen
hat, und ich hab mich auch die ersten paar Wochen dann drum gekümmert,
dass der halt alles bekommt,
und dann hat mir allen Ernstes einer von unseren,
ähm, tja,
Indienst, ähm,
Active Directory Leuten
gezeigt, wie das funktioniert, also, wenn du einen
neuen Benutzer angelegt hast,
dann musstest du ihn nicht nur im Active Directory
anlegen, du musstest ihn,
also, Ziel war,
der neue Benutzer soll
per Outlook Mails bekommen können,
also, was musste man machen zu diesem
Zeitpunkt, man musste den neuen Benutzer
nicht etwa ein Outlook
anlegen und gut wäre, nein, nein, das hat nicht
funktioniert, man musste den neuen Benutzer
in Nodes anlegen und
anschließend das Nodes Konto nach Outlook
migrieren, nur so hat's funktioniert
nur so,
das ging nicht anders, und da hab ich
da hab ich echt so, auch so
den Glauben an die
an die Business Enterprise Software
weiter verloren, ja
das ging nicht anders, du musstest
ihn anlegen in Nodes und musstest ihn dann
migrieren auf Outlook,
anders hat das nicht funktioniert,
oh man,
ist schon geil,
die Business Enterprise
Welt ist halt so ganz anders als das, was
man so, äh,
was man von daheim, beziehungsweise
aus kleineren Unternehmen, die Business Enterprise
Welt ist kompliziert und
wir, ja,
Dankeschön für den Sub,
cute Chat, ja eindeutig,
weeps in hier,
danke für den Sub,
nö, ist auch nicht, ist es, ist es nicht,
es ist überhaupt nicht ungewöhnlich,
aber dass wir jetzt endlich intern einen
haben, der Let's Encrypt verwendet, ist gut,
das hatten wir nämlich vorher nicht,
ja, Chainlord, ich hab's gesehen,
ja,
Felix hat mir
erzählt, ähm,
dass 2000, ähm,
frag mich nicht,
wo du aus den 10 oder so,
das ist schon, das ist schon ganz lange her,
ähm,
da war er noch, da war er glaube ich noch
Azubi damals,
dass er mal bei einem Meeting dabei war,
also, wir waren ja beide
Azubis beim Provider,
und da hat er erzählt,
dass er mal bei einem, ähm,
Meeting dabei war, eines,
eines Kunden des Providers von
damals, und da muss wirklich
allen Ernstes
irgendein
des, des, oder
informierter, ähm,
Managertyp gesagt haben,
als es darum ging, irgendwie, irgendwie
Suche, oder sonst was,
ähm, haben die, haben die wohl allen Ernstes behauptet,
dann kaufen wir halt Google.
Ich mein, hey, 2010
war Google sicherlich nicht so viel wert wie heute,
aber dass irgendein 0815
Frankfurter Klitsche Google hätte kaufen können,
pfff, da hab ich
so meine Zweifel,
und da denk ich mir auch immer,
was, was für Leute sitzen da,
sind euch, ich mein, ich bin kein
größter Stocksmanager, aber, es,
sind euch die Größenverhältnisse nicht
klar? So, so, so nach
dem Motto, Google furzt und der Laden ist
weg? Das ist nicht umgedreht!
Und deswegen, und gerade weil du das
sagst, ja, ich kenn das, ich hab das an
vielen Stellen schon gesehen, dass, dass die
Leute, oder das Unternehmen, oder dass die,
wie soll man sagen, Unternehmen denken ja nicht, also das
quasi die, wie heißt das, das
und das, wie heißt das, nicht Mindset,
wie nennt man, wie nennt man das denn, so quasi die,
so dieses Selbst,
dieses Selbstsichts,
der, der Unternehmen, und dann auch so quasi
das, was so intern als, als
Selbstsicht verkauft wird,
Corporate Strategy Ident, was auch
immer, ja, Leitbild, sowas in der Richtung, genau,
ähm, was da verkauft
wird, dass das oftmals nicht
so viel mit der Realität zu tun
hat. Ich kann's aber insofern
verstehen, weil, man darf nicht vergessen,
viele Leute sind dafür glaub ich anfällig,
und die machen tatsächlich dann auch Sachen
umsonst, oder gehen samstags arbeiten, was
auch immer, ähm,
weil das ja der guten Sache hilft, also,
jetzt, guckt mal, es ist doch egal wo,
jetzt mal, jetzt mal, um ganz groß den Bogen,
Bogen zu spannen, dass man sieht, dass das auf
allen, allen Skalen so ist.
Wo Kriege angefangen wurden, die letzten
Jahre über, es ist egal,
ob die Russen, es ist egal, ob die Amis
im Nahen Osten, guckt euch mal
den Namen dieser Operationen an,
das hieß immer irgendwas mit
Freedom, und das funktioniert!
Warum heißt das Scheiß irgendwas mit Freedom?
Ich mein, ich wüsste, ich, ich wusste nicht,
dass irgendwie wir schießen, wir schießen mit
Panzer die Leute kaputt, äh, die Häuser kaputt,
die Leute ab, dass das was mit Freedom zu tun hat,
ich, ich glaube auch nicht, dass irgendwie
besonders viele Panzer schon mal Freedom
gebracht haben, aber, das heißt alles
was mit Freedom. Warum heißt das
so? Es lässt sich einfach besser verkaufen,
wenn der Scheiß Freedom heißt.
Und so ist
das auch, wenn man, wenn man in Unternehmen
verkauft, man selbst ist die Guten,
und wir selbst sind die Besten, und
der Marktführer, und was es nicht so alles
gibt, ja? Das ist da auch
so. Die Leute, die
haben es irgendwann verinnerlicht, und, und, und
stehen dann mehr dahinter, weil sie
denken, oder sich einreden können, ja,
für die gute Sache hier. Was ja Blödsinn
ist, letztendlich geht es darum, entweder um
den Aktienkurs, oder
sei es nur, weil der Chef
neulich in den Weltall fliegen will, oder sonst was.
Das ist natürlich auch geil,
die Rentner auf 450 Euro Basis.
Haben wir uns die Battlefield-Spielerzahlen angesehen?
Ne, die sind aber besser geworden
mittlerweile, schaut mal. Seit dem letzten
Patch spielen kurz
also, es haben jetzt, die letzte Woche haben tatsächlich wieder
ein paar mehr gespielt.
Die letzte Woche,
guck mal, seit
dem Patch hier, der all ganz
groß angekündigt wurde, 4.0, ist es
ein bisschen hochgegangen. Aber ich bin mir
relativ sicher, dass es nur Tempo wäre.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, es ist halt immer noch lächerlich
wenig. Ja, das liegt wahrscheinlich
daran, weil
umso konservativer, beziehungsweise
umso traditioneller, könnte
man das Ganze auch nennen, eine Branche
ist, umso weniger Bock,
haben wirklich
kreative oder agile,
guck mal, was ich da nennen will,
also kreative Leute haben ja selten
Bock da drauf, sich
bürokratischen Hindernissen zu stellen.
Deswegen hast du ja auch, deswegen hast du
nur abgedrehte und gestörte Leute, umso
schwieriger es ist.
Vermute ich zumindest.
Das ist ein Rickroll-Video, 100 pro.
Ja, irgendwie war klar. Also, dass man
mehr Geld bekommen kann, dass man steuerlich
weniger rausbekommt, halte ich für ein Gerücht.
Es muss dann schon wirklich ganz
doofe Breakpoints
treffen. Es ist ja nicht so,
dass du jetzt, keine Ahnung,
30% Steuern bezahlst und
bekommst einen Euro mehr und bezahlst dann 40% Steuern.
Das ist ja, das ist ja gestaffelt.
Ja, also
das geht dann auch teilweise
nur um halbe Prozent und
sonst was, also
das musst du erstmal hinkriegen.
Ich bezweifle nicht, dass es möglich ist,
aber es ist doch recht
äh
du brauchst schon echt das blöd treffen.
Da müsstest du dann irgendwie nur
10 Euro mehr bekommen und genau
über irgendwie diesen halben Prozentpunkt
Breakpoint rüberkommen oder so. Normalerweise
bekommst du ja, wenn du mehr bekommst, ein bisschen mehr als 5 Euro.
Das heißt, du solltest am Ende
immer mehr raushaben.
Ist das bei euch auch so, dass ihr immer noch nach
dass ihr immer nach
Scrum-Arbeit durchgehend im Sprint seid?
Tja, ne, bei uns ist das anders. Gut,
ich meine, ich bin jetzt ja auch in keinem Entwicklerteam,
in dem Sinne, also ich bin ja nicht in der Softwareentwicklung,
ähm,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie meine Abteilung heißt,
wenn ich ehrlich bin. Ich glaube irgendwas
mit Infrastruktur.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube Infrastruktur und Services
oder irgendwie so heißen wir.
Ach, keine Ahnung. Was auch immer.
Ähm, bei uns ist das nicht so, aber
ich weiß das, ich weiß das von manchen
Entwicklerteams.
Bei uns ist das noch schlimmer.
Die sagen, sie arbeiten
nach Scrum, machen sie aber gar nicht.
Das einzige, was die an Scrum machen ist,
die stehen einmal täglich im Kreis
mit 10 Leuten
und labern ein bisschen und sagen dann,
wir haben ein krasses Daily Stand-Up gemacht.
Der Rest davon machen die gar nicht.
Ach so, da, ja, pff.
Also wer das erwartet, ist eh komplett realitätsfern.
Du kannst
nichts 8 Stunden am Tag konzentriert machen.
Du kannst, um es jetzt mal übertrieben zu sagen,
du kannst noch nicht mal 8 Stunden am Tag
konzentriert kacken.
Ohne, dass dir der Bobbes weh tut. Also du kannst
fast nichts, egal was es ist,
8 Stunden am Stück effizient machen.
Egal,
du kannst nicht 8 Stunden effizient
sitzen mal alleine.
Du kannst nichts,
du kannst noch nicht mal 8 Stunden am Stück
effizient schlafen.
Du kannst fast nichts
8 Stunden wirklich am Stück
effizient machen. Das geht nicht.
So, und natürlich Sachen, wo man
sein Hirn dazu braucht,
erst recht nicht.
Und selbst 4-5 Stunden ist
glaube ich sogar schon ein bisschen,
bisschen hoch angesetzt.
Also ich würde mal, also ich persönlich
würde mal drauf tippen, Sachen, wo man
wirklich, mal angenommen,
angenommen die Voraussetzungen
sind da, also man hat seine Ruhe,
man ist nicht in einem Großraumbüro,
gehen wir mal davon aus, und selbst
spielen 8 Stunden am Stück kannst du nicht
effizient.
Selbst wenn die Voraussetzungen
da sind, und du auch, sagen wir mal, ein Problem
hast, was ein bisschen dein Hirn
fordert, ja, 2-3 Stunden
am Tag höchstens,
danach kommt qualitativ
nichts mehr so Gutes raus, wie am Anfang.
Das dauert sogar mal eine halbe Stunde, bis du dich
ungefähr eingedingst hast, aber danach
2 Stunden fokussiert am Stück,
dann hast du schon viel gemacht.
Du machst diese 2 Stunden fokussiert wahrscheinlich
mehr als die nächsten 3 Stunden, selbst wenn du
dran sitzen bleibst. Tja, das ist eine gute
Frage.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die meisten Leute ganz froh
sind, wenn sie sagen können, ich habe heute gemietet, keine Ahnung.
Na Chuck, danke für den Sub.
Kann ich mir vorstellen. Oh ja,
Klan-Zugang.
So, ich glaube, wir haben den Chat
fast durch.
Kann ja jeder machen, wie er will.
Ich finde, das ist eigentlich auch die beste Regel.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ich finde, mehr deutsche Unternehmen,
gerade auch im IT-Sektor, sollten
dahin gehen.
Wenn du das erledigt hast, was du
erledigen sollst, ist okay.
Scheiß drauf, ob du 8 Stunden Präsenz
fakest oder nicht.
Also, was ich gerne habe, ist mal so 1-2
kurze Dailies am Tag. Das sind die
meisten Tage. Da kannst du inzwischen was
futtern gehen. Hast du morgens mal irgendeinen Daily,
mittags mal irgendeinen Daily. Das ist okay.
Und du kannst im Zweifelsfall nicht immer noch rausgehen mit
Leute, ich muss gleich zum Daily.
Aber ansonsten will ich meine Ruhe.
Macht dein Job dir eigentlich Bock
und willst du das genauso einfach weitermachen?
Also, das muss man trennen
voneinander. Macht dir dein Job
eigentlich Bock? Ja, aber
es hat
zunehmend Elemente, die
ich denke, die gar nicht wirklich zu
meinem Job gehören.
Die auch gehören sollten.
Die ganzen Sachen von Organisationssachen,
die ich heute auch im Laufe des Streams schon angesprochen habe,
die mir keinen Bock machen und die mir auch auf den
Keks gehen. Und wo wir uns, denke ich,
dort wo ich bin, auch nicht in die richtige Richtung
bewegen.
Willst du es genauso weitermachen?
Da kann ich sagen, ja, weil
ich arbeite nur 4 Tage die Woche
und
ich
habe weniger eine,
wie soll ich sagen, persönliche Bindung zu
meinem Arbeitgeber, als
ich Bindung habe zu den Leuten, mit denen ich zusammenarbeite.
Also, wenn mich am Samstag jemand
anruft und sagt
Max, Hilfe XY ist kaputt, kannst du
mal gucken? Dann
gucke ich nicht, weil
ich denke, oh ja,
ähm,
wir sind das geilste Unternehmen auf der
Welt, ich muss dafür sorgen, dass es weiter funktioniert,
sondern ich denke mir, okay,
der Kollege, der da gerade vor Ort sitzt, hat Probleme,
dem helfe ich.
Also, mir ist quasi
die Auswirkungen vor dem Unternehmen sind mir eigentlich
fast egal, mir geht es darum, dass ich demjenigen
helfe, den ich kenne und persönlich mich mit dem gut verstehe.
Falls man versteht, was ich meine.
Also, so, und
allein schon aus dem Grund,
weil ich nur 4 Tage die Woche arbeite,
man sich insgesamt jetzt auch nicht,
ich sag mal, das ist ja nicht vergleichbar
mit, ich mache jetzt 8 Stunden Müllabfuhr, also das ist
körperlich auch nicht super belastend oder so,
äh, und nachdem ich
bei 4 Tagen die Woche noch genug Zeit
habe, mein eigenes Zeug zu machen, plus
Bezahlung auch ganz okay ist, mein Mehr geht in der
Zeit natürlich immer, würde ich auch so weitermachen,
weil ich habe aktuell, finde ich, eigentlich
eine ganz gute Mischung aus
Geld verdienen plus
die
meiste Zeit
Freizeittechnisch, dass ich machen kann, was ich will.
Es ist vielleicht nicht ganz
50-50, aber
es ist, sagen wir mal so, 60-40,
also ich kann, ich kann
40% meiner Zeit machen, was ich will.
Das ist doch, also ich rede jetzt nicht von der Arbeitszeit,
sondern von meiner
Zeit insgesamt. Das ist doch genau
in Ordnung, ja.
Also, es gibt, es gibt eine Sache,
die instant dazu führen könnte, dass
ich das nicht mehr mache, das ist, wenn
jetzt einer auf der Arbeit sagt, hier Max, ähm,
4 Tage die Woche wieder nach Frankfurt fahren,
dann bin ich weg, das mache ich nicht.
Also, wenn man sich da nicht irgendwie anders eint,
das mache ich nicht.
Ich werde nicht mehr 4 Tage die Woche nach Frankfurt fahren.
Definitiv nicht. Dann suche ich mir
irgendeine Homeoffice-only-Stelle oder irgendwas anderes.
Das mache ich auf gar keinen Fall.
Ähm, das ist aber auch das einzige, was mir,
was mir so einfallen würde, jetzt.
Ähm,
ansonsten bin ich okay.
Was ist,
oh, das ist ein Riesenthema, da können wir,
das können wir jetzt nicht aufmachen, das Fass.
So, fertig, wir haben es geschafft, Leute.
Jetzt gucken wir uns, jetzt gucken wir uns ein paar Videos an.
Ich habe jetzt genug geschwätzt. Ich habe jetzt
eine Stunde 15 durchgehend gelabert
über irgendwelches Zeug.
Wir müssen uns jetzt mal irgendwas angucken. Was haben wir denn hier?
Battlefield 2, okay, wir lassen uns
eine Runde, Leute, wir lassen uns eine Runde Level Capture Bane.
Du wohnst auch in Frankfurt.
Naja, nicht wirklich, ich wohne da neben.
Aber nicht weit weg.
Also, ich brauche
ungefähr,
von Bahnhof zu Bahnhof, Viertelstunde.
20 Minuten.
Mit dem Zug, Viertelstunde.
Und
ich mache es ja mittlerweile so, ich fahre nur noch
zum Südbahnhof und laufe dann
vom Südbahnhof morgens in die Frankfurter Innenstadt.
Da bist du nochmal so 20, 25
Minuten, 25 Minuten
unterwegs. Einfach, dass man sich
morgen ein bisschen bewegt hat.
Aber ansonsten, also wenn ich
es wirklich drauf
anlege, bin ich
in einer halben Stunde, also da muss der Zug
extrem pünktlich sein, ich muss mich auch
sputen, sowohl
zum Bahnsteig hier, als auch
vom Bahnsteig dort. Also wenn ich mich
wirklich beeile und der Zug und so alles pünktlich
ist, brauche ich eine halbe Stunde
von Hoftor zu Sitz
auf der Arbeit.
Also ich sitze auf dem Stuhl auf der Arbeit und
ich gehe aus dem Hoftor aus und ich finde eine halbe Stunde ist durchaus
in Ordnung. Was meine
ich?
Ich bin im Auto und das wird am Montag gefixt.
So, also was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Specialist Classes Datamind. Who cares?
Leute, das muss ich zumachen.
Wenn ich da zufällig
reingucke, fange ich jeden Stream
wieder an mich darüber aufzuregen.
Muss weg.
Warum ist Prime Video so schlecht?
Hätten wir zu bieten. Okay.
Ist Ubuntu 22
und 30 Minuten, das gucke ich mir nicht an.
Was ist das eigentlich schon wieder
für ein Titel? Ubuntu 22
und 304 ist wahrscheinlich das gleiche wie Ubuntu
21.10, bloß mit ein paar
geupdateten Paketen. Großartig, wird sich da nichts geändert
haben. Wobei wir uns ja alle
einig sind, dass man das nicht Ubuntu ausspricht, sondern
Jivanti! Stimmt's?
Jivanti! Jivanti!
So ist das.
Okay, komm, wir lassen uns eine Runde Level-Captcha
baden. Ubuntu hat noch
mehr Snap integriert. Na okay, ob das
so viel besser macht, habe ich jetzt meine Zweifel,
aber
eher nicht, oder? So, dann lassen wir uns mal
eine Runde Level-Captcha baden.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal schnell nochmal Sound einstellen.
Biggest Patch ever, und es ist immer noch
Kacke! Yeah!
Was haben die sich
eigentlich bei Warzone gedacht, dass da jetzt irgendwelche
Monster am Start sind? Ich finde, das passt so
überhaupt nicht rein. Warzone war ja immer,
also gerade Verdunsk,
das war ja immer noch halbwegs realistisch angehaucht,
alles. Mittlerweile ist das
jetzt Fantasy, oder was? Ich dachte, das sind Zombies
in Fantasy. Na gut.
Gab's nicht sogar irgendeine,
nee, das war in Black Ops, in diesem Black Ops
Battle Royale gab's irgendeine Zombie-Stadt, ne?
Naja.
The director of the Uncharted series is
making a new Star Wars game, and much
more on this week in gaming. Also,
Level-Captcha baden uns.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, dass
das der planke Hohn ist,
dass dieses Update 4.0
heißt? Das würde ja
bedeuten, dass
Battlefield irgendwann mal bei 1.0 war.
Das sind, die sind jetzt
vielleicht bei 0.7 oder so.
4.0, wie sich
das anhört.
Jawoll, Voice-Chat, jetzt, wo keiner mehr da ist,
mit dem du's spielen kannst, yeah.
END OF ROUND SCOREBOARD!
Klapper, klapper.
Ich sag nicht, dass das schlecht ist, Leute.
Ich sag nicht, dass das schlecht ist,
braucht das Game sicherlich dringend.
Aber das Game braucht noch deutlich mehr dringend,
und es ist trotzdem nicht mehr zu retten.
Some of the highlights include
improved destruction and debris physics,
the settings in game are now more readable,
with an updated on and off switch,
performance is slightly better on PC
and consoles, a new takedown animation
has been added to the portal mode,
the player can now play the game
in a more realistic way,
I mean, man sieht doch allein schon daran,
dass er selbst keinen Bock auf dieses Game hat,
dass er quasi Trailer-Footage verwendet,
obwohl das Spiel ein halbes Jahr raus ist.
Äh, doch, doch, das Scoreboard kennt man.
Das, ach so,
END OF ROUND SCOREBOARD, das hab ich nicht gesehen.
END OF ROUND SCOREBOARD.
Das normale Scoreboard kenn ich, ja.
Die Wettereffekte sind das unsinnigste ever.
Das Game sieht halt immer noch so.
Identitätslos aus, einfach.
Ach ja.
Angel, da seht ihr gern.
Kommt jetzt nicht mehr so oft.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Aha.
Das haben sie gecancelt, ja.
Da kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Visceral Game Studio back in 2016.
It's unclear whether or not
this new Star Wars game may pick up
development where the ragtag game
left off.
Hat eigentlich George Lucas noch irgendwas mit
Lucasfilms zu tun? Nee, oder? Der Typ ist weg.
Das hat er verkauft an Disney
und tschüss.
Activision confirmed the rumors that Godzilla
and King Kong will be coming to Call of
Duty Warzone. In a cinematic
trailer, the duo were shown charging
at each other on the Caldera map.
An official PlayStation Blog post
accompanied the trailer and it shared plenty of
details about the new content. Caldera
will receive several map changes and unique
points of interest. Research facilities
and equipment will be scattered around the map.
A brand new gulag will be
added to the inside of a ship
off the coast of the island and the entire
map will receive... Ich mein,
Fortnite, zu Fortnite passt's
ja irgendwie, ja? Ich mein, Fortnite hat
irgendwie das halbe Marvel Universe
mittlerweile drinne und jetzt kommt
Warzone mit Godzilla und
King Kong. Keine Sau in der
Adresse, ja.
Battle Scars all based around the
Godzilla and King Kong conflict.
Standard Multiplayer is also getting new
content. Two small maps named Mayhem
and Sphere. Mayhem is based
on a 1950s movie set featuring
plenty of destructible elements
and in comparison, Sphere is a
hidden weapons lab with close quarter
combat. Season 3 featuring all of
this content launches on April 27th
while the King Kong vs. Godzilla
event won't start until May 11th.
Halo Infinite Season
2 content goes live on May 3rd.
The developers at 343 Industries
have shared a first look at the new
Battle Royale-like mode called
Spartan Standing. In this new
game mode, the entire objective is to
survive until the end of the round.
Twelve players spawn onto different large
scale maps with a limited loadout
and... Ich, da bin ich mal
gespannt, wie das gemacht ist. Ich kann
mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen,
dass so das Kern-Gameplay von
Halo gut zu einem
Battle Royale passt.
Du hast wieder
aufladbare Schilde, du hast eine
ziemlich, ziemlich hohe
Time-to-Kill, zumindest mit den
normalen Waffen.
Du bist langsam unterwegs,
das heißt, fortbewegen über große
Maps ist eh schon so ein Ding.
Es stehen überall Autos, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Also...
Keine Ahnung, wie gut Battle Royale
zu Halo passt oder so.
...5 respawns. Players will have the option
to upgrade their weapons with each kill. You win
the round by being the last Spartan alive.
Development on a fully fleshed out
Halo Battle Royale is also rumored.
Codename Tatanka is being co-developed
with the Certain Affinity Studio.
Ich weiß nicht.
Dazu kommt ja, wisst ihr,
das Problem ist,
dass du sowas in Halo nicht gewinnst.
Du gewinnst in Halo kein 1
gegen 2.
In Warzone machst du das,
theoretisch, ja. Gerade,
wenn du gutes Engagement aus
der Deckung hast oder wenn du noch irgendeine Stun-Granate
hast, du gewinnst in Halo kein 1 versus 2.
Das heißt, diese Geschichte hier
am Ende...
...development on a fully fleshed out
Halo Battle Royale...
Das hier, das wird im Leben nix.
Das ist im Prinzip einfach nur random,
wer auf wen zufälligerweise jetzt
schießt und dann am Ende...
Also...
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass das mit dem Halo Gameplay
an sich gut zusammen funktioniert.
...Battle Royale is also rumored.
Codename Tatanka is being co-developed...
Die einfachste Variante, wenn man Halo gut...
Also als Halo-Noob,
ich bin ja auch Halo-Noob,
aber der einfachste Tipp
für Halo-Noobs, wenn man
TDM oder generell irgendwelche teambasierten
Spielmodi spielt, ist, einfach immer mit
jemand anderem rumlaufen.
Du wirst einfach 80% mehr Fights
gewinnen, weil es in Halo darum geht,
dem Gegner quasi
konstant... Also in Halo geht es nicht
darum, den Gegner zu sehen und den Gegner
instant zu killen. Es geht
auch darum, den Gegner zu sehen,
Damage drauf zu machen, plus vielleicht
kriegt ihn dann irgendjemand von deinen
Teammates oder so. Du musst die...
Du kannst im Prinzip, übertrieben gesagt,
die Runde in Halo gewinnen, ohne
einen Gegner zu killen, was nicht so sein wird,
weil es deine Teammates ja auch so machen,
aber du musst das
nicht unbedingt derjenige sein,
der die Leute killt.
Also ich ähm...
Ich stell's mir schwierig vor.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das gut funktioniert.
Kappa! Der wollte Kappa!
Der wollte garantiert Kappa schreiben!
Also, dieses Moon...
Das ist ja quasi der
Emoji-Kappa-Ersatz.
Das ist ja quasi der Emoji-Kappa-Ersatz.
...
The report also shares how players may be rewarding for interacting with these advertisements.
One example is rewarding players with unique items in-game if they watch an entire ad.
How ads are depicted would depend on the individual developer.
Strangely, something similar was actually done in Battlefield 2042.
Alter, dieses Game schafft es wirklich, dass sogar die Werbung scheiße aussieht, man.
Also, ich käme mir als Logitech hart verarscht vor.
Stellt euch, stellt euch mal vor, ihr seid Logitech, habt irgendeinen Marketing-Deal mit EA gemacht,
der euch was auch immer was gekostet hat, und dann ist das sowas.
So.
Das sieht so schlecht aus, man.
In-Game-Billboard on the Hourglass-Map.
Das ist so schlecht.
Significant updates for the Extraction Royale Hunt Showdown don't come often.
And this next patch has players incredibly excited.
Update 1.8.1 will introduce new armed versions.
Okay, lasst euch Battlefield, Leute, lasst euch das mal auf der Zunge zergehen.
1.8.1 sind die jetzt bei Hunt Showdown.
Und das Battlefield 2042 ist bei Update 4.
Ja.
Welches Game ist fertiger?
New armed versions of the Grunt Zombies.
They will come in two variants, wielding either a rusted pistol or a lantern.
Both variants will be relatively easy to kill, but will create a lot more noise than usual.
Noise can be easily heard by other hunters in the game.
Update 1.8.1 will also introduce a new daily quest system.
These will be a series of challenges that reward players with blood bonds, money or weapons.
Ich hab von diesem Game keinen Plan.
Three quests once unlocked, three quests can be tracked at once.
The new content should be available on the public test version of the game next week.
Das einzige, was ich von dem Game gesehen habe bisher, ist beim Siegesmund bei irgendwie in einem Highlight-Video oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
... showcased this new character customization...
Soll aber echt nicht schlecht sein.
Das habe ich von vielen Leuten schon gehört.
Also nicht das, sondern Hand.
... the customization is incredibly in-depth.
Players will have the freedom to unlock dozens of options with in-game cash.
Clothing options vary.
From firefighter uniforms to fluffy bunny slippers.
Players can even adjust the color and material of each clothing item.
In-depth physics changes can be made to the characters as well.
You can adjust their muscles, scars and glossiness of their skin.
There will also be in-depth customization options for vehicles, weapons and even your gang basic.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du so viel customisieren, dass von dem eigentlichen Game nichts verüppelt ist.
The Saints Row Reboot is scheduled to launch on August 23rd.
The Polish studio Megapixel has announced a remake of the 1997 classic title,
The House of the Dead.
This on-rails survival shooter amassed a massive cult following over the years.
The remake will launch on PC, Google Stadia, PlayStation and Xbox on April 28th.
It includes new features like two-player co-op, local multiplayer, photo mode and multiple endings.
The game's publisher, Forever Entertainment, is currently working on a deal to remaster the second House of the Dead game as well.
Before we get to our final story this week, let us know what you thought about Battlefield 2042's latest update 4.0.
Has it improved?
Your overall experience?
Are you waiting for new content?
Let us know in the comments below.
Also wenn überhaupt, wenn ich überhaupt mal in Battlefield 2042 wieder reingucken sollte,
da muss noch mehr passieren als noch ein neuer Specialist oder noch eine neue Map.
In the comments below.
Panic, the publishers behind Firewatch and Untitled Goose Game are making a handheld console called the Playdale.
It's a tiny device with a black and white screen and a hand crank.
Loaded on its...
4 GB of internal data storage are 24 unique indie games.
Users must navigate these different...
But why?
Games using the D-Pad A and B buttons and the hand crank.
In some instances, turning the hand crank moves the character on screen.
There are supposedly more games coming in the future through seasonal content drops, but there's very little known about them yet.
Players can pre-order the device...
Okay.
Ich will das denen ja nicht ausreden, aber...
Warum?
...advice for $179.
$179, though it probably won't ship until 2023.
And that wraps it up for today's episode of This Week in Gaming.
Alles klar.
As always guys, thank you so much for watching and I'll catch you next time.
Richtig, Chet.
Das ist genau das Ding.
Es hört sich ganz cool an.
Das war es aber auch.
Das wird sich nicht, noch nicht mal cool genug anhören, dass sich das viele Leute kaufen, gehe ich mal von aus.
Ah.
Kurz Musik anmachen.
Übrigens, Leute, es hat mich doch letztens jemand so gefragt, ob ich gerade...
Oder was ich für Serien gerade gucke oder sonst was.
Ich bin ja nicht irgendwie der Permanent-Serien-Suchter, aber Amazon, ich war letztens abends auf Amazon, die haben mir vorgeschlagen, ich soll doch mal Homeland gucken.
Das ist irgendeine Serie von 2012 oder so.
Und ich habe jetzt die erste Staffel geguckt und ich war so, das ist echt nicht schlecht.
Das ist eines der unvorhersehbarsten Serien, die ich die letzten paar Jahre geguckt habe.
Also, fand ich nicht übel.
Ja, muss ich jetzt einfach mal sagen.
Auch clever, clever, wie sie das geschrieben haben.
Teilweise denkst du irgendwie, was weiß ich, er ist es, er ist es nicht und...
Nicht schlecht.
Das ist eine richtig gute Serie bis Staffel 5, okay.
Ja, da habe ich ja noch vier Staffeln, die ich gucken kann.
Ja, danach gehen ihnen wahrscheinlich die Ideen aus.
Homeland.
Was da?
Ja, acht Staffeln, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe jetzt die erste Staffel geguckt.
Muss ich sagen, also ich muss sagen, die erste, die war echt nicht schlecht.
Die ist jetzt von 2012 oder so.
Das war, das ist eines der wenigen Sachen, wo ich mir gedacht habe, hey, die Leute, die sich die Story überlegt haben, die haben wirklich sich Gedanken gemacht.
Weil du auch Sachen erfährst, die dann später wiederkommen und wo du es noch nicht meilenweit voraussehen kannst.
Finde ich gut.
Also, fand ich wirklich gut, die erste Staffel.
Staffel 8 wieder solide.
Staffel 8 ist anscheinend auch die letzte.
Gucke ich, also, ich weiß nicht, ich gucke so lange, bis es sackt halt immer.
Hängt vielleicht ein bisschen lahm.
Aber echt gut gemacht.
Und was ich halt immer gut finde, ist, mittlerweile ist man es ja schon gewohnt, dass man irgendwelche Filme guckt oder Serien, oder Serien sich anguckt und sich dann so denkt, so nach dem Motto, während man guckt, so nach dem Motto, aha, daran habt ihr jetzt nicht gedacht.
So nach dem Motto, da habt ihr euch selbst widersprochen, aha, hier, guck mal, eindeutige Logiklücke, damals haben sie das gesagt, jetzt machen sie das.
Also, das hat man ja mittlerweile an allen Ecken.
Weil du denkst, alter, der Scheiß ist nicht richtig durchdacht.
Aber das finde ich, haben sie in Homeland richtig gut gemacht.
Ich hatte ein paar Mal, ich, ich, ich, Spoiler jetzt nicht.
Ich hatte ein paar Mal, habe ich mir so gedacht, aha, vor zwei Folgen habt ihr das erzählt und jetzt hofft ihr, wir haben es vergessen.
Oder, das ist jetzt was anderes.
Aber zwei Folgen danach, kam das dann so nach dem Motto, fuck, das ist ja doch, die haben es doch nicht vergessen, ja.
Also, fand ich cool.
Also, muss ich sagen, nicht schlecht.
Ja.
Na gut.
Äh, wo sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben?
Warum, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind, Leute?
Wollen wir hiermit weitermachen?
War es ja wunderbar, oder?
Kennst du das?
Darf man das auf Twitch überhaupt gucken?
Das ist doch Amazon.
Ganz ehrlich, jetzt mal, bevor ich mir, bevor ich mir das Video, bevor ich mir das Video angucke.
Ich finde Prime, äh, nicht, ich wollte gerade sagen, Prime Gaming, Alter, zum Glück, zum Glück haben wir das noch nicht.
Da haben wir es noch nicht, aber wir haben es noch nicht.
Ähm, äh, Prime Video, also das, wo, wo Prime Video meiner Meinung nach am aller, allermeisten krankt ist, äh, wie sage ich das jetzt am besten?
Prime Video ist kein, nein, ich muss, ich muss mal kurz, ich muss, ich muss, ich muss überlegen, wie, wie, wie sage ich das, wie sage ich das am richtigen, wie sage ich das am besten?
Also, in Prime Video ist es halt so, wenn, wenn du, wenn du auf Prime Video bist, du findest irgendwie,
Also, du musst eigentlich schon vorher wissen, was du gucken willst, dass du was findest.
Das ist quasi ein bisschen, als hätte man Amazon reskinnt und hätte dann quasi gesagt, man nimmt, die, man nimmt den Amazon Shop und, und anstatt, dass man da jetzt Klopapier und, und Werkzeuge anzeigt, zeigt man Videos an.
Also, bei Amazon ist es ja auch so.
Also, du gehst auf Amazon und suchst nach was, weil, was du brauchst.
Oder aber, du hast Glück und der Amazon Algorithmus weiß schon, was du haben willst.
Also, das ist eigentlich das größte Problem an, an, an Prime Video.
Das ist auch, das ist auch bei allen anderen Amazon Services so.
Bei Audible ist es mittlerweile ein bisschen besser.
Ähm, aber bei, ähm, dem, wie heißt das andere, diesem Kindle, Kindle Krempel.
Äh, diese Kindle Bibliothek oder was auch immer, ja, was weiß ich.
Da ist das auch so, du, du denkst, das ist, du denkst, das ist alles irgendwie, hell, so half-assed Amazon reskinnt.
Das trifft's, glaube ich, ganz gut.
Wusstet ihr übrigens, dass Amazon selbst Livestreams hat?
Wusstet ihr, dass Amazon selbst nicht live lebt?
Amazon hat Livestreams, nicht Prime Video.
Amazon live gibt, nein, nicht Prime.
Ja, das.
Ja, Amazon hat seriously Livestreams.
Da haben sie irgendwelche mehr oder weniger bekannten Influencer-Leute, die, das ist, das ist quasi Teleshopping, wenn du so willst.
Nur ohne Tele.
Das ist quasi Dauerwerbesendung für Amazon.
Musst gar nicht, das, da gibt's auch ein Chat dafür und so.
The fuck?
Das hab ich letztens gefunden, zufällig, weil irgendein Channel, dem ich folge, der Smart Home Gedöns macht,
der, äh,
hat gesagt, er streamt jetzt gleich auf Amazon live.
Und dann haben die Leute in die Kommentare geschrieben, was?
Amazon was? Wie? Das gibt's?
Und dann bin ich da mal draufgegangen und hab gesagt, fuck, das gibt's wirklich.
Na gut, jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, warum Amazon Prime Video so schlecht ist.
...was du gucken willst und suchst verzweifelt auf Netflix, aber auch, wenn es doch eigentlich so viele Geheimtipps auf der Plattform gibt.
Also ich muss sagen, Homeland war die erste Empfehlung von Amazon, wahrscheinlich, weil es random war,
äh, war die einzige,
welche Empfehlung bei, bei Amazon bisher, was sie mir empfohlen haben, was mir gefallen hat.
Ansonsten krieg ich bei Amazon Prime immer irgendwelche B-Movies oder irgendwie Ultra-Trash empfohlen, den ich überhaupt nicht gucken will.
...gibt. Sobald du anfängst rumzuscrollen und rumzuklicken, besteht Netflix nur noch aus Weihnachtsfilmen und den räudigsten Rom-Coms unter der Sonne.
Und irgendwann kommt dann der Punkt, an dem du denkst, okay, fuck it, dann guck ich halt auf Prime Video.
Oh Gott, oh Gott, no. Oh Gott, no.
Oh Gott, no!
NO!
Und hier beginnt ein Albtraum ohnegleichen.
Apropos RomComs, äh, was gibt es denn da? So auf Prime.
Komms...
Das Problem hab ich auch.
Ja, also die Bedienung dieser Seite ist wirklich kompletter Abfuck.
Und wisst ihr, was mir auch...was mich auch mega nervt? Ist wenn man das auf dem Fernseher anguckt, also Android TV,
Jedes Mal, kennt ihr wahrscheinlich auch, jedes Mal, wenn man diese App startet, muss man auswählen, wer guckt.
Ob ich gucke oder ob Kinder gucken.
Warum muss ich bei jedem Start der App sagen, ich gucke, es gucken keine Kinder.
Warum gibt es kein Default Settings zu sagen, hey, es gucken keine Kinder.
Und wenn Kinder gucken, kann ich immer noch einen Button hin machen.
Das ist so bescheuert.
Yes, okay, klick auf die Kategorie Romantik und...
Achso, geil.
Doch, so viele.
...Laiers Staffel 5 und das war's.
Kennt ihr schon den Marshall-Arts-Film Brave Mädchen tun das nicht?
Okay, suche ich mal nach The Office.
Danke für die ganzen Filter, besonders Erscheinungsdatum letzter Monat oder letzte zwei Monate.
Ja, Amazon-Filter sind auch, die sind aber, das liegt daran, weil die im Shop auch so kacke sind.
Das ist das, was ich meine.
Dass das alles, dass diese ganzen Prime-Services irgendwie ein Amazon-Reskin sind, der nicht zu der eigentlichen Anwendung mehr passt.
Die Filter...
Die Filter bei Amazon sind auch meistens ziemlich sinnlos, ja.
Zum Beispiel, habt ihr mal versucht bei Amazon nach sowas Popeligem zu sortieren, wie Lieferdatum?
Gehen wir mal bei Amazon und suchen da jetzt zum Beispiel USB-Stick.
So.
USB-Stick.
Ich möchte sortieren nach, ist lieferbar und wann?
Warum geht das nicht?
Ich will nicht out of stock.
Ich will sortieren können nach Lieferdatum.
Warum geht das nicht?
Wenn du eingeloggt bist und Prime-Kunde bist, kannst du wenigstens noch hier oben Prime auswählen.
Und Prime bedeutet meistens schnellstmögliche Lieferung.
Jetzt ist nicht alles morgen da, das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Es gibt gerade, wenn du donnerstagsabends oder freitagsabends Sachen bestellen willst, dann gibt es die Variante erst nächste Woche oder noch bis Samstag.
Und viele Sachen sind halt erst bis Samstag.
Aber manche gibt es auch bis Samstag.
Und du kriegst es nicht gescheit hin, das zu filtern.
Außer, dass du drüber scrollst und halt guckst, wo steht Prime, wo steht Lieferbar bis Samstag.
Manchmal machst du dann auch Samstag hier direkt, Saturday direkt mit über die Suche.
Ja, es ist beschissen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man...
Ich meine, Amazon macht das nicht just for fun.
Das muss man sehen.
Weil Amazon gibt sehr viel Geld dafür aus.
Zu analysieren, an welcher Stelle des Bestellprozesses Leute aus dem Bestellvorgang aussteigen.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier das reinklicke und Amazon trackt bestimmt, wie lange brauche ich auf Checkout.
Scrolle ich erst die Seite runter.
So nach dem Motto, wenn ich erst die Seite ganz runter scrolle, das heißt, ich weiß nicht, dass der Checkout-Button oben ist.
Das analysieren die alles komplett.
Aber irgendwie kriegen sie das nicht gebacken.
Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht haben sie auch intern festgestellt, es ist besser, man zeigt nicht an, wann das Datum da ist, weil die Leute sonst vielleicht nicht bestellen oder so.
Aber es ist eklig.
Jeder 0815-Shop kann das.
Amazon kann das nicht.
Da weiß es, nach Staffel 1 und 2 ist die logische Konsequenz 4 und dann 7.
Quizfrage.
Zurück zu Prime Video.
Ja, das liegt daran, weil die Suche die normale Amazon-Suche ist und keine Prime Video-Suche, die explizit auf Videometadaten oder so zurückgreift.
Das wird die gleiche Suche sein, die man auch ganz normal über Amazon verwendet und da ist halt random.
Das ist nicht dafür, das ist gemacht, um USB-Sticks zu suchen oder Klopapier zu suchen, aber halt nicht eine Serie in der richtigen Reihenfolge.
Das ist halt affig, dass das auf Prime Video nicht geht.
Übrigens, jetzt mal.
Chat, unpopuläre Meinung, ja.
Oder weiß ich, weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht, wie ihr das seht, aber die Office-Memes sind ja ganz lustig.
Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich finde die Serie nicht lustig.
Ich habe mir die erste Staffel angekauft, ich habe mir die erste Staffel echt nur, also vor einer Weile gekauft.
Ich, ich weiß nicht, ich.
Obwohl ich eigentlich in so einem Business.
Strongest Enterprise Umfeld arbeite, die US-Serie, nicht die UK-Serie.
Ich weiß nicht, ich fand das jetzt nicht sonderlich gut.
Oder nicht sonderlich lustig.
Fühlt sich wie Stromberg an, naja gut, das liegt halt daran, weil das die deutsche Variante davon ist.
Aber Stromberg fand ich auch nicht witzig.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich müsste eigentlich genau die richtige Zielgruppe sein von The Office, aber ich.
Keine Ahnung, ich finde es ziemlich lustig.
Einfach auf alle, dann auf Prime Video, dann auf alle Videos.
Wie bei Gott kann diese Plattform so unbenutzbar sein?
Wirklich todernst gemeint.
Diese Frage haben wir uns schon so oft gestellt.
Einer der größten Konzerne der Welt, der einem der reichsten Menschen der Welt gehört.
Ja gut, Moment, Moment, man muss ja mal die Prioritäten, man muss ja mal die Prioritäten sehen.
Die Prioritäten sind nicht Prime Video gut zu machen, die Prioritäten sind ins Weltall zu fliegen.
Gehört, operiert eine der größten Streaming-Plattformen überhaupt.
Warum ist die Prime Video Benutzeroberfläche so schlecht?
Und was sagt das über das Unternehmen?
Übrigens, schöne, schöne DRM-freie Musik.
Dahinter aus.
Fleabag, Marvelous Miss Maisel, The Boys, Invincible, etc., etc.
Prime Video hat richtig, richtig gute, preisgekrönte Inhalte.
Der Katalog der Streaming-Plattform ist riesig.
Amazon gibt jedes Jahr zig Milliarden für...
Geht es dir auch so, dass du Hackerfilme und Serien nicht anschauen kannst?
Ja, es gibt ja glücklicherweise nicht so viele.
Ähm, es gibt halt immer Sachen, die halt so eingebaut sind, ja.
Das ist eigentlich ein anderer Film, aber da ist halt irgendwie so ein Hacker-Dude dabei.
Das finde ich halt auch immer ziemlich cringe.
Ich muss sagen, ich fand die erste Staffel, die erste Hälfte,
die erste Hälfte der ersten Staffel Mr. Robot ganz gut.
Das war natürlich auch teilweise, wo du dir gedacht hast,
okay, die Leute haben sich Mühe gegeben,
aber haben es trotzdem nicht so genau verstanden,
weil... Moment, das muss ich euch zeigen.
Mr., Mr., das ist kein Spoiler, es geht überhaupt nicht um die Story.
Mr. Robot, ähm, KDE-Gnome.
Ja, das hier, das hier.
Ich bin ein Exekutiver, der Linux leitet, aber...
Ja, ich weiß, was du denkst.
Ich bin ein Exekutiver, ich meine, warum leite ich sogar Linux?
Das ist, ich finde es cool, es ist, es ist, sag mal, es ist realitätsnäher
als 99% des anderen Technik-Jargons, was da in Filmen und Serien verwendet wird,
aber es ist schon irgendwie an der Realität ziemlich vorbei.
Es, weil, da hört es sich so an, als ist es jetzt irgendwie,
Gnome, neuer als KDE oder KDE, neuer als, also, die richtigen Hackermans,
wenn er richtig, eigentlich hätte, hätte Elliot sagen müssen nach dem Motto
I3-WM oder, oder sowas.
Richtige Hacker oder Text-Interface-Only oder irgendwie sowas, ja.
Ne, aber das, ich fand die erste Hälfte von Mr. Robot,
also die erste, die erste Hälfte, also die, die erste Hälfte der ersten Staffel Mr. Robot
fand ich ziemlich gut.
Danach fand ich es nicht mehr so.
Ich fand es nicht mehr so toll, weil es sich im Prinzip nur noch drum gedreht hat,
welche Störungen und, und Drogenabhängigkeiten der Hauptcharakter hat
und das Ende fand ich kacke von der ersten Staffel,
so kacke, dass ich nie weitergeguckt habe.
So ist es.
... Serien und Filme aus.
Letztes Jahr hat der Konzern für circa 7,7 Milliarden Euro MGM Studios gekauft.
Ach ja, ist ja nix, Schnapper.
Die bringen zum Beispiel James Bond heraus.
Allein die erste Staffel der neuen Herr-der-Ringe-Serie...
Oh Gott.
Leute, ich trau mich gar nicht, mir den Kram anzugucken, falls es rauskommt,
wenn es dann rauskommt.
Ich hab da ganz kurze Bedenken, dass das was wird.
... vor der wir übrigens panische Angst haben, diese CI-Matsche,
warum sind das alles...
Egal, hat rund 426 Millionen Euro gekostet.
Damit ist sie mit Abstand die teuerste...
Ich, ich predikte, ich predikte mal was.
Zu dieser, zu dieser Herr-der-Ringe-Serie.
Und eigentlich ist mir es auch wurscht, ob die...
... die...
... äh, dunkelhäutige Zwergenprinzessin oder sowas drin haben.
Ja, da hat sich ja Twitter wahnsinnig für und gegen und sonst was.
Was mir eigentlich wichtig wäre, weil Herr-der-Ringe ist mein mit Abstand Lieblings-Fantasy-Universum,
dass man versucht, zumindest, eine, eine Story im Sinne, im Geiste der, der ursprünglichen Idee zu erzählen, ja.
Also, dass man nicht zwangsläufig aus der Welt was macht...
... was sie nicht ist.
Soll das nach dem Filmspiel, nee, davor.
Das, das spielt lustigerweise zu einer Zeit, wo man relativ viele Freiheiten hat, ja.
Und es ist nicht so, als gäbe es nicht genug Storys, die man ausschmücken könnte, ein bisschen.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass man bekannte Charaktere rein aus dem Wiedererkennungszweck einbaut,
die wahrscheinlich mit den Vorlagen nicht mehr so viel zu tun haben.
Und dass man aus der Welt...
... etwas machen wird, was wahrscheinlich nicht im Geiste des Originals ist.
Und deswegen habe ich wirklich Bedenken, was da rauskommt am Ende.
Ich habe auch das Gefühl, das wird nix, ja.
So, Wizard, dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich habe, ich habe auch das Gefühl, das wird nix.
Damit ist sie mit Abstand die teuerste Serie aller Zeiten.
Game of Thrones war zum traurigen Schlusspunkt der Serie gerade einmal rund 300...
Game of Thrones? Ich habe die ersten...
Ich habe auch nur die ersten...
Lass mich jetzt nicht...
Ich will jetzt auch nicht spoilern, aber eigentlich kann man da spoilern.
Ehe schon jeder geguckt, aber ich spoile aber nicht.
Ich glaube die ersten drei Staffeln oder so geguckt.
Ich habe lustigerweise Game of Thrones aufgehört zu gucken.
Ich kenne die Bücher nicht, muss ich dazu sagen, ja.
Ähm, weder als Heulbuchvariante noch sonst was, ich kenne die Vorlage nicht.
Ich habe aufgehört zu gucken, wo sie sich, und das habe ich im Nachhinein rausbekommen,
weil ich das Wiki gelesen habe dazu.
Ähm...
Ich habe aufgehört zu gucken, wo sie angefangen haben, sich eigene Storys auszudenken.
Das war...
Ich habe...
Es kann sein, dass ich entweder bis Ende Staffel 3 oder bis Mitte Staffel 4 oder irgendwie sowas geguckt habe.
Und dann...
Dann...
Ich meine, Game of Thrones ist eh schon ultraschleppend in vielen.
Auch die ersten zwei, drei Staffeln, ja.
In vielen Bereichen.
Das ist wirklich...
Das schleppt sich teilweise wirklich hin.
Auf der anderen Seite ist das das Coole daran, du hast eine gewisse Bindung zu den Characters in Game of Thrones.
Einfach...
Weil du eben nicht von einer Szene irgendwie zur nächsten kommst.
Und das ist auch notwendig, weil es gibt halt auch mega viele.
Ja?
Allein schon die erste Staffel Game of Thrones hat irgendwie 140 Leute oder so am Start gehabt.
So.
Und ich habe...
Ich habe genau bis dahin geguckt, wo sie angefangen haben, sich eigenes Zeug auszudenken.
Und ich wusste das zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt nicht.
Ich habe das aber nachher im Wiki gelesen.
Weil ich dachte mir jetzt, irgendwie ist das noch schleppender und noch...
Dann hast du irgendwelche komischen Subplots, die nichts mit dem Rest zu tun haben und sowas.
Und ja.
Ich habe dann...
Ich habe dann im Nachhinein rausgekriegt, ja, das ist quasi...
So Staffel 4 rum ist das, wo sie angefangen haben, quasi, wo die Geschichte aus den Büchern für manche Charaktere zu Ende war, sich Zusatzdinger auszudenken.
Und das hat man gemerkt.
Und ab da hat es mir auch nicht mehr gefallen.
Und das war eh schon schleppend zwischendurch.
Aber auf der anderen Seite war es wirklich gut gemacht.
Und du hast gemerkt, dass da halt jemand eine sinnvolle, konsistente, und das ist ja immer das Wichtige, dass es nicht mehr heute so ist, morgen so, konsistente Welt- und Hintergrundgeschichte hat.
Das war das Gute daran.
Und dass sie sich auch wirklich genau, halbwegs genau daran gehalten haben.
Also...
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe nicht weitergeguckt.
Ich glaube nach Staffel 3...
Ich glaube dreieinhalb Staffel habe ich, glaube ich, geguckt.
Und dann...
Also...
Und dann hatte ich keinen Bock mehr.
80 Millionen Euro teuer.
Das ist ja das geilste Interview.
Genau, best season ever.
Amazon nimmt also richtig Geld in die Hand für Prime Video.
Warum ist die Benutzeroberfläche dann so unfassbar schlecht?
Kategorien funktionieren einfach nicht.
Harry Potter...
Ja, von der Witcher-Serie müssen wir nicht anfangen.
Ich finde, dass die erste Staffel durchaus...
Also, die Witcher-Serie hat in der ersten Staffel durchaus ihre Momente.
Ich fand das nicht alles kacke.
Ja?
Aber...
Ich meine...
Warum macht man...
Das ist das, was ich nicht so genau verstehe.
Warum macht man eine Witcher-Serie?
Und das einzige, was das mit den Vorlagen gemein hat, ist, dass es ein paar Hauptcharaktere
gibt, die den gleichen Namen tragen.
Die erste Staffel war okay.
Ja?
Aber man hat ganz viel Zeug anders gemacht.
Umgewurstelt.
Weggelassen.
Wo ich mir denke...
Wieso?
Ja?
Außerdem war das sehr inkonsistent an vielen Stellen.
Gerade, was sie sich da mit ihrem Rumgezaubere überlegt haben.
Mal geht das so, mal geht das so.
Jetzt kann man das nicht.
Jetzt geht das auf einmal wieder.
Es hat wenig Sinn.
Und ich bin jemand, wenn ich irgendwelche Serien oder Filme gucke...
Wie gesagt, die sind nicht so einfach.
Ich habe es nicht so einfach gemacht.
Wie gesagt, deswegen ist wahrscheinlich Herr der Ringe auch eines meiner Lieblings-Fantasy-Universen.
Ich interessiere mich bei Online-Games beispielsweise null für die Lore oder so.
Aber trotzdem, ich achte irgendwie darauf, dass das irgendwie halbwegs schlüssig in sich
ist.
Ja?
Das muss nicht...
Ich behaupte gar nicht, dass man sich wahnsinnig krass an die Buchvorlage halten muss.
Bei Herr der Ringe haben die auch viel Zeug weggelassen.
Aber es muss irgendwie schlüssig sein ineinander.
Und das schafft die Witcher-Serie in der ersten Serie nicht.
Ansonsten hat man halt auch vieles weggelassen.
Okay.
Zweite Staffel habe ich mir nicht mehr angeguckt.
Hat mich nicht überzeugt.
Aber ich bin eh nicht der ultrakrasse Serien-Grinder, sodass ich quasi wöchentlich Nachschub brauche.
Also, das ist nicht so wild, dass mir das nicht gefallen hat und ich das jetzt nicht weitergucke.
Also, eines der Sachen...
Also, eines der Sachen, die mir im Hinterkopf geblieben sind.
Ich weiß, es gibt ja viele Leute, die fühlen sich wahnsinnig schlau, die sagen, ah, Max,
die Leute verstehen bloß die Zeitsprünge in Season 1 nicht und sowas.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen, okay, es ist nicht der Job irgendwelcher Wikis, zu erklären,
wie der Zusammenhang ist, sondern das sollte der Zuschauer eigentlich von sich aus erschließen
können.
Aber das ist gar nicht mal das Problem.
Also, eines der Sachen, die mir sehr unsinnig aufgestoßen sind, ist, wie random und zur
Situation passend so die Magie in der Witcher-Serie funktioniert.
Ja?
Mal kannst du easy Teleports machen.
Easy.
Du kannst alleine teleportieren.
Du kannst Teleports machen mit Leuten zusammen, die nicht teleportieren können.
Mal geht das aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht.
Ja?
Mal geht das nur kurz.
Mal geht das Langstrecke.
Man weiß es nicht.
Mal dauert das eine Weile.
Mal ist es instant.
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ein Beispiel ohne Namen, um nicht so viel zu spoilern und keinen Namen zu nennen.
Ja?
Es gibt einen, ich nenne mal einen Zauberer.
Eigentlich ist es ja kein Zauberer, ist ja egal.
In der ersten Folge sterben Leute.
Das ist glaube ich nicht so viel gespoilert.
Und der ist dabei.
Er macht nichts.
Später ist er mit Geralt am Start.
Sie geraten auch in eine gefährliche Situation.
Und er teleportiert sich mit Geralt weg.
Wo man sich fragt.
Warum hat er denn bitteschön in Folge 1 nicht die wichtigen Leute wegteleportiert, wenn er doch easy teleportieren kann?
Ich bin mir sicher.
Es gibt irgendwelche Leute, die dann in irgendwelchen Wikis irgendwelche Theorien konstruiert haben.
Warum das doch so ist.
Ja?
Aber das kann es nicht sein.
Und das sind so Sachen, wo ich mir denke.
Alter, das muss euch doch auffallen, wenn ihr sowas zusammen...
Mana Leer, genau.
Das muss...
Hey, ich hätte kein Problem damit.
Ohne Scheiß.
Ich hätte kein Problem.
Wenn die sagen würden.
Mana Leer.
Wenn sie Mana als Magieressource etabliert hätten in der Welt.
Vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ja.
Und das sind halt so inkonsistente Sachen, wo ich sage.
Ja, pff.
Ja, dann hätte ich gesagt.
Genau.
Ich bin out of Mana, Digga.
Einer sagen müssen.
Das hätte ich gefeiert, hätte er das gesagt.
Mana Leer, Alter.
Das ist egal.
Das ist nur, weil das woanders auch...
Herr der Ringe ist, glaube ich, das schlechteste Beispiel für irgendwelche Magie...
Magic Sachen.
Die sind ja da alle ultra vage.
Es gibt ja in Herr der Ringe wenig, wenig wirklich, wie soll man sagen, wenig rumgezaubere.
Ja.
Und es ergibt aber auch rein aus Charactersicht keinen Sinn.
Warum teleportiert er sich mit jemand zwei Stunden später, aber davor, wo es quasi um
das Vernichten einer ganzen Stadt geht, schafft das nicht, die Anführer rauszuteleportieren
und sowas.
Das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Es ist egal, ob man das jetzt sagt.
Mana, nicht Mana, was auch immer.
Warum hat...
Die Erklärung ist eigentlich nicht so sehr, wie die Magie sagt, sondern warum macht er
das nicht?
Wenn er es doch kann.
Das...
Und ja doch, ich weiß, warum er das macht.
Weil es einfach super convenient ist, dass Geralt jetzt an der einen Stelle auftaucht,
wo er auftauchen soll.
Ja.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Dafür hatte die Witcher, die erste Witcher-Serie durchaus ihre guten Momente, ja.
Aber, keine Ahnung, ist auch egal.
Gucken wir mal weiter.
Wollen wir das Video mal irgendwann durchkriegen.
Wir müssen doch wissen, warum Prime Video so schlecht ist.
Stein der Weisen wird als Drama eingeordnet.
Auch auf der Startseite herrscht pures Chaos.
Hier wird mir einfach random Sherlock Staffel 4 vorgeschlagen.
Wollte ich auch schon immer machen, random mit Staffel 4 anfangen.
All das ist seit jeher einfach Standard auf der Plattform.
Auf allen Geräten.
Manche Serien gehen beim Weiterschauen auch einfach...
Expanse, auch so ein Ding.
Ich fand die erste Staffel richtig nice.
Ich hab die zweite Staffel bis zur Hälfte geguckt.
Und dann hab ich mir...
Oder was?
Die dritte war...
Ja doch, ich glaub die zweite Staf...
Ich bin mir gar nicht ganz sicher, ob es die zweite oder dritte war.
Dann hab ich mir gedacht, hä?
Was gibt denn das jetzt, wenn es fertig ist?
Da hatte ich auch keinen Bock mehr weiterzugucken.
Auch einfach irgendwo weiter.
Bei The Expanse wurden wir einmal einfach in die fünfte Staffel teleportiert.
Danke.
Wir haben einen TechRadar-Artikel gefunden, der genau dieses Phänomen beschreibt.
Vor fast zwei Jahren.
Ja, das ist ja auch nicht neu.
Es gibt verschiedene Erklärungsansätze für dieses Drama.
Vorweg, hier beginnt die...
Wie gesagt, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass die ganzen Prime-Services einfach ein Reskin von Amazon sind.
Und das unter der Haube ist das die Amazon-Suche.
Das ist das, was er vorhin...
Das erklärt auch das...
Ich meine, das macht's nicht wirklich besser.
Aber das wird's unterm Strich sein.
Spekulation.
Zunächst wurde Prime Video sehr eindeutig als Ableger der Amazon-Hauptseite.
Genau, das ist es immer noch.
Das Streaming-Angebot war ursprünglich eher ein zusätzlicher Pluspunkt, um Leute dazu zu...
Alter, was ist mit dem seinem Kopf los?
Sekunde, Leute.
Was...
Was geht mit dem seinem Kopf ab?
Threehead, Alter, was ist da los?
Was ist mit dem Dude seinem Kopf?
Das Bild ist nicht richtig, oder?
Die haben...
Die haben das Bild falsch zusammengesetzt.
Das ist aber auch ziemlich mies.
Ach, hier auch.
Aber hier nicht.
Doch, hier auch.
Okay, der hatte...
Der hat beim Scrollen...
Der hat beim Scrollen wahrscheinlich wirklich Screen-Tearing gehabt.
Ja.
Zu bewegen, sich...
Ne, wobei, ne, hat er nicht.
Das movt mit.
Die Bilder sind einfach kaputt bei Amazon.
Ja, gut, kleines Start-Up.
Kann sowas schon mal passieren.
Was sagst du zum Fall Julien Bam?
Da wurde ja gehackt.
Was soll ich zu sagen?
Wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Keylogger oder so eingefangen.
Die Prime Video-Hauptseite.
Was soll ich zu sagen?
Wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Keylogger oder so eingefangen.
Und so sind die beiden Websites weder visuell noch strukturell sauber getrennt.
Richtig.
Das ist genau meine Vermutung.
Noch heute funktioniert die Suche bei Prime Video wie bei der Amazon-Seite selbst.
Ja, genau.
Als würde man nach DVDs schauen.
Tatsächlich sei die gesamte Platte...
Ne, nicht nach DVDs.
Nach Klopapier, USB-Sticks, Kaffeemaschinen.
Dafür ist die Suche gedacht.
Vom, laut Experten, auch heute noch wie ein Webshop angelegt.
Ein zentrales Stichwort sind hier Conversions.
Das ist eine Metrik, die beschreibt, wie viel Prozent aller Beispiele in einem Webshop
letztlich etwas kaufen.
Webshops werden in Bezug auf diesen Wert optimiert.
Wie Produkt...
Äh, Kusvat, die...
Echt?
Und wie?
Wie wurde dein YouTube-Account hackermanned?
Das würde mich jetzt interessieren.
Was war bei dir...
Ähm...
Einfallstore...
Ja, es muss ja kein Keylogger im klassischen Sinn sein.
Wahrscheinlich ist das irgendein Rootkit auf dem Rechner, dass die im Endeffekt, ähm,
sowohl...
Ähm...
Einfallstore...
Ja, es muss ja kein Keylogger im klassischen Sinn sein.
Wahrscheinlich ist das irgendein Rootkit auf dem Rechner, dass die im Endeffekt, ähm,
sowohl...
Ähm...
Einfallstore...
Ja, es muss ja kein Keylogger im klassischen Sinn sein.
Wahrscheinlich ist das irgendein Rootkit auf dem Rechner, dass die im Endeffekt, ähm,
sowohl...
Ähm...
Tastendrücke mitschneiden können, aber auch, ähm...
Browser-Sessions oder...
Ja, Browser-Sessions zum Beispiel.
Ja, Browser-Sessions ist was.
Oder im Endeffekt gar den Rechner fernsteuern können, weil er ist garantiert noch eingeloggt
auf wahrscheinlich Session...
Ja, irgendwie sowas.
Was ich nicht glaube ist, dass, ähm...
Äh...
Die Google-Kanäle, äh...
Die Google-Kanäle mit und ohne die Google-Authentifizierung, Anmeldung irgendwie Probleme hat.
Session-Cookie?
Ja, das könnt ich mir auch vorstellen.
Ja, das könn ich mir...
Aber den, aber du klaust ja nicht einfach mal...
Die...
Den Kram...
Also, du musst...
Der Musste dir auf dem Rechner irgendwas eingefangen haben.
Du warst selber schuld.
Hatte keinen Вторificial Engagement.
Deine sekundäre E-Mail wurde gerne...
Ach so, ok.
Ja, dann ist es bei dir was anderes.
Der Emcor wurde übrigens auch von solche Leuten gehackerman, von irgendwelchen Crypto...
äh.
Scammern.
Das ist wahrscheinlich alles der gleiche...
deswegen einfach linux verwenden mit linux wäre das nicht passiert wisst ihr doch ich weiß die
sind sogar wie heißt der channel jetzt von ihm genau die videos die habe ich geguckt nicht alle
das habe ich teilweise geguckt dass dann das nicht mehr das aber schön da siehst du mal wieder so
was so was zieht so was so was zieht das kann man theoretisch nachher angucken so was zieht einfach
mal bäumen diese hörschrift 30k views sonst 85 wäre das mit linux wirklich nicht passiert
wahrscheinlich nicht wahrscheinlich nicht immer ein potenziell könnt ihr das unter linux
wahrscheinlich auch passieren wenn du irgendwelchen kämpfe runterlädt anklicks installiert was auch
immer das passiert unter windows auf jeden fall einfach und ja unter mac os wäre das wahrscheinlich
auch nicht passiert ja 3f
bringt dir halt nichts wenn du in einem browser eingeloggt bist und du keine ahnung zwei wochen
gültige session hast pengren dankeschön für den für den sub deswegen sage ich ja auch es
unter windows ist es halt einfacher aber wenn es jemand gezielt auf jemand ab sieht das ist
nicht ausgeschlossen dass das unter mac oder linux auch passiert aber unter windows bist du da halt
deutlich anfälliger für was soll es denn da für großartige andere möglichkeiten geben also mir
fällt jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht viel ein
ich weiß ja nicht was er für drei out drei faktor authentifizierung gemacht hat man könnte zum
beispiel noch irgendwie gucken ob man die zwei faktor authentifizierung sms irgendwie hijackt
oder so ist es leicht ein session cookie zu klauen wenn du ein rootkit auf deinem rechner
hast natürlich wenn du ein rootkit auf deinem rechner ist kann im zweifelsfall jetzt mal billig
gesagt jemand ein rechner einfach fernsteuern da musst du überhaupt kein session cookie klauen
dann machst du einfach den original browser auf und gehst auf die seite mit der auch mit dem original
mit seiner original ip mit seiner original browser cash session cookies und alles also wenn du
die irgendeinen mist in den trojaner eingefangen hast natürlich na ja das ist jetzt aber sehr
allgemein gesagt also wenn du geh mal von außen hat wirklich drei faktor authentifizierung da
musst du einen erstmal social engineering dass du an drei faktoren dran kommst ja also das ist
so wie wenn du sagst nichts ist sicher deswegen muss ich nichts verschlüsseln so nach dem motto
Ja, jede Verschlüsselung kann geknackt werden, theoretisch. Praktisch sieht das aber ganz anders aus.
Wenn du irgendwas hast, AES-Verschlüsseltes, mit einem 20-stelligen Passwort, das kannst du selbstverständlich theoretisch knacken.
Da brauchst du ein paar Millionen Jahre Zeit, dass das funktioniert.
Trotzdem ist es sinnvoll, das zu verschlüsseln. Lieblings-Haustor-Abfall.
Na, ich hatte mal in einem MMO, ähm, hatte ich ein Passwort, Katze123, Katze...
Ne, nicht in einem MMO, Schwachsinn.
In einem alten E-Mail-Account, über den dann gesagt wurde, ich hab Spam verschickt, hatte ich mal ein Passwort Katze123, Katze123.
Und es ist mir erst später aufgefallen, dass das keine gute Idee war.
Wobei das Passwort von der Länge her an sich gar nicht...
Ne, ich glaube, ich hatte nur Katze123, nicht Katze123.
Katze123, 1, 2, 3.
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, das ist natürlich viel zu wenig.
Also erstens nur 8 Buchstaben und dann sowas.
Das Ding ist wahrscheinlich in jeder Passwort-Datenbank drinne.
Hatte ich mal bei einer E-Mail-Adresse früher, Katze123, also...
Ja, früher, früher ist wirklich früher gemeint, ja.
2004 oder so.
Kann man einen Trojaner komplett loswerden, indem man Windows neu aufsetzt oder reicht das nicht aus?
Also ich würde sagen, wenn du Windows neu installierst, bist du in der Regel...
Hast du mal auf der sicheren Seite.
Es gibt natürlich Mittel und Wege.
Es gab ja auch schon Berichte über Sachen, die sich irgendwie einrichten in...
Hab ich nicht...
Irgendwelchen anderen Speichern-Sachen.
Von damals BIOS bis vielleicht in irgendwelchen ungenutzten Sektoren auf der Festplatte.
Und dann ist halt wieder die Frage, wie wird es dann wieder aktiv?
Dann hast du vielleicht...
Dateien, die quasi verseucht sind, die du beim nächsten Öffnen installierst.
Und dann ist es wieder, weil du sie halt auf dem Netzlaufwerk liegen hattest und das hatte...
Also, hundertprozentig sicher bist du natürlich nicht.
Damit, aber die allermeisten Sachen solltest du loswerden mit Windows neu...
Also Festplatte formatieren, Windows neu installieren.
Wir haben das Video immer noch nicht durch.
Cake, wait, Alter.
... Produkte platziert werden, wie die Buttons aussehen, wie einfach es ist, am Ende auszuchecken.
Alles in der Hoffnung, dass mehr Besucher zu zahlenden Kunden werden.
Und Prime Video scheint auf Basis dieser Philosophie aufgebaut zu sein.
Überall gibt es Dinge zu kaufen.
Von 14 Highlights ganz oben auf der Website drehen sich 8 um Bezahlinhalte.
Scrollt man nach unten, mischen sich die Reihen mit Inhalten, die man kaufen muss, und die Prime-Inhalte.
Vielleicht ist das die Strategie?
Vielleicht will man gar nicht, dass Leute das riesige Angebot an Prime-Titeln wirklich erkundschaften können.
Sie sollen lieber auf der Startseite hängenbleiben, sich dort Dinge kaufen,
oder von Anfang an nach einem ganz präzisen, hoffentlich kostenpflichtigen Inhalt suchen.
Hm, aber irgendwie hinkt diese Theorie ein wenig.
Prime könnte ja dennoch, ähnlich wie Netflix, ein sauber funktionierendes Such- und Entdecksystem haben.
Dort könnte man ja trotzdem schön viele Bezahlinhalte untermischen.
Es kann einfach kaum im Interesse von Amazon sein.
Ich glaube ehrlich, ich glaube irgendwie ehrlich, Amazon scheißt einfach drauf.
Oder aber, oder aber, wir müssen uns mal die Games von Amazon angucken.
Oder aber, sie sind einfach, sie können es nicht besser.
Vielleicht können sie es einfach nicht besser.
Guckt euch die Games von Amazon an.
Es ist nicht so, dass jetzt irgendwie New World an Geld, also an Manpower, oder darf man eigentlich noch Manpower sagen?
An People Power gescheitert wäre?
Oder an...
Oder an Geld.
Das ist nicht das Problem.
Also, vielleicht können sie es auch einfach nicht.
Dass die Kategorie Romantik genau einen einzigen Inhalt anzeigt,
und dass dieser Inhalt die fünfte Staffel einer Serie ist,
bleibt eine weitere Möglichkeit.
Es juckt das Unternehmen einfach nicht.
Vielleicht, ja.
Aber das ergibt, der Chat hat schon recht, es ergibt eigentlich auch keinen Sinn.
Es ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn, dass es Amazon egal ist.
Das ist schon richtig.
Aber man sollte sagen, eigentlich sollte es Amazon auch nicht egal sein, dass New World kacke ist.
Vielleicht, vielleicht können sie es einfach nicht besser.
Und das liegt wahrscheinlich dann auch noch nicht mal daran, dass sie individuell betrachtet unfähige Leute hätten.
Sondern das ist wahrscheinlich das Zusammenspiel in diesem, im Amazon Enterprise.
Vielleicht sind die, vielleicht sind, sind da auch viele Sachen zu starr.
So nach dem Motto, ähm, du musst das verwenden, obwohl...
Du musst das verwenden, obwohl das nicht dafür geeignet ist, ja.
Zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, ähm, gehen wir jetzt mal von aus,
Amazon hat ein eigenes JavaScript, äh, Frontend, Class Library Gedöns für ihren Shop.
Und die sagen, du musst das verwenden, wenn du einen offiziellen Amazon Service programmierst.
Und dann sagen sie, ja, aber für ein Videoportal eignet sich das überhaupt nicht, so wie das gebaut ist.
Dann sagen die, das ist egal.
Du musst das verwenden.
Das ist Firmenpolicy, du kommst nicht drum vorbei.
Du musst unser Amazon Framework verwenden.
Sowas in der Richtung wahrscheinlich eher.
Die sind nicht quasi, wie soll man sagen, die sind nicht agil genug, ja.
Dann wäre Twitch auch so scheiße.
Nee, Twitch war ja schon vor Amazon da.
Und Prime Video ist von Amazon für Amazon entstanden.
Ich, ich denke mal, dass es sowas in der Richtung ist.
Ein Abstand Platz 2 aller Streaming Services.
Gleichzeitig gibt Amazon zwar Abermilliarden für Inhalte aus, aber trotzdem viel weniger als die Wettbewerber.
Auch heute sei die Plattform für den Konzern laut einigen Analysen deshalb eher ein Teil des Prime Angebotes und kein echtes eigenständiges Business.
Das heißt ja nicht, was ist Prime Video?
Das gesamte Geschäft von Netflix ist Netflix.
Alle Abo-Services von Amazon zusammengenommen haben letztes Jahr zwar knapp 30 Milliarden Euro eingespielt.
Was macht eigentlich Magenta TV so?
Das sind trotzdem gerade einmal knapp 7% des 431 Milliarden Euro Gesamtumsatzes des Konzerns.
Zum Vergleich, fast die Hälfte dieser Summe stammt aus Verkäufen in Online-Stores.
Vor allem natürlich über die Hauptseite.
Vielleicht läuft Prime Video auch so gut genug für seine Zwecke?
Am Ende ist es ja nur ein Bonus für die Prime-Mitgliedschaft,
die wiederum vor allem ein Werkzeug ist, um den riesigen Online-Shop attraktiver zu machen.
Wenn man so gewaltig und dominant ist, wird man vielleicht auch behäbig.
Vielleicht werden interne Prozesse so kompliziert, dass sich am Ende nur noch sehr wenig vorwärts bewegt.
Aber wie schwierig wäre es am Ende, diese Website einfach besser aufzubauen und Inhalte vernünftig zu kategorisieren?
Amazon ist ein riesengroßes Unternehmen.
Daran siehst du auch, dass es wahrscheinlich wirklich was dran ist, was wir gerade vermutet haben.
Das ist so ein typisches Ding, wo man als Außenstehender denkt,
das kann doch nicht so schwer sein.
Und die Frontend-Leute und Backend-Leute, die an Prime Video arbeiten,
die wären dazu technisch wahrscheinlich auch ohne Probleme in der Lage.
Aber wahrscheinlich gibt es irgendwelche unsinnigen Konzern- oder Enterprise-Vorgaben,
dass sie die Technologien verwenden müssen dafür, die dafür nicht gedacht sind.
Das beste Beispiel ist doch Amazon Games, die die ganze Zeit ihren komischen CryEngine-Fork verwendet haben.
Obwohl die Entwickler gesagt haben, so ein Bullshit, Alter.
Den Kram will keiner verwenden.
Also wer es nicht weiß, Amazon Games hat da die CryEngine geforkt.
Und da was Eigenes rausgebracht.
Ich habe vergessen, wie hieß denn der Kram? Wood? Woodland? Nee.
Forest... Forestland? Oder...
Wie hieß denn der Kram von... Wie hieß der Kram von Amazon...
Lumberyard! Genau.
Ey, ihr müsst sagen, ich war mit Woodland und so gar nicht so weit von.
Ja, Lumberyard war es. Lumberyard, genau.
Das ist ein CryEngine-Fork. Oder kein...
Nee, die CryEngine ist nicht Open Source, aber Amazon hat sich die Rechte irgendwie da dran gekauft.
Das verwenden zu dürfen. Das ist ein CryEngine-Fork.
Also man hat sich dafür entschieden wohl, die Engine mit einer der schlechtesten Dokumentationen ever zu benutzen,
zu forken und für ihre eigenen Projekte zu verwenden.
Naja.
Man hätte auch einfach Unreal oder Unity verwenden können, wo man einfacher Leute für findet und...
Nee, was auch immer.
Also...
Das war auch lange Zeit bei Amazon so ein Ding, wo sie gesagt haben, nein, nein, wir verwenden unseren komischen CryEngine-Fork.
Und die Entwickler haben gesagt, alter, so ein Kack, das wollen wir nicht, das ist Müll.
Und ich gehe davon aus, dass das bei Prime Video ähnlich ist.
Die müssen dort Technologien verwenden, weil es eben quasi Business Enterprise Strongs Vorgabe ist,
obwohl es sich nicht eignet für eine Videoplattform.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es eine zentrale ContentDB bei Amazon.
Und wenn du da suchen willst, die ist nicht dafür ausgelegt, Serien zu suchen.
Die ist dafür ausgelegt, aber DynamoDB, ist das das?
Keine Ahnung, ob die DynamoDB verwenden.
Habe ich noch nie benutzt.
Aber das könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Denken wir uns mal, die haben irgendeine Suchfunktion für ihre Datenbank und die ist halt nicht in der Lage,
anhand der Daten, anhand von Serienmetadaten eine sinnvolle Suche durchzuführen,
sondern vielleicht nur anhand von einem Titel.
Und dann hast du halt so ein Ding, dass in Prime Video Suche eben Staffel 3 vor Staffel 1 steht und sowas.
Wenn man eine halbe Milliarde für eine Serie rausballert, warum kümmert man sich dann nicht um all das hier?
Was ist los, Jeff?
Die Benutzeroberfläche von Prime Video ist in vielerlei Hinsicht ein Enigma.
Immerhin wisst ihr jetzt, wenn eure Serie mal wieder in irgendeiner zufälligen Folge, in einer zufälligen Staffel weitergeht,
ihr seid nicht allein.
Hehe.
Cheers.
Hey, hoffentlich hat euch dieses Video gefallen.
Schreibt uns unbedingt in die Kommentare,
was ihr über Prime Video denkt.
Auf der Endcard findet ihr ein Video von...
Ups.
Das ist ein bisschen so, wie Battlefield 2042 DICE auch riesen Probleme hatte mit Frostbite.
Und sie mussten Frostbite verwenden.
Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass bei DICE einige gesagt haben,
Alter, warum verwenden wir nicht was anderes?
Und ich hab gesagt, nein, ihr verwendet Frostbite.
Tja.
Kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
Was das da ähnlich ist.
Kann man eigentlich auf so Videos reacten?
Ich mein, das ist YouTube, da weiß man nie, was man darf und was man nicht darf.
So.
Nein, Ubuntu muss ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
React for the Haters.
BFStats?
Gibt's... BFStats gibt's nicht mehr.
Achso, Spielzahlen. Ja, Spielzahlen sind immer noch schlecht, aber ein bisschen besser geworden seit dem Patch.
React for the Haters. Ja.
Ja, schauen wir doch mal.
React für die Haters.
A half-baked functional UI library created at Facebook that's used by millions of developers because it has a cool name and logo.
It was invented by Mark Zuckerberg in 2013.
Ich will nicht wissen, wie viele das jetzt glauben.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wer React erfunden hatte.
Aber ich garantiere euch, es war nicht der Zug.
2013.
Gucken wir doch mal.
React, äh...
Fuck, was heißt denn Erfinder?
Äh... äh...
Inventor.
Nee, nee, nicht Founder. Founder ist Gründer. Gründer. Inventor.
Hier. Der.
Der sieht nicht aus wie Zuckerberg, oder?
John Wock. Wocky. Keine Ahnung, wie man den ausspricht.
Der hat React erfunden.
Ich wusste, dass das Fake ist.
Garantiert hat nicht der Zug React erfunden.
Warum sagt das das Video dann? Weil das, weil das CheapAid ist.
Big mistake.
And it was my mistake.
And I'm sorry.
React is simple. It's just JavaScript, bro.
And that's why it gives you dozens of weird ways to solve the same problems.
Like functional and class-based components, hooks, forward ref, higher order components, mixins...
Hey!
Das, das, das Emote hat gut reingepasst, oder?
Das, ich hab's aus Versehen gedrückt.
Render profs, suspense, and so on.
It's credited as the first declarative UI library, even though it took most of those ideas from AngularJS.
Its killer feature, though, is the fact that...
Wohlgemerkt Angular 1 und nicht das, was heute Angular ist.
Its killer feature, though, is the fact that you can write pure functional code.
That is, until you want to do anything useful...
Sag mal, Leute. React-Kenner. Ich hab keine Ahnung von React.
Kann man mittlerweile sein HTML eigentlich als HTML schreiben, oder muss man das immer noch JSX inline schreiben?
Und wenn ja, warum haben die nicht irgendwie was wie Single-File-Components mittlerweile gemacht in React,
wo du dein CSS, HTML und JavaScript in einer Datei schreiben kannst, aber HTML in HTML und nicht HTML in JavaScript?
Warum ist das so? Oder ist das noch so? Keine Ahnung.
In this case you'll need to write impure functions with state and effects.
The beauty of this approach is that it makes simple things like reactive state much more complicated than they need to be.
And that's what makes us feel like real developers.
UseEffect is especially fun and was originally going to be called UseFootGun,
because it's a great way to introduce infinite loops, performance issues and bugs that you'll never be able to figure out.
Not to worry, though, React is always evolving with revolutionary new features
to monkey patch all the weirdness nobody saw coming on the previous release.
Now, even though it has an extremely high learning curve, React is a library and not a framework.
And that means to build something cool, you'll need to find and install hundreds of different packages,
most of which were built by teenagers who stopped maintaining them years ago
when they went off to college to learn a real language like C.
To get started, create a new React app, then open up Google
to enter the gates of tutorial hell.
Notice how we start in strict mode. That's used to hide baggage from previous versions of the framework.
I mean library.
Now in the code, we pretend we're doing functional programming by writing our components as functions.
Classes are also possible, but they are literally the devil.
Instead, we use these hooks everywhere that do the same shit classes do in a more magical, hipstery way.
Templating is handled in JSX.
A standard way to write HTML, which allows you to represent the UI entirely in...
Ja, deswegen musst du, deswegen musst du ja auch in React anstatt class class name schreiben und solche ekligen Dinger.
Warum? Weil class in JavaScript ein Keyword ist, was reserved is.
...on portable callback hell.
Now, we can all agree to hate CSS, but React will make you hate it even more when you try to style something on your own.
Luckily, there are hundreds of CSS and JS libraries working on this problem as we speak.
The extra complexity is worth it though.
Because React is blazingly fast, assuming you implemented all the weird tricks flawlessly.
Life is about suffering.
It's not supposed to be fun like Svelte.
Or fast like Solid.
Or reliable like Angular.
Or all of the above like Vue.
The only thing that matters is React is the most popular.
And that makes it undeniably the best.
Just like Microsoft makes the best operating system and McDonald's makes the best food.
Windows is ja eindeutig das beste OS.
React has been the most influential library in front-end web development for the last decade.
Das stimmt wohl, ja.
Nothing perfect.
But it got to where it is today because it does a lot of things right.
And for that, it deserves our respect.
Thanks for watching and I will see you in the next one.
Tschüss.
Ohne Scheiß, das, was mich bei Windows 11 mit Abstand am meisten abfuckt, ist, dass ich meine Tastleiste nicht mehr so haben kann wie hier.
Weil er automatisch groopt und so ein Rotz.
Wer will sowas?
Wer will automatisches Grooping haben, Mann?
Ich hab nicht umsonst einen Widescreen-Monitor.
Dass ich Widescreen machen kann.
Das ist das Gegenteil von Pepo White Happy, was die machen mit Windows 11.
Der Account-Zwang ist auch richtig dumm.
Ich weiß nicht, wenn das schon bleibt.
Aber wenn er doch ein Power-User ist, wenn man einfach seine Sachen sehen will.
Ach, Microsoft, shit, alter.
Die machen auf der einen Seite viele sinnvolle Sachen,
was die mit .NET machen, ist nice.
Visual Studio Code ist nice.
Was ich mit Github und auch in Azure ist vieles, wenn auch ein bisschen umständlich nice.
Aber was Windows ist, ist komplette Shit-Show.
Was die treiben.
Warum ist für Rechtsklick ein weiterer Klick nötig?
Was ich nur rechts einmal klicken.
Oder was? Hä? Hä? Wie?
Verstehe nicht.
Oder meinst du, warum du Rechtsklick nicht mit Linksklick
machen kannst? Was? Wie?
Verstehe nicht.
Zimmerboard sagt mir nix. Keine Ahnung.
Was?
Windows 11?
Hä? Man muss in Windows 11 doppelt
Rechtsklicken? Moment!
Das war nicht nur in der Beta so. Das ist jetzt
in der Live-Version immer noch so.
Ich dachte, das war ein Überbleibsel
aus der Beta-Version, die wir uns angeguckt haben.
Ihr meint diese
Geschichte hier,
dass wenn du hier klickst, dass du dann nicht dieses
Menü klickst, sondern auf Legacy-Menü
aufmachen gehen musst. Das ist
wirklich im Live-Windows? Ernsthaft?
Nein! Nein!
Nein!
Die haben den Arsch offen, oder?
Aber, aber
komplett bei Microsoft.
Das ist doch unfassbar.
So schlecht.
Man kann das wenig... Ja gut.
Gut, dass die Zeit der Registry-Hacks
und
25 Tipps, die nicht mal Microsoft kennt,
nie aufhören wird durch diesen Shit.
Dü-dü-dü-dü-dü.
Ja, warum verstehe ich auch nicht?
Wenn das möglich ist,
ist es bestimmt keine schlechte Idee,
aber
wenn ihr normale 0815-Desktop-Anwender
habt, die kriegen Abfacke unter Linux.
Nicht so sehr, weil es
nicht gehen würde, gerade wenn du Software verwendest,
die es halt auch unter Linux gibt oder eh hauptsächlich
im Browser läuft, sondern weil
die kleinste Umstellung,
abfacke ist für den normalen Anwender.
So, was können wir uns sonst noch angucken, Leute?
Gibt es irgendwelche... Haben wir hier vielleicht
ein paar Videos offen, die wir gucken?
Was haben wir hier eigentlich alles auf?
Mario-Musik, Mario-Musik, Mario-Musik,
ein CCC-Talk, den wir uns jetzt nicht angucken,
weil der eine Stunde lang geht.
Und auch mehr Musik.
Aber wir können das Video angucken von
How to be a Linux User.
Wie heißt das?
Was ist das für ein Thumbnail, Alter?
Sekunde.
When you are new to a group,
sometimes it's hard to fit in.
New to Linux users often find
that it is hard for them to fit in with
long-time Linux users.
The long-time Linux user,
it's almost like he is of a different
culture and has different mannerisms
and traditions. He speaks a different
language. So what can the new
Linux user do to become...
Artstehungsinstallieren, das ist eh das Beste.
Get away.
...more like the long-time Linux user?
First, grow a neckbeard.
Every group, every tribe of people have
their own customs as far as dress and
body decorations. As much as tattoos are
a vital part of Pacific Islander cultures,
the neckbeard is that for the Linux
community. Grow it long and wear it with
pride. The second thing you can do is
only... Nicht zu verwechseln mit dem
Hipster-Bart, der aktuell auch sehr
angesagt ist. ...use really old thinkpads.
...use really old thinkpads. ...use really old thinkpads.
You will never gain any street cred in the
Linux community. ...in the Linux community.
Ja gut, da ist was dran. Das liegt aber daran,
weil die IBM Thinkpads unter Linux immer
super supported waren. Beziehungsweise da
Hardware drin ist, die super supported
war. Und leistungstechnisch ist meistens
ausreichend. Ja, da ist aber schon was
dran. Thinkpads werden von vielen Linux
Usern immer noch sehr hoch gehalten.
...by using nice equipment. The older and
the crappier your computer is, the
better. Übrigens, ich habe jetzt so oft
Linux gesagt, Leute, wo ist dann
eigentlich das Allow Me to
Inter...
...to Inter...
Intercept for a Moment Meme jetzt.
Hast du einen neuen Laptop bekommen
und es funktioniert eigentlich alles. Ja, ich denke
auch nicht, dass es irgendwie großartige Probleme
gibt, dass was nicht funktionieren wird.
Also unter Windows 11 funktioniert der ganze
Kram wahrscheinlich genauso wie unter 10, aber
mich nervt das Gegängele einfach.
Von Account-Zwang
bis zu, ich muss jetzt,
obwohl ich einen Widescreen-Monitor habe,
ich muss jetzt die Sache
gegroobt haben, obwohl ich sie nicht gegroobt haben will.
Solche Geschichten.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum neue
Releases heutzutage quasi mehr
Gängelungen bedeuten bei allen möglichen
Zeugnissen. Gerade diese Funktion, die sie
jetzt testen mit, du kannst
Windows noch nicht mal ohne Microsoft-Account mehr
installieren. Das kann es doch echt nicht sein.
Das geht mir mega auf den Keks.
Leute, ich habe sogar einen MongoDB-Aufkleber
auf meinem Notebook. Ich weiß nicht, was mich da
geritten hat. Ich habe normalerweise
mit NoSQL-Datenbanken überhaupt nichts am Hut.
Aber ich habe einen MongoDB-Aufkleber.
...on it as you can. You want stickers
displaying penguins, of course, as well as
news, distro logos
and, of course, hacking and security stickers.
At this point
you're ready for step three, which is
stop going outside.
There's nothing out there for you anyway.
Everything you could ever want in life
can be found at the command prompt.
So train yourself to immediately recognize
things like sunlight and grass.
And as soon as you see them,
run, don't walk, back to the safety
of your computer.
Number four.
Shaving, haircuts and showering.
Ich meine, guck mal.
Warum soll ich rausgehen,
wenn ich mir auf YouTube einfach ein Video von draußen
angucken kann?
Da gehe ich zum Beispiel,
keine Ahnung, weil eben im Chat,
da gehe ich zu Reloadiac beispielsweise auf dem Channel
und gucke mir irgendwie Lost Places an. Es ist genug draußen.
Genug in freier
Wildbahn reicht doch schon.
Warum soll ich raus, Alter?
Das ist doch...
Ich gebe zu, meinen Twitter-Posts
widersprechen der Sache.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit viele Fotos von draußen gepostet.
Aber in Wirklichkeit
ist das ja eigentlich nur, weil ich fake...
Also, ich tue ja auch nur so,
als würde ich rausgehen.
Number four.
Shaving, haircuts and showering
are frowned upon.
Why are you trying to look good?
You no longer leave your house.
Oh Gott, dieses Foto.
Please.
In your house, because, well,
number five, you must be alone.
Pippo, fett Foto, Alter.
Linux-Users don't have girlfriends, wives,
significant others.
Society is a concept we are unfamiliar with.
And friends, well, they're allowed...
Sag mal,
außer auf Stock-Fotos,
niemand
sieht so aus, wenn er eine VR-Brille
aufhat, oder?
Also niemand spielt so mit einer VR-Brille
und niemand
guckt so mit einer VR-Brille.
Das ist doch eins,
für irgendwelche Stock-Fotos.
But only if they are online.
And the sixth way that you,
the new Linux-User,
can become like the long-time Linux-User
is, tell everyone that you use Vim.
Long-time Linux-Users
constantly brag how...
Du kannst, vielleicht Emacs,
vielleicht auch noch Emacs.
Wie ist das eigentlich,
wenn man heutzutage noch
Sublime-Text verwendet, Chat?
Ist das, ähm,
wird das noch gerne gesehen,
oder ist das eher schon...
Also geht, darf man das noch sagen, ja?
Also ich verwende keinen Sublime-Text mehr.
Ich hab lange Zeit gern Sublime-Text verwendet.
Ich seh mich heute, ehrlich gesagt,
erstaunlich oft in Visual Studio Code
und irgendwelchen fetten Jetbrains-EDEs.
...how awesome they are, because they use Vim.
Now, I know what you're thinking.
Vim is difficult to learn.
Don't worry.
You don't actually have...
Wenn du es einmal geschafft hast,
wieder rauszukommen, ist alles gut.
...to learn Vim, or even use Vim.
Just tell people that you use it, but secretly,
just tell people that you use it, but secretly,
keep using Nano, like a normal person.
but secretly, keep using Nano, like a normal person.
Nee, Nano ist...
Ohne Scheiß.
Nano verwende ich nie.
Never.
Nano.
Vim auf der Kommandozeile,
oder eben
Jetbrains-EDEs oder Visual Studio Code,
wenn's um Anwendungen geht.
Auf der Kommandozeile Vim only, Leute.
Nano, alter.
Du kannst Nano nicht mal gescheit längere Textfiles editieren
mit der Tastatur.
Nano ist ein normaler Texteditor,
mit dem Unterschied, dass du die Maus nicht drinnen verwenden kannst.
Ehm, wobei es wahrscheinlich
irgendwie sogar funktioniert.
Vim.
Also, glücklicherweise ist Vim mehr oder weniger auf 99,9 Prozent Default.
Also, drauf.
Aber wenn什麼 nichts, erste was ich installiere, ist Vim voll.
Ob jetzt die Linux Crowd so krasse Anime-Fans sind,
weiß ich noch nicht.
Aber, aber, ich ...
Ja, doch, da gibt's bestimmt Werbespielen.
Große Überschneidung, könnte ich mir vorstellen
Alles klar, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid
Okay, das lasse ich mir gefallen
Als Anwendungszweck
Weil du weniger Key-Shortcuts
Und komische
Key-Kombinationen
Übertragen musst und sowas
Ja, da lasse ich mir das gefallen
Okay, aber für die meisten
Anderen Sachen
Wim Beste
Wenn es einfach nur auf Kommando-Zeit um Text editieren geht
Ja, das Gute an Nano ist ja
Dass er vorinstalliert ist, genauso wie
Bei den meisten
Zumindest bei Debian ist, ist bei Debian eigentlich Nano noch Default?
Flo, danke für den Sub
Geht's bei euch
Um Emacs?
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob
Emacs Lisp wirklich ein Vorteil ist
Also, alles was ich von
Von diesem Emacs Lisp
Gesehen habe bisher ist
Ach, du meinst Language-Server-Protokoll, nicht Lisp
Okay, dann, alles klar
Ja, okay
Okay
Ja, aber ob Wim oder Neo-Wim
Ist jetzt ja erst einmal wurscht
Die meisten Leute kommen wahrscheinlich nie
Äh, wie soll ich sagen
In den Genuss quasi zu sagen
Hey, ähm, ich benutze jetzt Funktionen
Die nur Neo-Wim hat und Wim nicht
Das sind dann Leute, die 5 Seiten
Wim-RC haben
Und ich spreche da aus Erfahrung, ich hatte früher auch die
Mega-Wim-RC und mindestens 30
Verschiedene Plugins und so
Und ich konnte mein Wim gar nicht mehr aktualisieren
Weil es dann irgendwie gebraked ist
Wenn ich meine App
Wenn ich meine App, wenn ich meine App
Wenn ich meine Plugins aktualisiert habe
Haben sich 30 Plugins aktualisiert
Und es ging irgendwas nicht mehr
Es sind alles mögliche drin
Also mein Wim war overengineert
Als fuck früher
Heute habe ich eine Wim-RC mit
Keine Ahnung, 30 Zeilen Standard-Zeug
Und gut ist
Und ich glaube, nur nicht mal
Großartig viele Plugins
Moin Michael, 5. Spieljahren
Haben wir noch irgendwas, was wir uns angucken können?
Ne, Ubuntu 29 spielen, gucke ich mir jetzt bestimmt nicht an
Home-Nexus-Spieler
Network-Server-Rack
Ja, da gucke ich ja immer gerne, was andere Leute so treiben
Wo geht's denn los?
Erstmal skippen zur Technik
Gut, easy, erstmal übersprungen
So muss das sein
Was bauen sich denn andere Leute?
Okay, der hat wirklich ein Full-Sized-Rack
Wobei, ist das nach hinten wirklich Full?
Ja, wahrscheinlich
Ähm
Leute, was hat denn so ein Standard-Rack für eine Höhe?
48 HE?
Ne, ist ein bisschen viel, oder?
Was hat denn so ein...
Ne, das, ne, wobei
Was hat denn so ein Stand...
42?
48?
Irgendwie so
Okay, er hat einfach mal einen Monitor drinstehen
Ja, so kann man seinen Platz im Rack auffüllen
32 HE, 42 HE, irgendwie so
Wow
Alter, was haben die da immer drinne?
Für daheim
Okay, irgendeine Storage-Kiste
1, 2, 3 Dell-Kisten
4 Dell-Kisten
Noch mehr Storage-Kisten
Was machen die denn da immer daheim damit?
So, starting at the top
I just have a little monitor
Just so I, if I need to, I can plug in a cable to any of these servers
Ja gut, das ist nicht verkehrt
And I actually get direct access
Starting at the top
By the way, these are all Dell-Servers
So, starting at the top
I have the R...
Ja, die Stromkosten sind bald teurer als die Anschaffungskosten
This is my Unraid-Server
Das da ist dein Unraid-Server
Oder was war's denn?
At the top, I have the R520
Ja
This is my Unraid-Server
Ja gut, da hat er...
Then I have an R320
This one runs Windows...
400!
Das...
Das stimmt doch nicht, was da vorne draufsteht, oder?
Das sind einfach nur die Wechselrahmen
Und da sind andere, andere, ähm...
HDDs drin
Also ich mein, seriously
600G, 400G
Das kann jetzt sein
Das, das wär mega useless
Unsinnig!
Da fährst du ja besser
Ach, SSDs vielleicht
Okay!
Wenn das SSDs sind, hab ich nix gesagt
SSDs wären okay
Da steht ja auch SSD drunter, oder?
Nee, 15K?
Nee, nur das hier sind SSDs
Das hier sind SSDs
Und das sind Platten irgendwie
Die 400er sind SSDs und das andere...
Ja, aber hier nicht
Hier steht 15K
Das sind Disks, das sind Disks und das sind SSDs
Aber trotzdem zu klein!
Geile Servernamen sagt das denen?
Ich weiß nicht
Das sind auf jeden Fall schlechte Filme
Mag, mag nice Servernamen sein, aber...
...
Ach da!
Was sonst?
...
Ja stell dir mal fort, der hat nen Space im Servernamen
Cringe!
Warum haben die...
...
Warum hast du...
... ...
...
Ich mein...
... ... ... wenn man das zum Üben macht...
Das ist vollkommen in Ordnung, aber als produktives, ich nenne es mal produktives System, daheim ist das doch ein bisschen overkill. Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen, dass alles, was du zusätzlich hast zu der Funktion, die du brauchst oder halt auch nur quasi Infrastruktursachen, damit du deine Sachen laufen kannst, da musst du dich alles drum kümmern.
Und wir haben doch mal ein Video geguckt von einem, der irgendwie zig Kubernetes Cluster daheim hat, wo ich mir gedacht habe, der Kerl, der macht ja Vollzeit nichts anderes, als sich um seinen Rack daheim zu kümmern. Das kann doch nicht so eine Zweck der Sache sein.
Der nächste, der ist mein großer Junge, der R720. Dieser hat Plex und ein paar andere verschiedene Services.
Er hat ein Quadro P2000 in dem, das ist unglaublich.
Und dann der nächste, der ist ein Dell MD1200.
Das hat er bestimmt alles günstig auf Ebay geschossen, was anderes kann ich mir nicht erklären.
Das ist noch nicht aufgebaut, wie du siehst, gibt es keine Blinker-Lampen, aber das wird in der Zukunft aufgebaut, wenn ich meine Hände auf ein paar mehr High-Drives bekomme.
Nächste Sache, ich habe meinen HP-Printer.
Warum ist der im Rack?
Und dann habe ich ein 15.
Warum hat er den Rack und den Monitor im Rack stehen?
Irgendeine USV oder so, hä?
13.000, ach nee, also 1.300, okay, das ist was anderes.
Das ist okay.
Das ist für Backup.
Ah, der druckt sich den Storage-Spinär aus.
Ja, klar.
Ja, klar, verstehe.
Ja, schau mal, die Back auf geht's.
Flix.
Ich meine, immerhin, immerhin RGB drin, ja?
Wobei, das ist gar kein RGB drin, das ist irgendein Mainboard-LED, die halt einfach blau leuchtet.
Was war das eigentlich von vorne da oben?
Was sehen wir denn eigentlich hier von...
Wir sind mal 30...
Ja, 14.
Was sehen wir denn da eigentlich gerade von hinten?
Äh, was genau sehen wir da von hinten?
Ja, aber die Switches müsste ich doch von vorne auch sehen.
Wo sind die?
Ah, vielleicht hier da drinnen?
Hinter dem Monitor?
Nee, da passt nichts hin.
Meint ihr, die sind so kurz, dass die hinter dem Monitor passen?
So, I do always have it easily accessible.
Ja, ja.
Ah, hier ist der Monitor.
Ach, die sind...
Okay, das ist...
Die sind so kurz, das passt.
Okay, die sind hinter dem Monitor, alles klar.
Flix.
Keiner da zwei Raspberry Pis drinne?
Ja, guck mal, da ist er.
Sowas wollte ich mir aber ausdrucken, war mir dann aber zu umständlich.
So ein Raspberry Pi-Rack-Mount-Ding.
Kann man sich auch fertig holen.
Dauert zu lang, den Kram selbst zu drucken.
Ähm, zwei Raspberry Pis und was hat er da?
Vielleicht irgendein KVM-Switch oder so?
Ja gut, so sehen die Dell-Dinger halt aus von hinten.
Ah, jetzt kriegen wir es auch erklärt.
Ich muss jetzt auch mal was Unpopuläres sagen.
Ich bin...
Ich mag Unify-Sachen nicht.
Ich hab selbst Unify.
Access Points, vier Stück.
Und...
Warte mal, vier Stück?
Selbstgeschoss?
Keller, erster Stock, andere...
Ja, vier Stück.
Ähm, und ein Unify-Controller auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Die Dinger funktionieren.
Also es ist schon okay.
Aber ich...
Ich...
Mag's nicht wirklich.
Also, erstens...
Was mir nicht gefällt, ist, dass man überhaupt sowas wie einen Controller braucht.
Okay, verstehe ich irgendwie die Vorteile von einem Controller.
In dem Fall, dass du das da einstellst und das automatisch deployed auf alle Access Points oder so.
Okay.
In großer Installation, wenn man da vielleicht hunderte hat, in Ordnung.
Bei vier, denke ich, ist es noch...
noch denkbar, das ohne zu machen.
Ich weiß, du brauchst nicht wirklich einen Controller.
Das geht auch mit der Smartphone-App, aber das macht ja keiner.
Ja.
Und dass es halt so undurchsichtig ist, was was ist.
Also, du hast bei diesem Unify-Zeug sehr, sehr viel Magic.
Du hast dann zum Beispiel Häkchen...
Opti...
Auto-Optimierung.
Ja, da hast du keine Ahnung, was der im Hintergrund macht.
Ähm...
Viele Sachen sind so...
Du weißt...
Du weißt einfach nicht genau, was es treibt und es ist dann anders benannt und...
Und wenn halt was nicht funktioniert, dann weißt du nicht, was du machen sollst, ja?
Funktioniert beispielsweise die Auto-Discovery nicht richtig, hast du keine Ahnung, was du machen sollst.
Ich hab zum Beispiel ein Wireless-Uplink auf der anderen Seite vom Stockwerk, weil ich da kein Kabel hab.
Und...
Der hat ums Verrecken nicht Auto-Discovered.
Ich hab...
Hab da ewig gebraucht für, bis ich's gecheckt hab.
Und solche Dinge.
Also...
Es ist mir auf der einen Seite zu viel...
Unify weiß ich nicht, an was ich das richten soll.
Auf der einen Seite denkt man sich, ja, das richtet sich daran, die richtig große Installationen machen wollen.
Auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir, es richtet sich an irgendwelche Home-Noobs, die eigentlich überfordert sind von...
Von Settings, die ordentlich heißen.
Aber das kann ja nicht sein.
Entweder richtest du dich...
An große Installationen, dann sind das Profis, oder du richtest dich an Home-Noobs.
Dann machst du es so wie die Fritzbox zum Beispiel.
Aber Unify ist so ein...
Keine Ahnung, so ein halbgares Ding.
Das Einzige, was Unify-Access-Points bei mir rettet, ist, dass die Access-Points an sich halt ganz okay sind.
Ansonsten denkt der ganze Kram drumherum...
Pfff...
Keine Ahnung, so geil ist es.
Das ist nett.
Und deswegen würde ich mir auch nie im Leben als zentraler Firewall-Router-Lösung eine Unify-Kiste hinstellen daheim.
Im Leben nicht.
Es ist fantastisch.
Du hast es nie mit dir zu tun.
Es ist immer runnend.
Immer runnend und funktionierend sollte eigentlich die Grundlage eines jeden halbwegs ordentlichen Netzwerkequipments sein.
Mikrotik. Mikrotik finde ich nice.
Ich habe auch einige Sachen von Mikrotik.
Wobei ich sagen muss, die Access-Points...
Als ich das letzte Mal geschaut habe...
...hab mich nicht wirklich überzeugt.
Mikrotik-Router sind nice und gerade auch die etwas größeren Mikrotik-Switche, wo du teilweise 24 Port SFP Plus bekommst für um die 450 Euro und sowas.
Da kannst du nichts sagen.
Auch die kleineren, auch die Mikrotik-Router für 50, 60 Euro sind top.
Und auch die Einsteiger-Switches mit 24 Gigabits, 2x10 Gigabit sind wirklich preis-leistungstechnisch unschlagbar.
Das einzige Problem bei Mikrotik ist, dass eben Router-OS...
Tja.
Router-OS ist das Gegenteil von Unify.
Bei Unify hast du ein paar nichtssagende Häkchen, kannst aber viele Sachen gar nicht einstellen.
Bei Router-OS heißen die Dinger irgendwie noch korrekt, sind aber nicht sinnig angeordnet und viel zu viele.
Also das ist das komplette Gegenteil.
Also ich weiß nicht, wer schon mal die Ehre hatte, WLANs einzurichten unter Router-OS.
Das ist sehr, sehr unintuitiv.
Äh, die Mikrotik-Boards, das sind quasi die Boards, die in ihren fertigen Routern mit drin sind.
Die kannst du dir irgendwie einzeln kaufen, wüsste ich aber nicht, warum man das machen sollte.
Es ist schrecklich.
Nächste Sache, mein USW-Aggregation-Switch.
Das hat 8x10 Gigabit-Porte.
Wisst ihr, was ich bei diesem Unify-Zeug auch glaube?
Es haben ja so viele Leute.
Ich habe das Unify im Einsatz daheim und das ist ja nicht billig und ich glaube, viele Leute fallen da wieder in dieses Denkmuster rein.
Ich habe jetzt quasi mir für 1000 Euro Netzwerk-WLAN-Equipment gekauft und selbst wenn es irgendwie nicht funktioniert, kann ich es nicht schlecht finden, weil damit müsste ich mir ja eingestehen, ich habe vielleicht doch nicht für das geilste der Welt 1000 Euro ausgegeben.
Wie gesagt, ich habe das Unify-Zeug, aber ich feiere es nicht so super an.
Aber ich habe es leicht congestioniert.
Ich habe es natürlich gut.
Ich habe es nicht so super an, war es mit einem 500er und
dass 5G fähige Geräte auf 5G gezwungen sind.
5 Gigahertz, nicht 5G.
Ich habe es nicht geregelt.
5 Gigahertz fähige Geräte
auf 5 Gigahertzfähiger Geräte.
Auf 5 Gigahertzfähiger Geräte.
5 Gigahertzfähiger Geräte
gigahertz wlan gezwungen werden ist doch komplett für arsch
warum ist so was default man
es ist halt nun mal so
erwiesenermaßen
dass 2,4 gigahertz wlan
weiterreicht als 5 gigahertz wlan in der regel ja es macht durchaus sinn
in 5 gigahertz zu joinen wenn 5 gigahertz verfügbar ist aber wenn ich an der grenze bin
wo 5 gigahertz zum beispiel nicht mehr richtig funktioniert aber
2,4 gigahertz noch klappt
warum sollte mich das mein nächstes point verbieten bzw was auch immer es dann am ende ist
das ist default bei unify das ist total bescheuert
flawless ja haben wir schon gelernt
siehste
da hätte er sich auch irgendeinen x-beliebigen mikrotik switch kaufen können da hätte er für hundert paar gequetschte euro
einen fetten switch bekommen oder für weiß nicht was er einen fetten switch bekommen
mit 2 x 10 gigabit uplink und 24 gigabit ports easy der bräuchte gar keine 3 switche
war blöde frage für was verwenden die meisten leute eigentlich
also was sind so die
features von dieser also diese diese diese
tree machine geschichte oder so darum das ist ja quasi so die security firewall routing lösung von
unify was machen die meisten leute eigentlich damit
Dass man das überhaupt braucht ich habe jetzt auch schon einige youtube videos auf deutsch gesehen die das mega abfeiern was machen die denn damit
was machen die damit was man nicht mit mit einem 08 15
switch und also wenn es ja wirklich darum geht dass es easy für den für den
heim anwender sei das machen die damit dass es
also man auch
das ding hat wahrscheinlich
einfachere wlan setup als mikrotik oder so aber die meisten leute kommen wahrscheinlich mit einem switch oder fritz box easy hin
slits box hat zu wenig ports
Aber
die meisten leute wenn die sich in 24 port switch kaufen oder fritz box haben sie wahrscheinlich
was was in ihrer know-how liga gut bedienbar ist
und was eigentlich auch
soweit funktioniert, ohne dass du groß was
machen musst. Wenn du natürlich
ein bisschen advancedere Sachen machen willst,
sei es, dass du
wirklich mal von Hand Firewall-Regeln einrichten
willst, dass du ein bisschen komplexeres
WLAN-Setup ist, vielleicht möchtest du irgendwann auch mal
IPsec oder irgendwas VPN-mäßiges
machen, okay.
Aber dann würde ich es trotzdem nicht mit
irgendeinem Unify-Router machen.
Ich sag ja, WLAN
ist das Einzige, was mir so einfällt, aber
die meisten Leute wollen kein WLAN
daheim machen.
Die wissen doch nicht einmal, wozu man das überhaupt
verwenden sollte.
Wenn du denen sagst, ja, wie wär's denn, wenn man euer
Gäste-WLAN vielleicht in den extra WLAN
packt oder so, dann sag ich, was, hab ich doch.
Nein, nein, hast du nicht, du hast eine extra
SSID, aber du hast kein eigenes
WLAN für Gäste- oder
China-Geräte, was man auch nicht
zwangsläufig braucht, ja.
Also wenn man einfach nur einen Gäste-WLAN
hat, in einem eigenen Netz
und das an irgendeinem Router ist mit
Firewall dazwischen, wo du blocken kannst, kein
Zugriff aufs interne Netz, ist das
auch absolut
in Ordnung. Sobald du
dann aber in diesem
WLAN-Netz
vielleicht noch ein paar kabelgebundene
Geräte haben möchtest,
ja,
dann wird's, dann wird's schon
ein bisschen schwierig, dann musst du das irgendwie an
deinen Router-Port packen,
dann musst du gucken, dass du
den eigenen Switch nur da
für holst, weil du möchtest ja nicht, dass
der Switch irgendwie mit
beiden Ports intern und extern
dran gesteckt ist, sonst
könntest du dir nämlich einfach hergehen
und auf deinem Client eine interne
IP geben und es wird trotzdem funktionieren.
Also spätestens dann brauchst du WLANs, ja.
Gäste-WLAN ist eigenes
Subnet, ja, aber das reicht ja oftmals nicht.
Wie gesagt, spätestens
bei dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe,
reicht das nicht. Also spätestens
wenn du paar kabelgebundene Geräte haben willst,
zum Beispiel, dass
du
irgendwelche PoE-Kameras
hast, die du in dein
IoT-WLAN packen willst,
du kannst die zwar,
du kannst die zwar einstellen,
jaja, wenn du genug Ports an der Fritzbox hast,
meinetwegen, dann kannst du das machen.
Aber
danach ist Schluss, ja.
Also wenn du, keine Ahnung,
wenn du fünf PoE-Kameras hast
und die willst du in irgendeinen
IoT-WLAN packen, wo auch deine
IoT-Geräte drin sind,
dann wird das schwierig.
Dann brauchst du irgendeinen, fängt ja schon an,
dass du kein PoE über die Fritzbox machen kannst.
Also ganz so einfach ist es dann doch nicht.
Und spätestens dann musst du es eigentlich
in ein eigenes WLAN packen, wenn du
nicht einen komplett eigenen PoE-Switch
nur dafür verwenden willst.
Weil ansonsten hast du das Problem,
dass du deinen Switch nimmst
und
du hast einen 24-Port-Switch
mit PoE, meinetwegen,
dann steckst du deine Kameras da dran,
die sollen allerdings
in das,
in das, ähm,
IoT-WLAN rein
und dann musst du dir überlegen, wie du das machst.
Weil dann hast du, dann hast du
letztendlich das Problem, natürlich kannst
du das IP-technisch
voneinander trennen,
aber man darf nicht vergessen, dass der Switch trotzdem
Zugang hat
zu allem. Also wenn du dann auf
irgendwie einem dieser Geräte einfach deine
IP änderst, von
ähm,
einem IoT, von
von dem IoT-Subnet auf deinem
internen Subnet, dann hast du Zugriff
auf dein internes Netzwerk, wenn das nicht in deinem eigenen
WLAN hängt.
Das ist der gleiche 24-Port-Switch, der für alles
verwendet wird.
Du bist dann nicht gezwungen, irgendwie über die
Firewall zu gehen, weil dein Weg gar nicht da drüber
geht.
Also da bleibt dir nichts anderes übrig, als
dafür irgendwelche WLAN-Setups zu machen.
Ja, und da hört's natürlich bei der Fritzbox auf.
Aber trotzdem, ich würd mir, ich würd mir trotzdem kein
Unified-Zeug hinstellen.
... on my USW-Aggregation-Switch,
... on my USW-Aggregation-Switch, this has eight 10-Gigabit-Ports on it,
... das ist ordentlich,
... that connect all my servers,
... and then I have a USW-
Ja, dazu brauchst du aber Geräte, die WLANs können.
... for PoE-Switch.
Moving down,
I have two Raspberry Pis with room to add more.
I actually 3D-printed out this rack mount,
as you can see, it's a little bowing,
but it does the job for what I need.
... and then moving down,
just the back of all the servers.
... and every server,
... except for my Unraid,
... is connected with fiber 10-Gigabit.
... I have to...
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Brauchen, sei mal dahingestellt.
... replace this fiber port,
... it had broke,
... both of, the whole card had broke.
... so, I'll get a replacement soon for that.
... and then everything else is also set up with redundancy.
... I'll
...
... land
Wenn die W-Aggregation runtergeht oder der 10 Gigabit-Port runtergeht, wie bei diesem hier,
läuft alles noch richtig.
Es könnte nicht alle Bandwerte haben, die es vorher hatte,
aber es läuft noch, wo ich es haben kann.
Und es kann noch die meisten meiner Geräte funktionieren.
Sie sind auch mit zwei Power-Kabeln verbaut.
Und ich habe kleine Power-Strippen auf der Seite.
Jedes Power-Strip ist mit einem der UPS-Kabeln verbaut.
Und ich kann etwa 30 Minuten haben, wenn die Kraft rauskommt.
Was? Das ist ja alles schön und gut, aber wozu?
Ich kann einen Generator da rausnehmen.
Und auch all diese Switches, wie die US-24-Port-PUE,
sind mit Fiber verbaut,
um die W-Aggregation zu verbauen.
Und dann habe ich das andere Kabel,
das aus meiner Garage rauskommt,
wo ich einen anderen Switch habe,
der alle Access-Punkte und andere solche Dinge anbietet.
Und dann habe ich noch einen anderen Access-Punkt,
hier im Server-Rack,
der verbaut ist mit...
Das finde ich immer geil.
Ja, so ungefähr hängt das Ding bei mir im Keller auch da.
...verbaut ist mit dem 24-Port-Switch.
Und das ist wirklich nur,
wenn der Garage-Switch runter geht.
Ich werde immer noch zumindest einen Wifi-Ansatzpunkt haben,
nur für diesen Verdünnungsfaktor.
Aber auf jeden Fall,
das wird es für dieses Video sein.
Wenn ihr mehr über diese Server hören möchtet,
oder es läuft auf jedem,
dann schreibt einen Kommentar unten oder drückt den Like-Button.
Oder wenn ihr Fragen habt,
dann schreibt einen Kommentar unten.
Danke, Leute.
Pog.
Muss mal kurz hydraten, Leute.
So, haben wir noch irgendwas zum angucken?
Ich glaube, ich mache jetzt gleich Schluss.
Und es war's.
Und...
Dann machen wir noch ein bisschen Programmier-Stells.
Ey, was kam jetzt eigentlich raus?
Wir haben doch irgendwelche WLAN-Geschichten hier.
Was dann?
Kameras als Untag-Gäste-WLAN.
Am Switch.
Es gibt bestimmt die unterschiedlichen Setups,
die in manchen Varianten funktionieren oder nicht.
Es ist auf jeden Fall hinderlich,
in vielen Szenarien ist das,
dass die Fritzbox kein WLANs kann.
Aber die meisten Leute brauchen das daheim ja auch nicht.
Bei dem Song haben sich meine Eltern kennengelernt.
Moment, Moment.
Ich dachte, die haben sich bei...
Ich dachte, die haben sich hier kennengelernt.
Kobol.
Nein, wir programmieren keinen Kobol.
Nee.
Nee, nee.
Auf gar keinen Fall.
Das werde ich mir nicht angucken.
Was hat die Fritzbox nicht?
Die Fritzbox hat vieles nicht,
was einen ordentlichen Router auszeichnet,
aber die Fritzbox hat viele Funktionen,
was sie zu einem guten Multifunktionsgerät macht.
Also wir hätten sie eben von WLAN-Support.
Die Fritzbox hat aber zum Beispiel,
soweit ich weiß,
auch keine gescheiten Möglichkeiten,
ausgehende Firewall-Regeln zu machen, oder?
Geht das mittlerweile?
Ja, VPN-Setup-Sachen sind auch recht rudimentär.
Gut.
So Sachen wie Routing-Protokolle
braucht niemand daheim.
Das lassen wir jetzt mal weg.
Fritzbox kommt ja mit WireGuard-Support.
Boah.
Erlang.
Da muss ich erstmal meine Klammern
auf der Tastatur austauschen,
dass ich die nicht überlaste mit Erlang.
Erlang Example Code.
Passt mal auf.
Merk...
Die wenigsten können Rust programmieren
vom IQ her.
Rust ist wirklich 150 IQ+.
Wir machen heute den letzten Teil.
Wir machen heute den Label Champ weiter.
Passt mal auf.
Ich habe da einige schon eingebaut.
Ihr werdet begeistert sein,
was der Label Champ jetzt champen kann schon.
Pearl.
Hat jemand von euch mal Pearl programmieren müssen
die letzten 10 Jahre?
Ich nicht.
Pearl ist out.
Absolut räudig.
Ja, das stimmt.
Rust geht voll klar.
Ja, wenn du 150 IQ und mehr hast,
bestimmt.
Rust ist nice, aber Rust, na gut, ohne es jetzt zu übertreiben, du brauchst natürlich keine 150 EQ-Punkte, das ist klar, aber Rust ist wirklich erstmal hardcore gewöhnungsbedürftig, bis du dich dran gewöhnt hast, dass der Borrow-Checker, heißt es ja bei Rust, dass das, wie das tickt, ja.
Also du musst dich bei Rust wirklich dran gewöhnen, dass du dir schon während du programmierst, Gedanken zu machst, wie lang ist die Variable gültig, wann geht das aus dem Scope, was weiß ich, wie lang läuft der Thread oder ist das vielleicht dann irgendwie noch zugänglich, die Variable, obwohl das Objekt schon aufgeräumt wird.
Da könnt ihr euch nämlich von ausgehen, der lässt euch das einfach nicht kompilieren, wenn da sowas drin ist.
Das ist ja auch gerade das Innovative und das Coole an Rust.
Rust schafft das, halbwegs memory-sicher zu sein, nur mit Compile-Time-Checks.
Was heißt nur mit, das stimmt nicht.
Also es geht nicht alles, ja, aber sag mal, zum größten Teil safe zu sein, ohne Runtime-Checks, nur mit Compile-Time-Checks.
Das ist ja quasi gerade der Riesenvorteil an Rust.
Und warum die mittlerweile auch in Firefox so viel mit Rust machen, was eigentlich eine gute Sache ist.
Ähm, ich mein, vor allem schützt dich das nicht, ja.
Also, wenn du jetzt eine Konsolenanwendung hast und sagst, bitte geben sie eine Zahl ein und du gibst 5 ein und du greifst auf den fünften Index in deinem Array zu und den gibt's nicht, dann, und du bestehst auch drauf, ich will da drauf zugreifen, dann crasht dir das auch, ja.
Aber das ist ja meistens gar nicht...
Das ist ja meistens gar nicht das Problem, wenn's irgendwie crasht.
Problematisch sind die Sachen, die nicht crashen und sich anders verhalten als geplant, das ist ja meistens das Problem.
Einfach crashen ist oftmals nicht das Problem.
Was mir bei Rust...
Ich hab Rust, gerade als das neu war, äh, war ich so, kurzzeitig war ich so richtig so, Rust, Rust-Trip, das hört sich jetzt nach Drogen nebenan oder so, aber ich hab da, ich hab, fand das richtig, richtig nice.
Ähm, aber ich hab da nach einer Weile aufgehört, Sachen in Rust zu machen, weil's mir zu anstrengend war.
Rust, äh, was ich an Rust immer noch ein bisschen gewöhnungs-, ähm, bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig finde, ist manch, manch eine Syntax.
Ja, allein schon, allein schon, wenn man, wenn man hier sowas, wenn man hier sowas sieht, also, ja, oder es wird noch schlimmer.
Ja, gerade wenn du Structs hast und dann Lifetime von Objekten kennzeichnen musst.
Rust, es ist schon anstrengend.
Dafür hat's den Vorteil, dass du die meisten Sachen mit Compile-Time-Checks abgefackelt hast.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen, Alter, Perl.
Achso, wir haben ja gesagt, wir wollen uns das Video zu Julian Bam angucken.
Trotz 3FA, nicht nur...
Okay, letzte Amtshandlung heute, dann geh ich was essen.
So, sind wir stehen geblieben.
Gehackt, trotz 3FA.
Wie konnte das passieren?
Lassen wir uns das jetzt mal von einem Profi-Hackerman erklären.
...namenhafte Unternehmen werden in den letzten Jahren vermehrt Opfer von Hacking-Angriffen.
Auch YouTuber mit Millionen von Abonnenten, wie etwa der Schöpfer des legendären Robben-Songs Julian Bam, gehen den Zeitpunkt...
Was für einen Song?
W-w-was?
...Kriminellen immer häufiger ins Netz.
Zum Glück ist in solchen Fällen die Community des YouTubers stets zur Stelle und weist auf Twitter und anderen Social-Media-Plattformen darauf hin, dass da etwas nicht...
Stimmt.
Sogar ich habe heute Nacht entsprechende Kommentare in meinem Postfach gefunden, woraufhin ich direkt Videomaterial für die spätere Auswertung aufgenommen habe.
In diesem Video erkläre ich, wie Julian Bam trotz seiner Vorsichtsmaßnahmen, die nach eigener Aussage in einer 3-Faktor-Authentisierung bestanden, gehackt worden sind.
Da würde mich halt mal interessieren, was hatte der denn für 3-Faktor-Authentifizierung?
Wie kannst du bei YouTube überhaupt 3-Faktor-Authentifizierung machen?
Lass mal überlegen.
Okay.
Passwort-Login.
Dann...
Irgendeine Form von 2. Faktor.
Wahrscheinlich...
SMS.
Aber was?
Kann man...
Kann man sagen...
YubiKey, das kannst du...
Geht das in Kombination?
Ja gut, für dein Passwort könntest du das vielleicht machen, ja?
Du könntest dein Passwort in irgendeinem...
In irgendeinem Keysafe speichern, den du mit deinem YubiKey unlockst oder so.
Oder geht das?
Geht das für Google-Login, ja?
Okay, das weiß ich nicht, dass das geht.
Das ist gut.
So.
Kann man da 3 Sachen einschalten?
Habe ich mir noch nie angeguckt, ja?
Google-Login kann YubiKey.
Ja, als...
Als zusätzlich zum Passwort oder als quasi...
Bevor das...
Also quasi zum Einfügen des Passworts oder als zusätzlichen Faktor?
Okay.
Ja, das ist nice.
Ja, dann machst du sowas.
Plus Passwort.
Plus, ähm...
Keine Ahnung, SMS oder Authenticator-App oder so.
Aber das bringt dir alles nix, wenn einer deine Session-Cookies klaut oder sowas.
Oder du irgendeinen Rootkit-Backdoor oder sonst was hast und der einfach deinen Browser verwendet.
Dann musst du ja nix klauen in dem Sinn.
Ja, dann wäre es natürlich sinnvoll zu sagen, du musst dich jedes Mal neu einloggen.
Die Sache ist bloß die, da sind wir wieder beim Thema Bequemlichkeit versus...
Bequemlichkeit.
Aber gucken wir erstmal sein Video weiter.
Aber was ist überhaupt passiert?
In der Nacht vom 18.04.2022 wurden mehrere Accounts eines großen YouTubers gehackt.
Die Profilbilder und die Namen wurden in ARK-Invest umbenannt.
Ja, sowas hatte der Emcor...
Durch diese Warnsendung hat Julian Bam...
Sowas, sowas ähnliches hatte der Emcor ja auch bei sich auf dem Channel.
Der hatte irgendwelche Krypto-Scam...
...verifizierungshaken verloren.
Dass bei einem YouTube-Kanal mit weit über 5 Millionen Abonnenten kein Verifizierungshaken mehr vorhanden ist,
...
leitet bereits darauf hin, dass hier etwas nicht stimmt.
Dieser Haken zeigt nämlich nicht nur, dass man viele Follower hat,
sondern auch, dass man sich von YouTube hat verifizieren lassen.
Das heißt, man hat eine gewisse Anstrengung unternommen, um nachzuweisen,
dass man der ist, der man zu sein vorgibt.
Und genau dieser Identitätsnachweis spielt in der digitalen Welt eine sehr wichtige Rolle.
Verlässt man sich nämlich beispielsweise nur auf ein Passwort zum Identitätsnachweis,
dann ist das ein sehr schwacher Schutz, denn jeder, der dieses Passwort kennt,
kann sich für dich ausgeben.
Julian Bam hat in einem Video...
...einem Tweet jedoch angedeutet, dass er eine Drei-Faktor-Authentisierung nutzt.
Was das ist und welche Rückschlüsse man daraus auf das tatsächliche Gefahrenpotenzial ziehen kann,
klären wir gleich.
Zuvor schauen wir uns noch einmal an, was die Hacker mit ARK Invest bezwecken wollten.
Nun, sie haben einen Livestream gestartet und alle Follower...
Ja, das lief beim M-Call ja auch.
Irgendwelche, wie sagt man so, Krypto-Bros...
...wurden dann entsprechend informiert, in dem unter anderem Elon Musk zu sehen war...
Wie sie einfach...
Den Kerl haben sie gern dabei.
Der wirkt für viele Leute halt so nach Innovation und Kompetenz
und man macht ihn irgendwo rein, womit er überhaupt nichts zu tun hatte
und dann denkt man so, oh krasser Elon Musk, ja dann, dann, dann machen wir das jetzt auch.
...dem es wohl darum ging, seine Bitcoins zu vermehren.
Man sollte sein Krypto-Manieren eine bestimmte Adresse versenden
und es wurde versprochen, dass man das Doppelte wieder zurückbekommt.
Das ist ja fast ein bisschen wie...
Fallt da bitte, bitte nicht drauf rein.
Das ist Scam.
Diese Masche wurde in der Vergangenheit schon mehrfach angewendet.
Ich weiß nicht, aber in letzter Zeit sind diese Krypto-Scams...
Wassup, wassup, wassup!
Oder was hat der Typ erzählt bei BitConnect?
Das war doch genau der gleiche Shit.
Ziemlich populär.
Wenn du so einen Kommentar bei mir auf dem Kanal sehen solltest, bitte sofort melden.
Ich kümmere mich darum, dass die schnellstmöglichst entfernt werden.
Aber woher weiß man eigentlich, dass es sich bei dem betroffenen Account um den von Julien Bam handelt?
Schließlich wurden alle Videos auf dem Kanal gelöscht und nur der Livestream mit mehr als 20.000 Zuschauern...
Wahrscheinlich redirectet auch der alte Name noch.
...zudem auch noch über 31.000 Likes hatte, war zu sehen.
Ganz einfach. Klickt man sich ein bisschen durch die Tabs und landet bei Community, dann sieht man an den Inhalten, dass hier früher offenbar einmal Julien Bam gepostet hat.
Hier waren die Scammer wohl nicht gründlich genug.
Scrollt man ein bisschen durch die abonnierten Kanäle, stellt man fest, dass es einen weiteren Kanal namens ARK Invest gibt, der 1,85 Millionen Abonnenten besitzt.
Das war einmal Julien Bams Zweitkanal mit dem Namen...
...Boolean Jam, der ebenfalls übernommen wurde.
Dass gleich mehrere Kanäle von ihm betroffen sind, wird bei der Problemanalyse noch einmal wichtig.
Auf Twitter hat Julien Bam kontakt zu YouTube-Support aufgenommen.
Seine Kanäle Julien Bam und Boolean Jam gehören allem Anschein nach wohl wieder ihm.
Zumindest tragen sie wieder ihren ursprünglichen Namen.
Die Inhalte sind auch...
Warum schreibt er Boolean mit U und nicht mit zwei O?
... allerdings noch nicht wiederhergestellt worden, was natürlich einen erheblichen finanziellen Schaden verursacht...
Cringe, Witz, ich weiß.
Ich habe während meiner YouTube-Pause im März im Schnitt 200.000 Aufrufe pro Monat auf meine Videos erhalten, obwohl ich nichts hochgeladen habe.
Welche Dimension das bei den beiden Kanälen von Julien Bam hat, möchte ich mir gar nicht ausmalen.
Von daher wünsche ich dir, Julien, dass die Videos so schnell wie möglich...
30 plus, Witz!
...hergestellt werden.
Also, wenn das 1 nicht war, dann 30 plus. Fragt mal 30 plus, Leute, ob die verstanden haben, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Ich hätte sonst die Robbe machen.
Nee, aber Spaß beiseite. Ich wünsche dir wirklich alles Gute.
Kommen wir nun zu der eigentlichen Frage dieses Videos.
Wobei, nee, er hätte es eigentlich so schreiben müssen.
Boolean, nichts, schreibt man ja gar nicht mit I. So hätte er es eigentlich schreiben müssen.
...YouTube- bzw. Social-Media-Accounts, hier speziell von Julien Bam, überhaupt gehackt werden.
Nun, in meinem Video, wie Hacker Passwörter knacken, habe ich in der Vergangenheit bereits...
Ich poste das nachher in der Wendler-Telegram-Gruppe, Witz.
...welche Angriffsmöglichkeiten es für Passwörter gibt.
Gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Ich habe gehört, Xavier Naidoo ist jetzt wieder angeblich...
...geläutert zurück und hat sich wieder angeblich auf den rechten Pfad zurückbewegt, habe ich gelesen.
Keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich ist ihm einfach nur das Geld ausgegangen.
Kurz nach diesem Video ereignete sich im Frühjahr 2020 der berühmt-berüchtigte Mercedes-Hack,
bei dem der Instagram-Account der Automarke von einem Hacker namens Ketz übernommen wurde
und dort unter anderem Bilder von Montana Black gepostet wurden.
Im Vergleich war...
Warum ausgerechnet Montana Black-Filter?
Ey, ich meine, okay, immer noch besser als Krypto-Scam.
Dazu wurde bei der Übernahme der YouTube-Kanäle von Julien Bam hier in Richtung...
Aktiv, Digger!
...großes Ziel-Scam betrieben, nämlich den Livestream mit mehreren tausend Zuschauern, der zu allem...
Der gleiche Scam lief bei M-Core auch auf dem Channel.
...die sehr viele wahrscheinlich gebottete Likes hatte und Elon Musk zu sehen war,
gibt es bestimmt den einen oder anderen, der auf die dahinter steckende Betrugsmasche reingefallen ist...
Ja, bestimmt!
...und beziehungsweise noch darauf reinfällt.
Das stimmt.
...dass er trotzdem unvorsichtig bei der Sicherung seiner Social-Media-Kanäle war,
halte ich für sehr unwahrscheinlich...
Ja.
...da er in seinem Tweet an YouTube von einer drei Faktor aus...
Also, ich denke auch mal, dass er nach Möglichkeit das gemacht hat, was er machen konnte, so als...
...ja, vielleicht nicht so ultra-technik-affiner.
Allerdings, auf der anderen Seite ist es immer die Abwägung zwischen Bequemlichkeit versus Sicherheit.
Ich glaube, die wenigsten Leute werden es so einstellen, dass beim Schließen des Browsers quasi die...
...Cookies gelöscht werden, beziehungsweise die Sachen gelöscht werden, dass beim nächsten Öffnen des Browsers...
...man sich wieder neu einloggen muss und sowas.
Das wäre sinnvoll.
Das sollte ich eigentlich auch so machen, ja.
Ich glaube, ich mache das jetzt auch so.
Sicher ist sicher.
Ich mache mir einen extra Browser für YouTube und Social Media, der automatisch sich cleart nach dem Schließen.
...spricht.
Eigentlich ein guter Anstoß jetzt dafür.
Ich gebe dir eine Woche.
Ja, ich weiß genau.
Ich werde es wahrscheinlich nicht lange verwenden, weil es ist halt einfach das, was ich eben gesagt habe.
Du musst abwägen zwischen Bequemlichkeit und Sicherheit.
Und spätestens, wenn es dich so abfuckt, dann wirst du leichtsinnig beim Eingeben der Passwörter oder aber du schaltest es wieder aus.
Für jeden von euch dürfte die Zwei-Faktor-Authentisierung ein Begriff sein.
Dabei wird zusätzlich zum Passwort ein weiterer Mechanismus eingesetzt, mit dem man seine...
Ja gut, das wissen wir.
...Equalität nachweisen kann.
Das wissen wir.
...Equalität nachweisen möchte und muss dann auf...
Ja, das ist auch nice.
...Dort draufklicken.
Eine Drei-Faktor-Authentisierung ergänzt den Identitätsnachweis um einen weiteren Faktor, der im Optimalfall aus der dritten Kategorie stammt.
Also zum Beispiel ein Fingerabdruck, ein Retina-Scan oder irgendetwas anderes, was in die Kategorie biologische Authentifizierung fällt.
Es könnte aber auch...
Wisst ihr, was witzig ist?
Zu Zeiten, bevor das so angesagt war, in den ganzen Filmen haben die Leute immer Scannen gemacht.
Da wurden Augen gescannt und was auch immer.
Niemand macht das heute so.
Außer im Sonderfall.
Ja, das meiste ist sowas wie...
Gerade, gerade wenn du es auf dem iPhone...
Gesichtserkennung.
Ja.
Oder irgendwelche klassischen Varianten.
Vielleicht auch noch Finger.
Aber...
Also die wenigsten haben so eine Authentifizierung, wie sich das damals beispielsweise Mission Impossible oder sowas vorgestellt hat.
Von Augenscannen...
Bis sonstige Dinger.
Das macht kaum einer.
Außer, dass der Fingerabdruck des Browsers, der Standort oder die aktuelle IP-Adresse hierbei hinzugezogen werden.
Doch wie kann denn ein solcher...
Ist Local Storage nicht sicherer gegen Angriffe als Cookies?
Das kommt im Prinzip aufs Gleiche raus.
Das macht, würde ich jetzt mal sagen, macht pauschal gesehen keinen großen Unterschied.
Ob du jetzt den Local Storage verwendest oder Cookies...
Ähm...
Wenn jemand...
Irgendein Trojaner, Rootkit, was auch immer auf deinem Rechner hat.
Und im Zweifelsfall deinen Rechner fernsteuern kann.
Dann ist es eh egal.
Weil dann macht er einfach deinen Browser auf.
Sei es so im Hintergrund.
Oder zieht sich das komplett ab, inklusive deinem kompletten Profil.
Oder macht im Zweifelsfall einfach deinen Browser auf und geht auf die Seite.
Also...
Umgangen werden.
Dann...
Müsste man nicht Zugriff auf alle Geräte von Julien Bam haben, um dieses Sicherheitsmaß...
Einfach nur hashest du das Login in den Local Storage schreiben.
Ja und was hast du dann davon, wenn du es nicht überprüfen kannst?
Also...
Es ist ja nicht so, als wird...
Es wird...
Wird dann da irgendwie nochmal neu authentifiziert oder sowas.
Beim Login, ja.
Aber das ist ja nicht so, dass du das Login-Passwort irgendwie speicherst.
Wenn du...
Wenn du Passwörter übermittelst, dann machst du das in der Regel ja nur mit einem Hash.
Dann sagst du...
Hey, ich nehme das Passwort, lokal am besten, hashe das, schick den Hash rüber, beziehungsweise
ich schicke noch, falls das notwendig ist, die Hash-Methode mit.
Der Server macht das Gleiche, der nimmt die gleiche Hashing-Methode, nimmt das Passwort,
hasht das und guckt, ob es rauskommt.
Oder aber, was noch viel besser ist, du hast auf der Server-Seite nur den Hash gespeichert.
So sollte man das eigentlich machen.
Also, du hast gar keine Passwörter auf Server-Seite.
Das machen leider zu wenige.
Mittlerweile dürfte es hoffentlich Standard sein, aber es kommt oft genug irgendwelche
Daten-Leaks raus, wo dann im Endeffekt rauskommt, aha, nee, guck mal, die haben trotzdem Passwörter
im Klartext gespeichert.
Salted-Hash am besten, ja.
Wobei der Salt ja nicht Secret ist.
Das muss man ja dabei sagen.
Damit das funktioniert, muss der Salt bekannt sein, ja.
Der Salt ist einzig und allein aus dem Grund da, dass du...
dass das Vorberechnen schwieriger wird.
Salt muss Public sein, sonst funktioniert das nicht.
Aber du kannst halt nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht vorberechnen.
Also der Salt macht im Prinzip das Verfahren nicht sicherer.
Der sorgt nur dafür, dass du weniger Sachen im Vorfeld vorberechnen kannst.
Warum fragt Google nicht einfach nochmal nach Passwort, bevor man den Kanalnamen ändert?
Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht so genau.
Die fragen öfters mal bei verdächtigen Aktivitäten nach.
Ich weiß nicht, anhand was die das festmachen.
Vielleicht machen die das ja fest daran, wie lange du schon eingeloggt bist.
Wenn quasi deine Session schon drei Tage läuft, dann nicht.
Aber wenn du dich vor 15 Minuten erst eingeloggt hast, dann nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Maßnahmen zu umgehen?
Nicht unbedingt.
Hier wäre interessant zu erfahren, welche Faktoren Julien Bam für seine 3-Faktor-Authentisierung nutzt
und ob er sie bei jeder Anmeldung neu eingeben muss.
Ich muss diese Schritte beispielsweise nur dann noch einmal durchführen,
wenn ich eine neue IP erteile.
Wenn ich eine neue IP-Adresse zugewiesen bekommen habe
oder mich von einem anderen Rechner aus mit meinem Google-Konto registrieren möchte.
Und natürlich auch dann, wenn ich mich auf meinem Rechner abmelde und erneut anmelde.
Doch auch das kann man ausschalten.
Ich denke nicht, dass Julien Bam jedes Mal, wenn er zum Beispiel ein Video hochlädt,
auf einen Kommentar antwortet oder Änderungen an seinem Kanaldesign durchführt,
seine 3-Faktor-Authentisierung durchführen muss.
Nee.
Aber ich meine, was ja auch noch möglich wäre.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie das ist, wenn du Kanalnamen änderst und sowas.
Also das wäre natürlich sinnvoll, da prinzipiell nochmal Passwort,
wobei Passwort haben die garantiert rausbekommen.
Passwort alleine reicht nicht.
Die müssten wirklich komplette Triple-Faktor dann nochmal durchmachen.
Passwort alleine reicht nicht,
weil das Passwort von ihm haben die Typen innerhalb der ersten 15 Minuten mitgelockt,
als er am Rechner war.
Das ist kein Ding.
Die müssten theoretisch nochmal komplett alles neu abfragen,
wenn du Kanalnamen änderst und so.
Das würde es dann auf jeden Fall schwieriger machen.
Das wäre nämlich völlig unkomfortabel.
Und für gewöhnlich findet man immer einen Kompromiss zwischen Sicherheit und Usability.
Genau das, was ich eben auch schon gesagt habe.
Ich bin beispielsweise auf meinem Rechner dauerhaft mit meinem Google-Konto angemeldet
und erst, wenn ich mich abmelde, muss ich bei der Neuanmeldung mein Passwort neu eingeben
bzw. meinen Hardware-Token bemühen.
Ich habe also eine bestimmte Session offen, die durch einen Hacker übernommen werden könnte.
Session-Hijacking nennt man das.
Der Hacker braucht dann eben nicht den zweiten oder dritten Faktor,
weil er ja eine Session übernimmt,
in der das alles schon durchlaufen wurde.
Richtig.
Dies wird oftmals durch den Diebstahl des Session-Cookies einer aktiven Session erreicht.
Dazu erstelle ich diese Woche noch ein detaillierteres Video.
Hacker-Man-Content.
Ich hoffe, YouTube geht eben nicht auf den Keks wegen Hacker-Content.
Mittlerweile weißt du auf YouTube ja gar nicht mehr genau, was geht und was nicht geht.
... auf Julien Bam's Rechner hätten, was mit Hilfe eines ...
Eigentlich auch ein Unding auf YouTube.
Und die Typen, die sich die Videos dann Probe angucken,
haben doch von Tuten und Blasen keine Ahnung.
... die wir Session übernehmen konnten, würde das erklären,
wie sie den Schutz der 3D-Sendung,
wie sie den Schutz der 3-Faktor-Authentisierung umgehen konnten.
Doch nicht nur die Session, sondern auch der Browser könnte gehijackt
und eventuell gespeicherte Passwörter automatisiert ausgelesen worden sein.
Also ich geh davon aus, ich hab keine Ahnung davon,
ich geh davon aus, der hat sich schlicht und ergreifend irgendwas eingefangen auf seinem Rechner.
Und ähm ...
weiß man nicht, wie weitreichend das war,
von Keylogger bis theoretisch komplett Remote-Steuerung möglich.
Und so wird das funktioniert haben.
Wie ich in meinem Video zum Passwort ...
Das ist das Nahliegen.
... Passwort-Stealing in modernen Webbrowsern gezeigt habe,
sind dafür noch nicht einmal Programmierkenntnisse erforderlich.
Deshalb solltest du unbedingt die Passwörter von allen deinen Online-Accounts ändern.
Mit einem sogenannten SIM-Swapping-Angriff,
bei dem sich ein Hacker der Mobilfunknummer seines Opfers,
wenn auch nur kurzfristig, bemächtigt,
kann dir den Schutz, der beispielsweise durch den Versand eines zeitlich begrenzten Einmal-Codes
an das Smartphone des Betroffenen entsteht, ausgehebelt werden.
Jack Dorsey, der CEO von Twitter,
wurde 2019 mit genau dieser Technik,
gehackt.
Dass alle Accounts von Julien Bam ...
Stimmt, ich erinnere mich.
... übernommen wurden ...
Da war was.
... sollte darauf hin.
Wie genau SIM-Swapping funktioniert,
werde ich dir ebenfalls zeitnah in einem Video erklären.
Es könnte auch sein,
dass es einen technischen Fehler bei der Implementierung der Drei-Faktor-Autobeziehung ...
Das glaube ich nicht.
... auf Seiten von YouTube gibt,
oder die Hacker einen Zero-Day-Exploit ausgenutzt haben.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Das halte ich aber für eher unwahrscheinlich,
weil sonst vermute ich mehrere Accounts unterschiedlich ...
Das ist das Letzte, also ganz ehrlich,
das ist immer das Letzte, wovon ich ausgehen würde.
Also quasi alle, wo die Accounts mal weg waren,
oder temporär weg waren,
haben immer gesagt, so nach dem Motto,
oh, ich wurde gehackt,
ich habe hier was auch immer,
das, das, das an,
ich habe niemandem mein Passwort gesagt.
Das muss irgendwo ein Fehler bei Google sein.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Also weder Facebook-Login,
noch Google-Login,
noch Microsoft-Login oder sonst was,
würde ich pauschal davon ausgehen,
dass sie grundlegende Schwächen haben.
Sonst hätten wir ganz andere Probleme
und ganz andere Tragweite der Probleme.
Also ...
Und wenn einer,
jetzt mal ernsthaft,
wenn einer ein Google-Login,
Zero-Day hat,
ich glaube,
da wird er nicht unbedingt öffentlichkeitswirksam
den Account von Julien Bam übernehmen.
Also lieber Julien,
hier sind meine Tipps.
Bitte überprüfe umgehend alle deine Geräte auf Malware.
Es kann gut sein,
dass sich auf einem oder mehrer deiner Geräte
ein Trojaner, also ein Spionage-Programm befindet.
Ja.
Wenn du magst,
unterstütze ich dich gerne dabei.
Setze von einem anderen Rechner,
der am besten noch gar nicht benutzt wurde,
alles neu auf.
Ändere deine Passwörter auf allen Accounts,
die du aktuell im Internet verwendest.
Viel Spaß.
Wenn sich auf deinem Rechner ein Trojaner befindet,
der beispielsweise durch Social Engineering
verbracht worden sein könnte,
könnten diese Zugangsdaten
ebenfalls ausgespäht worden sein.
Informiere Freunde und Kontakte,
die in deinem Adressbuch stehen,
dass sie nicht auf Links klicken sollen.
Das ist tatsächlich ...
Ja, da hätte ich jetzt gar nicht ...
Das ist tatsächlich wichtig.
Gerade wenn du irgendwie dir was eingefangen hast,
was dann deine Bekannten anspammt oder so.
Das ist tatsächlich wichtig,
weil du hast da so viele Leute,
die denken so,
ja, ja, da klicken wir mal drauf,
der Max hat was geschickt,
so nach dem Motto.
Nee, das ist tatsächlich wichtig.
Und vor allem,
der Kerl hat halt fünf Millionen Abos oder so.
Also, allein schon da ist es halt riesig groß,
dass das Missbrauchspotenzial ...
... dass deine Accounts verschickt werden,
zumindest so lange,
bis die Gefahr gebannt ist.
Entferne alle ...
Überlegt euch mal,
überlegt euch mal,
kannst, was weiß ich,
Twitter-Account von Montana Blackwell weg, ja?
Und der würde einen Link posten,
was weiß ich,
was ist denn so ein typischer,
typischer Aktiv-Digger
und dann irgendeinen Link dahinter.
Da würden tausende Leute auf den Link klicken
und wenn das dann halbwegs plausibel ist,
was man auf dem Link sieht,
findest du die ein oder anderen Leute,
die sich scammen lassen
und der ganze Kram hat sich schon gelohnt.
Deswegen ist wichtig,
dass man wirklich,
dass nach Möglichkeit,
wenn man noch,
gerade als Influencer,
die Möglichkeit hat,
irgendwie auf anderen Plattformen,
da was,
was kundzutun,
dass die Leute aufpassen sollen.
Ja, Digga, bestes Casino, genau.
... auf deinem YouTube-Kanal haben
und füge sie,
sofern du den Quellen vertraust,
schrittweise wieder hinzu.
Manchmal kann nämlich der Hack
einer Drittanbieter-App dafür sorgen,
dass sich das Problem
auf die damit verknüpften Kanäle ausweitet.
Ich beispielsweise gebe nur
ganz, ganz wenigen Apps lesenden Zugriff
auf bestimmte Bereiche meines YouTube-Kanals,
und überhaupt gar keine App schreiben den Zugriff.
Nö, ich auch nicht.
Ich melde dich hin und wieder
neu in deinem Google-Konto an,
damit eine übernommene Sprechung
nicht zu viel Schaden anrichtet.
Das stimmt, ja.
Es ist nicht verkehrt,
und das werde ich ab sofort auch machen,
wenn man sich so einmal täglich abmeldet
und nochmal neu anrichtet.
Ja, gute Vorsätze, mal gucken.
Da hab ich immer so meine Zweifel dran,
ob man das wirklich durchhält.
Das Beste wäre eigentlich,
du machst einen Browser,
der komplett löscht beim Schließen.
Aber,
tja, wer macht das schon?
Und zum Schluss,
aber das hast du ja bereits getan,
halte deine Follower auf dem Laufenden.
Informiere sie darüber,
was passiert ist,
und hilf dabei,
die Security-Awareness
für das Internet zu steigern.
Dann hast du von den übernommenen
Accounts bei Julien Bam Erfahrung.
Ihr habt mir gerade geschrieben,
dass Julien Bam
ein Video hochgeladen hat
zu dieser Sache vor einer halben Stunde.
Wir schauen jetzt legit
mein erstes,
da war es doch,
juckt mich nicht,
okay.
Ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben
ein Julien Bam Video geguckt.
Premiere.
17 Minuten, Alter.
Okay.
So, so, so, so, so, so, so.
Test, Test, Test, Test.
Weirdchamp.
Warum hat er sein Audio-Equipment
nicht ordentlich eingerichtet
als krasser Influencer-Man?
I'm back.
Boah, ich weiß gar nicht,
wo ich anfangen soll,
aber Fazit.
Ich mag deutsche Influencer nicht.
Ich kriege Anfälle,
wenn ich die Sprechweise schon sehe, Mann.
Egal, da muss ich jetzt durch, Leute.
Vorweg, das waren auf jeden Fall
die schlimmsten Tage,
die schlimmste Woche für uns alle hier
und vor allem für mich.
Das glaube ich ihm.
Das ist mega belastend.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen, ja.
Da geht dir der Arsch
wirklich auf Grundeis bei sowas.
Wir wurden gehackt.
Richtig mies gehackt.
Mies gehackt.
Und das Ganze hatte so viele negative Konsequenzen
für alles, was wir hier
auf dieser Plattform gemacht haben.
Und es war die Hölle.
Es war wirklich die reinste Hölle.
Das glaube ich ihm, ja.
Aber...
Richtig mies, Digga.
Nee, das glaube ich ihm.
Da geht dir wirklich der Arsch auf Grundeis.
Gehen wir mal erst an den Anfang.
Julien Bam hat bis jetzt
alle seine YouTube-Kanäle verloren.
Es ist jetzt gerade ein Scam für Bitcoins.
Auf Juliens Profil,
was eines der größten Profile
im deutschen Raum darstellt,
sind keine...
Da stürzen sie sich alle drauf wieder.
Sonntagnachts.
Der 17.04.
Ich komme hier nochmal rein.
Wollte so in Ruhe
alleine noch ein paar Sachen abarbeiten.
Da geht dir der Arsch auf Grundeis, ja.
Arbeite auf entspannt.
Mein PC wurde auf einmal
immer lauter und lauter
und immer lauter.
Und ich dachte echt, was...
Arbeite auf entspannt.
Alles klar.
Was ist denn hier los?
Ein Hubschrauber landet neben mir.
Die Lüfter am Durchdrehen.
Ich so voll panisch.
Mach Task Manager auf.
Haben die Typen noch irgendwelche
Bitcoins gemeint oder was?
Guck erst mal,
was verbraucht denn hier
meine komplette Leistung?
Und auf einmal mein PC so...
Ganz leise wieder.
Ich so okay, chillig, chillig.
Beängstigend, aber auch chillig.
Das ist ein Ding.
Ich finde das tatsächlich gut,
dass er das gemerkt hat.
Weil...
Das habe ich auch schon mal
in einem Video gesagt.
Es hat seinen Grund,
warum ich immer
einen Process Manager offen habe.
Ich habe einen Process Manager,
einen Task Manager offen.
Und ich habe auch schon öfters
in Videos gesagt,
es ist nicht schlecht zu wissen,
was so der Standard,
wie soll man sagen,
der Standard Workflow, Workload,
sonst was auf seinem Rechner ist,
dass man Abweichungen davon erkennt.
Ich gebe zu,
das ist heutzutage relativ schwierig.
Es ist normal,
dass sich jetzt hier mal
der Google Updater startet.
Es ist normal,
dass man das .NET Framework
im Hintergrund irgendwas macht.
Es ist normal,
dass irgendwie mal irgendwie
Steam Updates laufen
oder sonst wo.
Aber man sollte misstrauisch werden,
gerade,
und die meisten können sich
natürlich besser verstecken,
aber gerade,
wenn auf einmal neue Dinger
in der Taskliste auftauchen,
so nach dem Motto,
was ist das?
Bisschen dumm daran ist,
dass mittlerweile unter Windows
standardmäßig schon so viel Shit läuft,
dass du gar nicht durchblickst
und dann irgendwelche Dinge hast,
wie keine Ahnung,
was zum Teufel ist der Mo,
der was?
Ich habe es vergessen.
Hier,
der Mo Uso Core Worker.
Was ist das?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Was ist da?
Da hätte ich jetzt zum Beispiel
schon mal bedenken,
wenn ich dieses Ding sehe.
Was zum Teufel ist das?
Für Windows Updates.
Was?
Geschiss, Alter.
Ja, das ist heute ein bisschen schwierig,
das rauszubekommen,
weil Windows auch mal gerne
im Hintergrund Dinger startet,
von denen er nie was gesehen hat.
Obvious, was das ist, ja.
Ja, aber es ist trotzdem nicht verkehrt.
Es ist nicht verkehrt.
Und das ist gut,
dass ihm das gleich instinktiv aufgefallen ist.
Das finde ich nice.
Also, viele merken das nicht.
... wieder zu,
mein PC auf einmal wieder
komplett am Ausrasten.
Ich dachte,
es explodiert gleich in mein Gesicht.
Ja, ist ja gut.
Ich werde neu geboren als Two-Face,
mache Task...
Was?
Zum Teufel.
... Manager wieder auf,
suche diese Scheiße,
die gerade hier mein PC,
meine Lüfter so in Nutzung hochtreibt.
Und nichts gefunden einfach.
Als wäre da irgendetwas
in meinem Computer gewesen,
was aber nicht gefunden werden wollte.
Und smart,
oder auch eher das Gegenteil,
unwissend, wie ich nun mal bin,
in diesen ganzen Computergedöns,
habe ich halt einfach den Task Manager
offen gelassen,
damit ich halt abarbeiten kann.
Ich mache mein Stuff fertig,
habe by the way auch nur in Docs gearbeitet.
Also am besten wäre jetzt tatsächlich gewesen,
einfach Stecker raus.
... PC belastet
und irgendwann Computer aus,
home gegangen,
pennen.
Am Pennen,
am Pennen,
ich habe gepennt,
ein bisschen weiter gepennt
und dann bin ich halt aufgewacht irgendwann.
Montag,
montags,
Ostermontag by the way,
gucke auf mein Handy,
erste Nachricht,
die ich gesehen habe,
war von Sascha,
unsympathischTV
und der hat mir geschrieben so,
yo Bro,
wurde dein Channel gehackt?
Und ich so,
hä, what the fuck,
ist das jetzt irgendwie so ein Prank
oder ist das irgendwie so eine Bestrafung?
Prank!
Das ist ja das Schlimme,
dass du mittlerweile
in den Influencer-Kreisen
als erstes Mal daran denken musst,
wenn dich ein Bekannter anruft,
fuck,
der prankt mich.
Challenge,
und warum schreibt der mir das um 5 Uhr?
Ich hasse Influencer-Dings,
nicht Influencer,
so dieses,
ah,
was soll ich sagen,
so dieses,
diese,
diese ganze Influencer-Denkweise
und sowas,
Alter,
das ist so schlimm.
Das erste,
stell dir mal vor,
wie kacke das ist.
Das Schlimmste,
das Erste,
was du dir denken musst,
ist,
wenn dich ein Bekannter anruft,
prankt er mich jetzt.
Was ein Müll,
Alter.
Morgens,
guck mal,
wie kaputt ich schon mittlerweile im Kopf bin,
wie sensibilisiert ich für solche Themen bin,
dass ich das gar nicht glaube am Anfang.
Und dann schreibt mir Sebastian Klug,
gut,
das ist fast normal,
würde ich sagen.
Keiner würde,
keiner würde erstmal instinktiv sagen,
ja,
hier,
Channel gehackt,
ja,
muss so sein.
Dann würdest du sagen,
hä,
wie kann das sein,
nee,
der Text schreibt mir immer mehr,
schreibe mir und ich so auf einmal.
Das scheint so zu sein.
Ich gehe sofort auf die Kanäle und frage mich erstmal,
so,
was macht Elon Musk auf meinem Channel?
Irgend so ein weirder,
fremder Stream läuft auf allen meinen Channels.
Julien Bam,
Boolean Jam und auch Juck mich nicht,
die Videobeschreibungen voll mit.
Konnte er sich noch einloggen?
Das würde mich jetzt interessieren.
Konnte er sich selbst noch einloggen oder nicht?
Scamme Links,
wer da drauf geklickt hat,
der tut mir wirklich leid,
weil er hat wahrscheinlich eher Geld verloren.
nicht eher Geld verloren. Und alle
unsere Videos waren weg.
Und ich so, oh mein
Gott. Und dann
ging die Scheiße erst richtig los.
Es war klar, irgendjemand hat sich in unsere YouTube-Kanäle
eingehackt. Ich call Thomas. Thomas
wusste schon Bescheid. Thomas war schon im Haus.
Er lockt sich ein bei YouTube. Klappt.
Jetzt geht's aber Schlag auf Schlag hier.
Parallel haben wir noch versucht, YouTube zu erreichen.
War ein bisschen schwierig, weil ja auch
Ostermontag war. Es ist immer schwierig, YouTube zu
erreichen. Und ich hab dann auch angefangen,
die Passwörter zu ändern. Lock mich ein.
Ich find das beruhigend,
dass es sogar für ihn schwierig ist, YouTube zu
erreichen. Ich hab mal so, hä?
Mein Instagram-Profilbild
wurde gerade gelöscht.
Und ich so,
ruf zu Thomas hoch, mach sofort
alle PCs aus. Thomas Perplex
macht die ganzen PCs aus. Ich koppel
mich von allen Geräten aus dem WLAN raus.
Komplett Parallel. Ja, gut.
Aber tatsächlich, manchmal
ist die beste Firewall die
Zange. Gut, man muss nicht die Zange nehmen, aber
man kann einfach einen Stecker rausziehen.
Ja, manchmal ist das tatsächlich, wenn du
keine Ahnung hast, was Sache ist.
Ich mein, schlimmer machst du es damit wahrscheinlich
nicht.
Weil mir eingefallen ist, dass ich mich
vor kurzer Zeit auf irgendeinem
Rechner über den Browser auf
Instagram angemeldet habe. Und da
wurde mir bewusst, YouTube hat sich nicht über YouTube
eingehackt, sondern über einen unserer
Rechner. Deswegen hatte er auch Zugriff
auf Instagram. Und das
heißt, der sieht ja jede
Änderung von jedem Passwort,
weil er halt immer noch auf dem Rechner ist.
Erstmal mit mobiler Daten, Mails
gecheckt, keine Mehrfach-Authentifizierungsemail,
kein fremdes Gerät erkannt,
keine fremde IP oder whatsoever, alles
ganz normal. Deswegen hat auch eine
Drei-Faktor-Authentifizierung gar nichts gebracht, weil
der Typ das, oder weil der Hack
das Programm... Ja, dann ist es im Prinzip so, wie wir
das vorhin vermutet haben. Sie haben sich irgendwas auf ihren
Rechnern eingefangen. Wie gesagt,
wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal die Session geklaut,
sondern wirklich irgendwas zum Remote
steuern vom Rechner drauf gehabt. Dann ist er eh
vorbei. Dann hast du eh gelitten.
Im Seelenfrieden
vom Rechner aus quasi gemacht hat,
weil wir halt schon eingeloggt waren auf
diversen Webseiten. Und
das ist normal ist, weil
man eine Seite, bei der
man sich 50 Mal am Tag einloggt,
man da halt auch eher eingeloggt bleibt für eine längere
Zeit. Ist normal. Ja.
Obwohl wir das mittlerweile jetzt auch anders geregelt haben.
Okay, weiter geht's. Jemand anderes aus meinem Team
kommt, macht PC an, lässt... Wie gesagt,
das ist halt einfach der Unterschied. Bequemlichkeit
versus Security. Und du wirst...
Du hältst es nicht durch,
jedes Mal dich neu einzuloggen. Du flippst aus
im Kopf.
...Programm laufen. 172
Trojaner gefunden. Die Hälfte
davon am... Was?
...einen. Also... Watt? Watt?
Watt? Moment, Moment, Moment. Das wird das...
Halte ich jetzt, aber...
...mal am Tag einloggt, man da halt auch eher eingeloggt
bleibt für eine längere Zeit. Ist normal.
Obwohl wir das mittlerweile jetzt auch anders
geregelt haben. Okay, weiter geht's. Jemand
anderes aus meinem Team kommt, macht PC
an, lässt Malware-Programm laufen.
172 Trojaner
gefunden.
...
Naja, keine Ahnung.
Die Hälfte davon am Minen, also
Krypto-Mining. Das heißt, die haben unsere
Kanäle nicht nur als Werbefläche genutzt
für ihren Scam-Shit,
sondern auch unsere Grafikkarten,
um Krypto zu minen.
Also... Ja, wenn schon richtig, ja.
Wenn schon richtig.
Wobei man sagen muss, das ist ganz schön
dumm, ehrlich gesagt, Krypto zu minen.
Weil, was ist das Ziel?
Ja? Möchtest du
Leute scammen über
YouTube oder möchtest du entdeckt werden?
Es ist jetzt nicht so, als könntest du
mit Krypto-Minern hier wahnsinnig viel Geld
verdienen in den paar Stunden
bis Tagen, bis sie das merken. Also
eigentlich ist Krypto-Mining ziemlich dumm.
In dem Fall
jetzt gewesen.
Weil das ist das, was dann im Endeffekt auffällt, ja?
Wenn ein Rechner so wirkt, als
ist er am Abheben, wie der
Hubschrauber, oder
er funktioniert nicht mehr richtig, weil er
zu 99% Krypto minet,
dann werden die Leute doch misstrauisch.
In der Regel würde man eigentlich von ausgehen,
dass der sich hätte verstecken
wollen. Vielleicht hat er vorher
schon Krypto-Miner drauf gehabt, ja.
Ich hab mit Krypto schon seit
ein... Antivirus-Programme noch heute
sinnvoll oder reicht die Windows Firewall aus?
Der Windows Defender reicht
genug.
Rest brauchen wir nicht.
...monat nichts mehr zu tun, weil ich hoddle,
ich mach kein Daytrading, ich investiere auch nicht in
irgendwelche komischen ICOs. Ich hoddle
einfach nur und das war's. Und das mach ich auch nicht von
diesem Rechner hier aus. Und generell
bin ich immer sehr sicher im Internet unterwegs. Ich meine,
jetzt bin ich hier hauptberuflich schon seit mehreren,
mehreren Jahren so, ne. Ich geh nicht
auf irgendwelche, klick nicht auf irgendwelche
Werbepop-Ups, wo ich der eine
millionste Gewinner bin. Zu der Zeit hatten wir
mittlerweile schon jemanden von YouTube erreicht,
der in England war
und deswegen auch nur mit begrenzten Möglichkeiten
am Start war, aber der hat uns auf jeden Fall schon ein bisschen geholfen
und konnte uns auch sagen, dass solche Hackerangriffe
oftmals auf Feiertage
geplant werden, weil da der Support
der Seite natürlich am geringsten ist.
Ja, hab ich gespürt.
Ich habe sogar angefangen,
auf YouTube zu abonnieren,
also nachvollziehbare
Taktik, ja. Klingt
logisch. Twitter und auf Instagram ein paar
Laber zu machen und irgendwen von YouTube
zu erreichen, weil es so schwierig war. Es war ein Ding
der Unmöglichkeit. Sowas mach ich gar nicht. Du musst mir schon
echt tief ins Herz stechen, dass ich solche
Leute tagge auf Instagram. Aber dagegen
spricht, dass sie dann Crypto meinen auf den Rechnern.
Ach, Hilferufe so.
Wenn sie nicht entdeckt werden wollen. Boah.
Auf jeden Fall
waren die einzigen, die uns dann helfen
konnten, die letztendlich
auch so die,
die magischen Regler haben,
in Anführungszeichen natürlich gesetzt,
YouTube USA.
Und die waren schwierig zu erreichen, denn
aufgrund der Zeitverschiebung waren die halt
noch am Schlafen, Alter.
Der ganze Tag einfach die reinste
Magma-Hölle. Neuigkeiten,
keine Neuigkeiten, hin und wieder her.
Also, dass das mega belastend
für ihn ist, will ich nicht bezweifeln. Das kann ich
mir gut vorstellen. Da kann ich mich auch gut reinversetzen.
Das Abfuck, da geht ja wie gesagt der Arsch
auf Grundeis. Ja, das verstehe ich.
Da hatten wir auch unseren YouTube-Partner-Manager Marco
Reich, der vieles in die Wege geleitet hat.
Der ist auch geschafft, dass die richtigen, wichtigen
Informationen zu den richtigen, wichtigen Leuten
kommt. Und
die meinten dann, aber
das ist ein unglaublich
komplizierter Case. Und ich
so, boah.
Scheiße, ja. Ich schon so am Abschließen
mit dem Kanal. Ich so, okay, wie wird mein
vierter Kanal heißen müssen?
Und, boah, waren die letzten acht Jahre umsonst.
Sind die ganzen Videos
weg. Ich hab mich so
motivationslos gefühlt wie noch nie.
Ich starr so an die Decke und
so jeder Framer. Ich hätte da
gar keine Zeit, mich in der Situation
motivationslos zu fühlen.
Ich hätte eher, würde mir
ausmalen, fuck, was ist noch alles
weg? Was kann noch alles passieren?
Ja, sei es jetzt von
Online-Banking
bis PayPal, bis Amazon,
bis
alles mögliche.
Ich glaube, da hätte ich richtig Panik bekommen.
Ich glaube, ich hätte nicht
einen zweiten YouTube-Channel in dem Jahr. Gut, er macht
das hauptberuflich, ja, verstehe ich.
Aber trotzdem, also,
wahrscheinlich hätte ich an andere Dinge gedacht.
Lebens war einfach so ein
kitschiges Tumblr-Bild einfach.
Weil egal, wo ich hingeschaut habe,
du hättest da so einen blöden Spruch
drunter legen können, so.
Und es hätte gepasst.
Das Rest, das kann durchaus sein,
dass das was größer geplantes war,
wenn das so war.
Aber wahrscheinlich alles mit der gleichen Masche.
Also, vielleicht hat man sich ja koordiniert.
Es kann ja durchaus sein, dass er sich
ja irgendwie den Trojaner schon drei, vier Tage
vorher eingefangen hat. Kann ja sein,
dass man das geplant
gemacht hat, quasi dann
überall zeitgleich sich zu erkennen
gegeben hat. Fuck, wo war ich denn jetzt mit dem Video?
Ah!
Hier.
Ey, nichts
ging mehr. Mein Körper war so
schwach. Meine Seele war so weit weg
von seinem Ursprung einfach.
Ich würde es vielleicht anders
ausdrücken, ja, aber ich kann mir
das,
das ist wirklich, ich kann es nicht anders sagen,
dir geht der Arsch aufgrund, ja, ja.
War einfach.
Und ich weine wirklich, wirklich selten, so.
Es gab einen Moment, da habe ich
wirklich ein paar Tage
geweint. Das war damals.
Das ist
nicht mehr so weit hin.
Und dann passiert so etwas,
dass alle Kanäle verschwinden.
Kriege richtig, ich
zitter innerlich, wenn ich darüber rede, weil das,
weil ich mich aber daran erinnere. Bestimmt
wollen viele wissen, aber wie haben die
Jungs denn geschafft, sich 172
Trojaner zu gönnen? Ja. Alter,
ich weiß es nicht.
Es ist, wir spekulieren
hier. Mal ganz davon abgesehen, wenn du
einen Trojaner hast, ist der Weg zu 172
nicht weit.
Logischerweise, ja. Also wenn du
einen hast, kannst du Sachen nachinstallieren.
Also wenn du den richtigen dir
eingefangen hast, dann kannst du Sachen nachinstallieren.
Also das ist eh egal. Einer reicht.
Es macht keinen Unterschied, ob einer
oder 172.
Vielleicht ein paar Ideen, aber die sind nicht von dir.
Das ist nicht based on
irgendeine Garantie hier, dass
klar ist, dass es daherkommt. Wir wissen auch nicht,
wann das Ganze passiert ist. So wie YouTube ja gesagt
hatte, kann das auch schon viel
früher passiert sein. Wir könnten uns schon viel
früher infiziert haben, aber die haben das
gerade jetzt, würde ich mir Gedanken machen, an seiner
Stelle, was, und haben sie
wahrscheinlich auch, was
hast du denn noch, oder was habt ihr noch
auf diesen Rechnern gemacht?
Wer war noch wo eingeloggt?
Ähm,
welche Passwortmanager
hab ich da drauf gehabt, vielleicht?
Und hab Dinge aus dem RAM abgegriffen
bekommen, also sprich, auf welche Sachen hat man
das noch? Ähm,
BB-Monitor, ich trau
der aktuellen
YouTube-Influencer-Geschichte
alles zu, aber in dem
Fall, ne, glaub ich nicht.
Zumal ein Kollege von mir, den ich ganz
gut kenne, der mCore,
ähm, auch CryptoScam
gehackt wurde
auf seinem Channel, und
ähm, das ist niemand, der
sowas faket, der hat mit YouTube auch gar nicht mehr
viel am Hut.
Ne, das ist kein Fake, das glaub ich in dem Fall
nicht. Zutrauen würd ich den ganzen
Influencer-Dudes, aber in dem Fall, ne,
das ist kein Fake.
... aktiviert, weil, wie gesagt, da
der Support der Plattform
immer am geringsten ist.
Ja, weiß ich nicht, das hätte,
vielleicht ist es letztes Jahr passiert.
Vielleicht ist es...
Ich würd mir jetzt echt Gedanken machen an ihrer Stelle, was hab ich noch
alles mit diesen Rechnern gemacht? Was hätte man
noch alles abgreifen können?
E-Mail-Accounts sind da
beispielsweise auch ein wunderbares Angriffsziel,
weil wenn du den eine,
wenn du den viel benutzten E-Mail-Account
Zugriff hast, kannst du bei ganz
vielen anderen Diensten wieder Passwort-Resets
machen.
... passiert, wo ich am PC war,
wie und wo, warum
auch immer, ich weiß es nicht.
Das nervt mich auch ein bisschen am meisten,
weil ich würde gerne wissen,
wo der Fehler liegt.
Das würde mich auch an seiner Stelle interessieren.
... sogar nochmal doppelt drauf achten,
was passiert.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Parallel haben wir noch alle PCs platt...
... Linux verwenden.
... platt gemacht, neu aufgesetzt,
weil wir halt auch ein bisschen Schiss hatten,
dass sich irgend so ein Trojaner Kack noch zwischen Daten versteckt.
Ja, kann durchaus sein.
Klar hab ich auch Dokumente,
Videos, Fotos
für die Ewigkeit verloren.
Ich meine, stellt euch mal vor,
ich sag euch, ihr habt jetzt fünf Minuten Zeit,
alles von zu Hause mitzunehmen, bevor gleich alles weg ist.
In der Eile werdet ihr auf jeden Fall...
... irgendwas vergessen.
Ihr werdet es erst merken, wenn es zu spät ist.
Am selben Tag haben wir sogar...
Hä?
... gerade mit YouTube Asia
und mit unserem Partnermanager von YouTube Germany,
also Marco, zusammen in...
Hä?
... in Calls oder...
Du hast doch nicht nur fünf Minuten Zeit,
du kannst den Stecker rausziehen aus dem Rechner
und alles speichern, was du willst.
Netzwerkstecker raus, gut ist?
The fuck?
Neuen Rechner kaufen,
im Zweifelsfall einen alten stehen lassen in der Ecke
und später Sachen sichern.
Oder anderen Rechner, ich meine,
er kennt noch genug Leute, aber das...
Ja, vielleicht...
Vielleicht ist der Gedankengang...
... anders gewesen, kann ja sein.
Weil der Case einfach so kompliziert ist
und immer mehr Last fällt auf meinen Rücken
und drückt mich noch tiefer in den Boden.
Ich war schon im Boden, ich wurde nur noch
reingedrückt und kam...
... unten wieder raus einfach.
Und dann kam
die geilste Nachricht ever.
Nicht
nur alle Videos sind weg,
sondern es wurden gerade sogar
zwei Kanäle von uns komplett
gelöscht. Und ich nur so
Boah...
Ja gut, das war jetzt irgendwelche YouTube Autodetection,
die festgestellt hat, Krypto-Scam oder sowas.
Und der Grund, warum die gelöscht wurden,
war ganz einfach.
Weil wir einfach die Richtlinien der Community Guidelines
Ja, genau, das dachte ich mir.
Krypto-Scam.
... Streams hochgeladen hat, so scammy
Links in die Videobeschreibung gepackt hat.
Genau, das war klar, das war irgendeine Autodetection.
Also das waren wir ja nicht mal.
Und trotzdem war das halt ein Verstoß
für das System von YouTube und deswegen
wurden die Kanäle einfach
aus dem System rausgenommen. Und wir so
Boah, Alter, das war wirklich
ein... das war ein Massaker, ein
Maschinengewehr von Bestrafungen.
Das wirklich auf...
Ja, ich kann es nicht oft genug sagen. Ich kann mich da
wirklich...
Ich kann mich da reinfühlen, ja, also
ich hatte auch schon Dinger.
Ähm...
Und natürlich nicht in diesem
Ausmaß, ja.
Und zum Glück bei mir nicht mit YouTube, nur mit
anderen Accounts, wo ich auch gedacht habe, ach du
Scheiße, Alter.
Ja, ist halt so. Ja, das ist...
Das ist kacke.
Es macht dich halt auch so fertig, weil das
unvorbereitet kommt. Du rechnest ja damit nicht.
Wie gesagt, also eines der härtesten Dinger war,
weiß ich noch, wo...
Wo ich mal in einem MMO gebannt wurde.
Das kannst du jetzt nicht wirklich mit einem
5-Millionen-Sub-YouTube-Account vergleichen, okay?
Aber ich mein, hey, in meinem Alter damals, ich hab da
tausende Stunden Spielzeit drinne gehabt,
wurde gebannt,
weil ich angeblich Leute beleidigt
hab im Chat.
Und, ähm...
Ich hab... Das hätte ich... Ich hätte durchaus
damals Leute beleidigen können im Chat, ja.
Aber ich habe
das nicht geschrieben.
Und, ähm...
Das... Da bin ich dann damals
draufgekommen, dass...
Ich hab meinen Account geshared damals.
Das war nicht das Problem, muss ich sagen.
Ich hab nicht das...
Sondern derjenige,
mit dem ich den Account geshared hab,
und nein, das war nicht der Friseur,
derjenige hat sich wohl irgendeinen
Scheiß auf seinem Rechner eingefangen.
Also sprich, es ist nicht so, als hätte der mich
gescamt,
sondern der war selbst so unfähig,
seinen Rechner zu... Also, der Typ damals,
dem ich den Account geshared hab, sicher
zu halten. Da hab ich... Also, da
hab ich auch mir echt...
fast in die Hose gemacht, so übertrieben
gesagt. Weil das war... Das war ein Account
damals für mich, das war so... Damals zu der
MMO-Zeit war das mit mein wichtigster
Lebensinhalt, ja. Ich hab
gekrindelt, kreiselt,
kreiselt, ich hatte tausende Spielstunden.
Und dann ist der Account einfach weg.
Da guckste... Nebenbei haben wir noch über
50.000 D-Abos gemacht, auf allen
Kanälen zusammen. Und...
Das ist halt... Ja, das ist halt schon schade, weil
das sind letztendlich dann auch sehr... Da sieht... Da sieht...
Das... Da bist du nicht der Einzige,
der sowas schon gemacht hat, hier.
Ich hab mal einem random Typ mein PSN... Also, ich hab
das nicht gemacht, aber ich... Ich kenne
Leute, die das gemacht haben, ja.
Ähm... Ich hab mal einem random Typ mein
PSN-Passwort gegeben, dass er mich MW2 auf
Prestige 9 hackt. Ich hab's
nie gemacht. Wahrscheinlich war ich schon einfach zu alt
auch zu dieser MW2-Zeit, aber ich kenne Leute,
die sowas gemacht haben. Und nicht nur
darin. Es gibt auch die...
Es gibt auch die China-Chinesen
Gold-Scammer, so nach
dem Motto, wir pushen deinen Account,
auf sonstwas. Ich kenne genug Leute,
die haben das gemacht. Gerade noch aus der MMO-Zeit.
Und fast alle haben...
Irgendwie...
Probleme damit gehabt.
Ich meine, du musst dir überlegen, die Leute,
die irgendwie so super shady Sachen machen
und schon anbieten,
warum sollten die vertrauenswürdig sein,
dein Account nicht
irgendwie zu scar... Das ist bescheuert,
ja.
...zuschauer und Fans
unserer Projekte gewesen, die dann doch so aktiv
waren, dass die, äh, den Abo fielen,
und dann gesehen haben...
Erstmal Elon Musk macht Krypto-Scams.
Was hab ich denn da abonniert? Ne, das hab ich nicht abonniert.
Deabonnieren. Also die dann quasi manuell sich entschieden
haben, unsere Kanäle zu deabonnieren,
weil die auf einmal so ein Scam-Video
da gesehen haben. Und das ist halt
schade, weil natürlich
erreiche ich mit diesem Video auch nicht diese Menschen
hier alle wieder. Doch. Klar, die kriegen das trotzdem
empfohlen und die sehen, er ist wieder da.
Also ich gehe davon aus, das wird sich relativ
schnell erholen. Würde mich wundern,
wenn nicht.
Aber die meisten... Und Leute, das wäre wieder
ein Moment gewesen, wo ich hätte weinen können, aber
dieses andere Weinen, dieses Vor-Glück-Weinen
war einfach, wie viele Menschen,
aber tausende von Menschen, täglich
mir geschrieben haben, wie
können wir dir helfen... Ich sag's mal ganz ehrlich,
mich hätt's genervt.
Die Leute können ja da eh nix ändern.
Es ist schön
zu sehen, dass man irgendwie Support hat, aber in dem Moment
hast du ganz andere Sorgen.
Und wahrscheinlich hätt's mich genervt.
Aber das ist bestimmt so eine Einstellung.
Wahrscheinlich hätt's mich genervt, weil mich noch zusätzlich
die Welt anschreiben. Und ich muss jedem 50 Mal
erklären, ja hier, sonst wie was passiert.
Ich hätte einfach nur
im Kopf gehabt, fuck, ich will
meinen Account wieder haben.
Die restliche Welt soll mich mal in Ruhe lassen.
... ihre Hilfe angeboten haben,
gesagt haben, mach einen neuen Kanal, wir abonnieren
sofort, die teilweise mitgefiebert
haben, dass diese Videos irgendwie wieder
online kommen, die geweint haben
teilweise. Es ist unglaublich... Ja gut, bei den Leuten weißt du
nicht Bescheid... Tausende von Mails in
jeden Verteiler... Also die Leute da wirklich lost.
... an ganz viele Leute, die irgendwie
in Verbindung mit mir zusammen waren, haben Mails
bekommen. Ich hab sogar bei Tinder
ein Match
bekommen, die gesagt hat, ey, ich wünsch
euch viel Glück rein mit den Hauptvideos.
Also was das für Wege geschlungen hat, das Ganze. Ich hab auch selten...
Da wird erstmal auf Tinder weitergewischt,
bis Julien Bam kommt, um
ihm dann zu schreiben, hoffentlich kriegst
du deinen Channel wieder.
Also, wenn das nicht
die krasseste Suma-Geschichte aller
Zeiten ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Wahnsinn.
... über
eine halbe Million Storyviews
auf jeder Instagram-Story für
so eine lange Zeit
und das war einfach krass zu sehen, wie
viele Menschen einfach so
bei uns waren.
Moment, muss der sich nicht auch
matchen, dass das funktioniert?
Hat er in der Zeit auch mal nebenbei Tinder-Mädels
gescrollt, oder? So krass hab ich diese
Community irgendwie noch nie gefühlt, oder
in dieser Art hab ich die Community noch nie gefühlt und deswegen
wollte ich an der Stelle auch einfach mal...
Packt meine Accounts weg, erst mal Tinder auf.
... sagen. Ja. Kommen wir noch mal
zurück zum Thema und den auch darauffolgenden
Tagen. Das einzige, was uns übrig geblieben war,
war der Julien Bam-Kanal.
Ohne ein einziges Video halt, ne?
Und ohne Profilbild, ohne
Banner, ohne jegliche Funktion von
YouTube, aber mit über
fünf Millionen Abonnenten. Ein toter
Kanal mit über fünf Millionen Abonnenten. Ja, YouTube kann
den Kram ja zum Glück geklaut haben, oder? Aber vor allem
auch ohne AdSense-Konto. Und ihr
müsst wissen, diese Firma finanziert
sich durch natürlich Werbedeals,
aber halt auch durch Werbeeinnahmen, die durch die
Videos generiert werden. Und das geht
nur, wenn es ein AdSense-Konto
gibt. Aber das wurde komplett von uns
abgekoppelt.
Es wurde weggeladen von uns. Es ist weg.
Ja. Abgekapselt
worden, weil wir ja auch gegen die Richtlinie der
Community-Lightlines gestoßen haben. Wer ist das Chat? Wer ist das von euch?
Oh nein!
Wer ist das?
Weil diese Kanäle wurden ja gelöscht.
Das heißt, eine unendliche Leere
umkreiste mich die letzten
Tage und...
Wer ist das von euch?
Alter, was ist mit Google los?
Also, wir müssen irgendwie so hijacking-bezogene Formulare
ausfüllen, damit wir denen garantieren können, dass
wir nicht selber diese
Scam-Streams hochgeladen haben auf unseren
Kanälen oder diese Scam-Links in die
Videobeschreibung gepackt hatten unter den Streams.
Alter, ich glaube, mein Browser ist RIP, Leute.
Aber ich glaube, es ist nochmal einfach eine rechtliche Sache.
Okay, ich glaube, wir haben es wieder.
Ich glaube, mein Browser ist richtig F.
Mein Browser ist richtig F.
Okay, geht wieder. Nice.
Ist wieder alles da, oder?
Ja.
Ich glaube, den Rest vom Video müssen wir nicht
gucken, oder? Ich meine, er hat seinen Account wieder.
Das ist gut.
Außer der Schock. Der Schock ist bestimmt immer noch da.
Und ich bin mir sicher,
der wird sich jetzt an vielen Stellen
doppelt Gedanken machen.
Bei solchen
Security-Themen. Da bin ich
mir sicher. Die Frage ist nur, wie lange es hält.
Das geht schon.
Negativ-Beispiel-Screenshot.
Brauchen wir wieder. Das ist wohl wichtig.
Wohl richtig. Richtig
und wichtig, wie ich diese Redewendung
verfolgen muss.
So, Leute. Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Vier Stunden. Ich wollte heute Abend hier eigentlich
LabelChamp weiter streamen.
Du bist übrigens die Default-Schriftart im LabelChamp
mittlerweile.
Ich weiß, es waren einige Fragen und so noch
im Chat übrig. Leider habe ich
meinen Browser neu gestartet, weil er abgekackt ist.
Und hab die jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich könnte... Moment.
Ich gucke mal in mein... Ha!
Wir haben doch hier das Streamer-Dashboard.
Das ist doch für sowas da.
Schauen wir mal in das Streamer-Dashboard.
Ad...
Wubblos.
Der Fahrstuhl. Ne, der Fahrstuhl ist nicht mehr da.
Ok, ich scroll mal kurz
schnell durch.
Gut, das bezieht sich jetzt auf das Video.
Antivirus-Programme noch sinnvoll.
Naja, solange du den
Windows Defender hast.
Jetzt wird er
noch reactet hier.
So muss das machen. Der hat das Youtube-Game
langsamer noch drauf.
Ähm...
Wo haben wir denn hier jetzt stehen geblieben?
Heute Abend streamen? Ja, Nachmittag wahrscheinlich wieder.
Nochmal.
Mal gucken.
Ne, das hat sich alles aufs Video bezogen.
Ich glaube, ich hab nix, nix übersehen.
Ok, Leute. Dann geh ich jetzt
was essen. Wir sehen uns.
Bis denn.
Tja, wenn der Kieler Junge mal am startet.
Mit dem würde ich tatsächlich was aufnehmen.
Wir sehen uns. Bis denn. See you.